all right it says we're live it's
happened it's time now we should just
update the thumbnails
this should be the thumbnail from now on
yes if you can hear us you know what to
do you know that's the key you know you
knew this was coming pete you got to let
us know tell us if you can hear us down
below
where's that chat
it says we have 600 people in here right
now where's my snare can you see us can
you hear us can you see us can you hear
us can you see his word to your mother
this is the most i've talked so far
today absolutely all right looks like
we're live heck yeah we're live john can
you put the chat in the center sure
so guys um i gotta ask what did you all
think of spider-man no way
did it suck as much as everyone said
yeah was it as disappointing as you
thought it would be this whole time
where's all them [ __ ] who were like
you're going to feel so
bad when you see toby maguire and andrew
garfield
yeah they're not they're definitely not
in it [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
that's what we actually come here to
talk about spoilers
or the movie nah it's just about about
putting it to everybody who uh who
doubted us so maria hammond got us this
shout out to this cardboard cutout
of uh spider-man
and uh it's pretty dope so koi was
supposed to be in here with us i gotta
get this out of the way right away koi
was supposed to be here with us he has
been feeling pretty under the weather
and we you know it's the only thing to
determine what's going on there so it
was like yep it's it's best you stay
home and probably rest up
not to be in this room right that's
about it so sorry he can't be here right
now and we'll do our best to compensate
for him so this livestream's gonna be 30
minutes long yes absolutely absolutely
go to his uh social media and send him
some love
let's shout some people out really quick
before we just start hopping into this
yeah eric
who's always in our comments christian
torres drake
amazing movie cried multiple times i did
cry three times and yes i would say that
too even knowing leaks cheeky yt
surprisingly uh did not affect my
experience i was i was exceptionally
moved in fact i was a little bit on edge
like what if this doesn't come true
what if toby and andrew did yeah
yeah big part of me what's a little bit
like
videos
all that speculation and all that
putting it on the line if i'm sure
they're definitely in it that was uh
that was a major relief for us i'm so
happy to see everyone here and i'm just
so relieved that this movie is actually
pretty great
i know it's the the hot thing to do is
do your spoiler talk on the weekend but
you know we wanted to give everyone
enough time to watch it over the weekend
and also to watch it several times is
that yeah how many of you guys john
let's put out a poll before we get into
it all right
uh we're gonna put out a quick poll
uh we've seen the movie three times and
that's about that's exactly the poll
that we were about to
to say right here uh john's getting this
poll ready
get it going john we're gonna ask you
guys in the chat right now
um here you need me to type it for you
john you don't have to do everything by
yourself
if there's one thing we learned from
toby and andrew is that you can't do
everything by yourself you got to learn
to work as a team and you need
validation well if you don't need my
help don't [ __ ] ask for it all right
what are we pulling here how many uh how
many times have you guys seen it
waiting waiting waiting
you know us we take a while to to warm
up here just the once twice at a at a
option for three i know a couple people
seen it four times
yeah we did see it three times we
watched it at the premiere
and then we watched it um the second
time at a smaller screening a smaller
band screening and then we watched it uh
the third time we wanted to make sure to
go opening night as much as it was gonna
affect our our schedule we had tickets a
theater it was like an hour away uh but
we were like we have to watch this
opening night with a crowd and
definitely the cause the real people
crowd the premier crowd had fans for
sure but we wanted to like the people
who bought their tickets had to wait
online forever to get their tickets as
well we wanted to see it with them yeah
um and share in that experience and i i
feel like the premier crowd was easily
the one that was like the loudest
throughout but opening night crowd
definitely had some of my most favorite
moments yeah uh in terms of how they
reacted to things throughout especially
like when andrew garfield does save mj
that was easily the biggest reaction was
opening night crowd oh yeah and i think
the ones that were most surprised when
they saw toby it was a weird experience
because i hate when people are on their
phones in the theaters i [ __ ] hate it
i really really do
um
but
there was a moment where i saw someone a
little bit ahead of me who when toby and
andrew came up with such a shock she
whipped out her phone and had to start
recording the crowd uh or her screen to
capture the audience reaction yeah so
one part of my brain went what a rude
ass [ __ ] the other part of my brain
went i should do this i am one of the
people who watches audience reactions on
youtube so
let her do it for now
and part of me then was like yeah i
usually hate that too but i was like but
maybe i want to immortalize this moment
because you know we'll never forget the
first time we saw them screen together
you know and definitely couldn't do that
at the premiere what's the pull out
right now what did you guys vote 62
percent have seen it one time so far 29
have been two times and then 6
and four percent for three and four or
more per uh respectively hold on my
cousin's uh my cousin's uh messaging me
huh
hey jess your baby's so cute i'm
literally just started a live stream on
youtube right
now spoilers the baby is cute about 700
people here right now
my cousin just had a baby
[Laughter]
so uh
yeah send some love
i will call you back yes your cu your
baby is absolutely beautiful
bye
uh yeah all right guys yeah i cli i mean
all of us clapped oh yeah it was it was
uh it was easily the most uh vocal i've
been in a theater it's weird i think
this was the one that really saved
this oh totally i've heard that with a
lot of films this year but i'm like not
spider-man that was the one that really
made it feel like we are back at the
theaters yeah because there are no
asterisks with this and then with the
performance over the weekend being so
astronomically like third highest
grossing opening weekend movie of all
time
yeah that's i feel like even the ones
that have done really well have had some
kind of well the pandemic kind of a
qualifier but yeah this is this is the
return and yeah it made me feel like a
kid that way like when people people say
that a lot but this was a movie that did
that where i got swept up in the wonder
and i was like cheering and laughing and
crying and and you know just transported
the way you want to be by movie magic
true so
oh we're 1k viewers right now that's
cool hey
thank you if you guys would hit that
like button that would be super super
duper stellar
all right guys um look we had we had so
many super we usually wait like 30
minutes to get to get there this is
let's get them um uh let's let's let's
start kicking them off right now so we
don't fall too behind here because we
often end up being like two hours behind
on our super chats and i feel bad every
time
because we usually take a half hour to
get to them all right and then we end up
also like talk because there's there's
things to talk about guys why don't you
guys leave your criticisms in the in the
chat too because normally what happens
in these streams this is your first time
here is we kind of riff off of what you
guys are talking about here specifically
leave the most obvious details we all
knew about that were also in the
trailers that aren't spoilers whatsoever
yes yes anything and everything is on
the table today see that person's saying
that in portugal they had a pretty quiet
theater
and um
like they're generally pretty quiet so
then to have an experience
john yeah show her password right on the
live stream
you know it's luckily it's dots why'd
you just move it over here to the screen
for a second at a second
you got it john thank you this is you
you see john's worried face well because
i checked the super chats four times
before we started and now it's doing
this
panicking yeah uh some mistakes aren't
suffered lightly
that's right man always in a state of of
of nervous tension
always in a state of oh god it's just
really just
the situation and this is making me feel
so much better too what i do man i know
you break the tension with panic with
your humor as you like about it so i'm
just gonna make fun of you all right
where are we at that's good
that's my friendship with everyone i
often get criticized for not being
sensitive enough to
people's plights i don't know about that
all righty all righty uh i got you gonna
enlarge this risk of screwing everything
else up
all right is electro a plot hole or not
i don't know i see some people justify
like it's not a plot hole
i think with any fandom
there's always a base with any fandom
that kind of treats their franchise like
it's impenetrable
and uh that could be a little
frustrating because i love the marvel
cinematic universe and i especially love
this movie and spider-man is usually
like the out of the marvel franchises
these are the one i know the most
so uh but i don't think it's impervious
you know yeah
but let's see what we got here right now
all right remember bulldog thank you so
much for the super chats the soups chat
you know soup should do more live
streams he called them supes chat soups
chat
why isn't he doing this
matt ramos doing that morocco
when tick tock goes live
no home
was fantastic my favorite spider-man
movie
oh that's good to hear remember oh new
poll new poll remember you have inspired
the new poll all righty all right okay
so most people have seen but let's put
that poll on screen really fast all
right
[Music]
i have to downsize it
you got this john i believe in you man
i did that with a smile on my face god
damn it
how many times have you seen no way home
okay most people have seen it just the
one time that's understandable it's a
long movie it's a packed eater it was
hard to get tickets props to the four
percent though awesome that's right four
percent all right john now maxum now now
blow up everything again
and and uh
can't get it back on track all right new
poll you got a new poll we got we got a
new poll coming in new poll coming in
all right what is it i forgot the
question what were we talking about
before that whole little bit we had
about you freaking out over it being
minimized
uh something really important is
something really important i forgot the
very memorable you guys happen to
remember what we were just talking about
uh oh oh where uh is where
is this your favorite spider-man movie
that's the one
you got it john
there was one guy laughing and clapping
on his own that's
i wish that person was there i had a
hard time actually getting emotional i
was like wow this is a really great
scene at the ant-made death scene
um
but there was some woman who like a few
rose behind us
who was
uncontrollably sobbing like it was uh
it was like you know we had a full
theater
it's one of those things where where
part of you or at least part of me is
like okay i i don't want to
you know have like some of all these
options
yeah it's the fun of it very considerate
i love fun of it that's the [ __ ] you
black and white answers man i love that
you gotta take advantage of the options
that they give you uh uh it's all
engagement but yeah i i feel like
there's a line where or especially at a
movie like that because the same thing
happened at end game where there was
somebody dressed as spider-man in the
row like one or two ahead of us and when
peter got dusted they were sobbing
so loud and
uncontrollably that it's one of those
things where i'm like okay we're all
here at the premiere so
fan anybody can have the reaction they
want to have and i don't want to take
that away from them however
this is kind of a lot it's kind of like
very noticeable and sort of distracting
yeah because i'm uh i mean i cr like the
second time i watched it i i just cried
like non-stop in the second half uh
right around at me right when aunt may
said with great power comes great
responsibility or the the actual way she
said it um and then like the scenes
preceding it that were war and tears i
was like really sobbing a lot
but when we saw it at the premiere there
was one person who was like doing that
um
just like flat out sobbing it was it was
overpowering the audio of the movie and
yeah like now most of my attention's on
is this is she okay yeah she's gonna
like like have a break a mental
breakdown right now well more so than an
endgame i was like okay maybe maybe they
lost like an aunt or a parent figure or
something to where this is i could see
in spider-man no way home
more so it being like oh i can very much
relate to this because somebody in my
family may be past or whatever but yeah
without the context you're like
okay we're all into it you know
make the amazing spider-man oh i forgot
to say we are we're totally live i
haven't done any social media what's the
next question i'm so sorry it's okay um
yo pinoy pride people if you are
filipino put it down in the chat jacob
battle lawn it's funny one of the
questions i wanted to ask jacob was
about how can we never see your parents
or your family and then in this movie
you see i was remember when we had like
three questions to maybe ask that was
one of the questions and then in this
movie like oh you see it and you even
get like a magic history with him yeah
you get lola all right here we go olivia
d14 thanks for the question i love that
name olivia
would you rather have toby spider-man 4
or the amazing spider-man 3 in all
sincerity
after watching this movie and especially
what they sort of allude to
uh it's like the the spider-man 4 is the
one prior to watching no way home is the
one i easily champion for really wanted
hated how we have like one of the best
spider-man movies in my opinion
spider-man 2 and then you get one of the
absolute worst spider-man movies of
spider-man 3 in my opinion
and i've always wanted to see sam raimi
go out on a true high note with what he
wanted to do for spider-man forward if
you guys have seen like the concept art
that leaked from the artist uh when he
was developing the film with sam raimi
it looked like it was going to be a
little bit more violent along the lines
of the fight scenes that we actually got
in no way home so i really wanted that
but after this movie
the amazing spider-man 3 they alluded to
things here that i was like man that
that sounds like it would have been a
really cool movie just watching peter
have to struggle with his rage
and his grief as he's proceeding with
trying to continue to be spider-man oh
yeah that sounds it's exceptionally more
interesting to me
yeah and i mean that sounds also like a
really natural like you know the first
tasman even the psychotasm has a lot of
anguish for peter to go to and i mean
especially watching that first movie i
forgot how much dysfunction there is in
his relationship to his family and
everything so you had to watch that
rageful peter for an actual movie and
see where that could go like see where
the cautionary tale yeah like oh you
already have with great power comes a
great responsibility but now there's a
greater grief that has sort of entered
the center of your consciousness and and
what does that look like and i feel like
we've seen that and we're going to see
that more with batman because especially
the batman looks like a guy who's like
kind of flying off the handle a little
bit sure and uh and yeah i could
definitely imagine that with andrew
garfield i mean i i'm all for a dark
take i wonder if if it might be a little
too dark for some folks but i i would
love to see that oh no i'd love to see
it too i'm just trying to take this
photo for twitter guys i didn't do that
that social media post let's do this
let's go let's go i mean you could
retweet the real rejects one
what are you talking about
and personal absolutely it is no you
should do that we live right we live
get it get in here
oh wait wait wait hold on guys guys
smile on camera for us everyone smile
type a type an ascii smiley face hit the
photo button
you got it john
that is not an appealing photo that is
the most appealing photo that we could
have possibly taken and while you post
that i'm going to read the next super
chat thank you uh bat
play hello hello from the philippines oh
yeah pinoy pride baby hello
i miss your live stream in the
philippines i'm so sorry but thank you
for contributing and i hope you get to
see the replay if you're not here any
longer i got to tell jacob battle on
about don't delay no way home ph and
then i realized it would actually be the
antithesis of me clipping that and
posting it on twitter
if he's like stay off social media and
then here i am putting out a post
in the same somebody in the philippines
is on social media needs to know to get
the fudge off
very true
we we do what we can thank you so much
though about gear
todd andrew hey greg and john love your
vids do you see a scenario where
andrew's peter is in the venomverse and
toms is in the mcu in the future no way
home is fire uh yeah i think so because
you know whenever we talk about it it
really seems like the venom verse
belongs in the andrew garfield universe
it seems like it would be more suited
yeah i mean like tonally aesthetically
like the cinematography of amazing
spider-man
is better than any of the venom movies
but it lines up like color wise that
that blue
lines up better with venom and what
we've seen from the morbius trailer thus
far so i totally think it would
absolutely
but then that that morbius trailer is
just confusing the [ __ ] out of me you
know
uh like what is going on there the fact
that they have
uh the the oscorp building there they
have the toby spider-man there then they
got vulture there and then no way home
establishes there's no oscorp in the mcu
so it's not the nbcu what is going on
here
what is venom exists here though
is this just a completely alternate
universe
that seems to be the only explanation i
can think of is that this is just
another again another universe where the
the face of vulture is michael keaton as
well i guess yeah i mean i nailed this
when i when i set this up pre-starting
live stream and now i'm having a hard
time getting this guy there it's okay
you gotta see all right that's all you
had to do that's all you had to do
you're so good baby you're so good yo
people we are live on youtube talking
spiderman no way home social media type
of personality right here that's
right captain levi thank you so much for
the super sticker uh definitely hold on
let me blow this up a little bit more
just ruin every now actually i'm not
gonna do it actually i am i said i'm
gonna do it so i'm gonna do it do it
john and we're gonna scroll all the way
back down
two new members you got this john there
we go there we go look at all these
lovely little stackers
but where's the one i was headed to
i saw cosmic wonders name we should skip
everyone we should we favor other
youtubers everyone
all right there we go
this is so
don't panic john i am not don't panic
proceed with confidence i have a big old
smile on my face there we go look at
that captain levi
thanks for the support everybody
adorable sticker and then madonna
forever
thank you thank you so much you rock i
think that's what those fists say most
likely most one would would assume this
is from november 17th oh my goodness
that was the wrong live stream here
i think the don't panic john
i think don't panic the thumbnails are
glitching a little bit it happens man
you [ __ ] up now's the time to panic
it's okay go ahead let it panic let
people you would be more relatable if
you panicked on a live stream this is
actually increasing my level of stress
this commentary is going to clip people
would clip it i can feel the microscope
i would get so much canceled for being
the worst friend ever nah they don't
care and then people will be like nah
man john should have manned up
on the computer
it's so strange i don't know what's
happening with these thumbnails but okay
uh shadow skull game we're back in
action willem dafoe thank you shadow
skull and willem dafoe was menacing he
was already my favorite raimi villain
but now he's my favorite mcu villain
gave me heath ledger's joker vibes yeah
that's something we commented on
especially if you watched our video
where we talked about our favorite
scenes
it uh it hit it only hit me on the third
viewing when i was like oh there's
something real joke or dark night [ __ ]
happen here
was when he um
uh
the i mean a the the sense of control
that he has over the situation and kind
of the tone established with him when he
is getting punched in the face and he's
just laughing at spider-man
just similar to how you know joker
eliminates rachel hoping to give birth
to you know batman giving in to his dark
side hit me same thing with spider-man
he's trying to like push him like you're
what is the line that he says maybe you
got can you can you put this poll away
john
um please
that's how i really talked to john in
real life
yeah
that's the truth um but no the the uh
the the the uh
what is the quote you guys what is the
exact quote where he says like you're
too when he's saying like you're two i
know i understand the ideology of you're
really strong
send me home to die that's the one yeah
that you're john
uh yeah that that moment um was very
joker s to me killing rachel uh killing
killing anime seemed like similar to
killing rachel it seemed like he wanted
spider-man to kill him just so he would
win by spider-man having killed him you
know what i mean yeah it's like i will
have won because i've corrupted you
beyond repair exactly and i think that
would have and that does feel very
joker-like so thanks for that that
comment there shadow skull game
absolutely
matteo something of a scientist myself
you know what i loved about the way
william to [ __ ] is a couple of you guys
brought up in the live stream just now
um yeah we read the live streams as much
as people think we don't uh the subway
someone uh someone pulled that out and
what i loved about his delivery there
was it felt natural and not a wink even
though it it's written like a wink like
the line is clearly put in there as a
wink but the way he delivers it felt so
natural and he doesn't like redo the
same delivery that he did yeah in the
first one it's like it's something he
says yeah when the moment arises yeah
yeah yeah yeah sylvester fryson also
added on to that you're struggling
that's struggling to choose line
matteo diavino
hey guys this is now my favorite
superhero movie of all time good to know
thank you for the super chat hell yeah
also obviously toby and andrew were the
highlights but
can we all agree andrew stole the show
and appreciate this amazing redemption
what i appreciate is i feel like the
appreciation for andrew garfield has
come around absolutely truly
i think his performance was kind of um
overshadowed by
the lackluster response to the amazing
spider-man when it came out
and
upon re-watch of the franchise uh like i
rewatched all them so john before we
watched uh spider-man no way home
and i was actually incredibly surprised
by how in love i was with the amazing
spider-man
and how much i liked the amazing
spider-man 2.
that surprised me especially the amazing
spider-man 2 and and it's in a large
part of it is due to the character study
of andrew garfield's portrayal there and
he actually shot to be before watching
no way home i was like i think andrew
garfield is actually my favorite
portrayal of live-action spider-man
and um
i really think i mean we've talked about
this quite a bit behind behind the
scenes is that i think andrew garfield
his movie just came out too soon
i know a lot of people liked it still
there are a lot of people like instantly
liked it but i think due to the fact
that it was only a couple years after
spider-man 3 we weren't used to this
whole constant reboot thing that was
going on everywhere
and a lot of people were expecting a
spider-man 4 when they announced the
spider-man 4 they didn't do a spider-man
4 then just rebooted it
i just think there's a lot clouding uh
people's ability to really accept this
new direction and i feel like honestly
if that movie had come out like
10 years later versus a the time when it
did come out it probably would have been
easier to accept the film yeah yeah and
so i think andrew garfield uh like
in my opinion i actually find toby and
andrew equal in no way home because part
of what makes andrew's performance shine
is the way he bounces specifically off
of uh toby maguire so i think like they
both play the right levels to make both
of themselves shine yeah so i actually
found them both a little bit equal there
and uh but yeah i'm just happy that
andrew garfield is truly getting love
yeah absolutely and i mean i think too
it's partly the timing with that movie
being so soon after the raimi films you
know everyone still attached those but
also i think it it
because he was the second
you know there were other spiderman on
screen before toby maguire but for a lot
of people toby maguires were like the
definitive adapt adaptations begin and
so i feel like andrew garfield had the
misfortune of being you know the second
guy to do it and so you're gonna get all
the comparisons and you're gonna get
both those from comic fans as well as
people who are just really dedicated to
those toby maguire movies and now i feel
like since we have three peters parker
to look at it's easier now to appreciate
what's different about them and
appreciate you know the the darker
flavors that that come out of the andrew
garfield movies very true
but i think uh when the three of them
are together he does he like he's just
he's so naturally funny and he's
i love his sense of wonder well and i
think that's why he shines so much
amongst them yes like we saw him be so
[ __ ] depressed
those other ones that it seems like he
has a sense of joy in that
in this one
and that's why i love watching him so
much here
because he he really seemed happy to be
around everyone and um and i do love his
sense of wonder when he like shows up
like toby maguire is like
yeah i'm here you know i gotta feel like
i gotta help but i'm like that's kind of
how toby's would respond i'm thinking
like that's his thing for a day i've
adjusted
yeah yeah he's got more of just like an
earnest like okay yeah observe what's
around me
all right let's move on here captain j10
my theater just clapped both times i saw
it
you captain j10 for that and yeah no it
was applause from beginning to end
throughout and it was cool watching with
a smaller crowd
when because normally like a crowd of
that size of like 30 to 40 people that
normally doesn't get much of a reaction
but to see like everyone was still like
clapping and stuff yeah
it's a little weirder at first but it
also feels more personal yeah
yeah yeah and that's part of the fun of
it that's part of the human experience
jb bonafassio really quick john can you
imagine uh hiding that poll just from
our viewers perspective so i want to be
able to see the live stream chat as it's
going thank you for watching for so long
sir quang uh please continue john all
right uh jb bonificio bonifacio sorry
it's totally plausible that peter lives
in the same apartment complex as grylls
spider-man in hawkeye episode six
hashtag believe actually that's i've
never heard that that's a really good
theory i haven't heard the girl's
connection i feel like that is a solid
theory and i feel like too i mean you
know the the very end of the movie
uh you see him you know swinging uh over
it's it's it's uh you know the the
christmas tree in the ice skating rink
rockefeller center and uh and so
you know
part of me really doesn't expect him to
show up but the other part is like what
if he is swinging
at the very end of this movie into
hawkeye episode six you know he saves
the day
yeah exactly
you know and then hawkeye can help it'll
be good all right oh yeah povent meyer
hey guys
what do you hope they do with spider-man
4 uh plot villain wise that's a great
question
i
think it i mean it's what i'm really
hoping for because obviously with the
post-credits scene they tease
uh the the symbiote which by the way
that postcard seems bizarre that is a
weird it takes such a different shift
every time i've seen it in the theaters
like no one's really like
a lot of people are like huh people
laugh when they first see him
and no one's really
a lot of times people aren't really like
hey nieces a lot of people a lot of
times people aren't really uh
even laughing at the venom jokes that
are going on yeah
and then he goes away and i'm like okay
i guess he just showed up to leave
yeah yeah he got here you don't want to
stay at the party to be removed
immediately yeah
and but then with the black suit that's
something i've talked extensively about
on this channel is what i really want is
for them to
explore
the dark like and they is because
especially the fact that you see in this
movie the dramatic heft that tom holland
has and if you've seen tom hall and do
other movies uh even like something is
popular on netflix devil all the time
you can see this dude can go into dark
places yeah and i feel like black suit
symbiote that would be something really
cool to explore as like watch although
it might have been more effective if his
relationships were still intact and you
watch him start to destroy those
relationships due to being affected by
the symbiote
um
but that's mainly the the thing i want
to not not like let's hurry up and get
that's a [ __ ] venom and fighting
spider-man but watch him dancing yeah
really give
that's when you should bring back toby
again yes
i've been here don't do it don't do it
yeah yeah
um yeah that would be that would be cool
to just see um i want to see more of
that just really a hardcore character
study of him villain wise i mean i'm not
sure i keep one of the [ __ ] scorpions
coming back i know they teased him
forever again
yeah so we just put her up in the chat
scorpion people are saying should be
scorpion someone's saying scorpion
absolutely kung fu hot dog is sad what a
great day merry christmas i started off
uh all the cheers at my first greeting
for no way home seeing charlie and my
spider boys two men was fan service done
right
uh tasm three yes please that's right
charlie cox was probably the most uh
fan we won't forget about the the stream
labs we're just getting the first round
of the of the super chats done reversed
um yeah the the uh the the uh when
charlie cox showed up that scene felt
the most like
a fan service thing because it could
have been any lawyer yeah yeah it really
could have been any lawyer
needed to have this conversation anyway
but it's beautiful fan service it's a
great way to make you excited to see and
and it teases the possibility of
daredevil and spider-man like not not
matt murdock as lawyer charlie cox i
mean reverse that but
daredevil and spider-man being able to
maybe fight together and knowing that
kingpin is going to be in hawkeye at
least
his presence so far has been there yeah
um but at kingpin being in hawkeye the
idea of spider-man and daredevil
actually it would be pretty sweet if
they put daredevil in spider-man 4. that
means so many tickets and if and then
that would be a a team up that is
motivated by the comics and that people
would be really excited for and maybe
that could exist in a way where they're
sort of peers more than oh we got
another mentor right when we ditched all
the mentors you know that would be
pretty sweet but yeah like to have them
be doing you know
ground but above ground level crime
fighting in new york like that would be
yeah and then very peter becomes a
hardcore catholic yes and they always
they're just always at church talking to
priests about their problems yeah
you hurt
spidey's back uh my back yeah uh choto
you haven't seen netflix's daredevil
it's amazing you gotta watch it yeah
what are you doing with your life
i mean no i think murdock was only there
like i said it was more of like a fan
service confirmation like it's gonna be
my it's gonna be charlie cox returning
as daredevil that was a cool way to do
it we have an opportunity for a lawyer
let's use him
i did
i've seen it three times and maybe you
guys can clarify this for me
why
how computer was able to get off like it
seemed like he why don't the charges
stick yeah like it stuck pretty well
like what i really loved is you watch
the consequences of what's happening to
those around him
and that's what motivates him mainly to
make a decision to go to doctor strange
i think that's more peter parker-esque
is like my friends are suffering from
this my family's suffering i need to
change this whereas like if he's getting
you know the one who's the only one
suffering i don't think he'd be so
motivated to change it
and so i like the consequences of that
but it did make me question like how how
did you get off like so easily
yeah and then why if you got off so
easily why then do happy and may need to
lawyer
because like no yeah they get the whole
child endangerment thing she's a really
good lawyer calvin yeah
but not good enough to deal with the
more normal circumstances that he's
gonna yeah that was a bit uh uh of an
interesting one to me because i'm like
isn't spider-man being charged with like
murdering somebody with a bunch of
drones wasn't
was there not evidence that he did
commit the murder because based off of
the footage though cause that's what
people are saying hey geo what's up
buddy yo yo
because there are people uh yeah cause
isn't there i thought in the
i mean i'm actually not remember what
the footage look like clearly right now
but i thought the footage showed that he
killed mysterio that's how it looked was
it not clear like oh you could clearly
see it like it was the argument that it
was manipulated
maybe i mean which i feel like you can
prove that
yeah i mean they have you know digital
forensics now so so that would be i mean
i guess my mind then says in my head can
and i'm like whoa but quentin beck had
to be like so brilliant at it you know
because he's a super villain so he would
probably get past anybody the police
have working on the case but
you never know
okay so apparently there was a court
scene they were going to cut out some
people are assuming that they just they
figured the footage was doctored i mean
yeah we know it's doctored so i i can
jump to the conclusion that they figured
it out
knowing the fact that quentin beck came
from stark industries maybe someone in
stark was able to figure out like yeah
it was doctored yeah and you know
starting to have the best lawyer happy
would probably be so there's a lot of
conclusions i could jump to yeah i just
wish the movie just had something you
know yeah video can't legally be
authenticated i don't know law
you're telling me
thanks for being first time here ash
anyway absolutely and kung fu hot dog uh
thank you for the follow-up you guys
will hit one million next year and
deserve it thank you for that shutting
the channel down right day we do at 999
999 subscribers we're shutting down yeah
once we hit a million it's downhill
that's all we've ever lived for
all right thank you
olivier hamelin uh hey guys a big fan
uh thank you for the super chat by the
way give the extensive and great
coverage you've done for this what are
your feelings knowing this journey is
coming to an end and what are you most
excited for next
nothing literally nothing i have nothing
to live for excite me now i have no yeah
all the all of it has been blown on this
it was bittersweet uh
when it was ending you know you get so
caught up in the
it because it's been such a unique
um ride to to this movie being released
yeah that
you know i'm so glad it's good you get
such a unique ride to the movie coming
out and you know like is this true is
this true what is what's really gonna
happen what if this doesn't actually
happen
uh and okay if it is there is it gonna
be too much is it going to be over
convoluted will they do it right it's
just going to feel fan service you know
like there's so much
speculation plot leaks a lot that is did
not come true uh and a lot that did
and so to get to this point uh
you know what i'll tell you
that i did not think
would happen
it seemed like when you're hearing
this multiverse collision
the collider
you're hearing this multi plus you're
hearing this multiverse collision
and
and then you know you're like okay if
toby and andrew are in it like how could
you possibly get bigger yeah how could
you possibly get better go smaller and
then when it had the ending which never
i never once read we never heard any
leak we never heard anything about
they're gonna wipe peter parker away and
he's gonna have to start completely on
his own from scratch
and the great sacrifice he makes
not once did we hear about that and then
when we when i saw that ending
and knowing the position he's in
it got me
that much more excited for the neck i'm
literally getting nipple chills as i'm
talking about it
it got me that much more excited for the
future of spider-man i thought like
after this i'm like how could you
possibly get excited again really
this is like the end-all be-all right
here you know
and then then when it ended i was like
wow i can't like that was tom holland's
best performance
he was
gripping his health people have been
talking in the chat what who is hey
connie's here uh people have been
talking in the chat
what is like who had the best
performance and as much as i love toby
and andrew i i do think tom holland had
the best performance in this movie and
yeah it wouldn't work if he didn't
yeah it's like this is his film yeah he
had the best performance in this movie
and where they set up his character and
it's such a unique position because
we've never seen peter parker that much
on his own before never in andrew
garfield's never in toby's he literally
doesn't have a parent he has no role
model whatsoever nothing nobody knows
him nobody and he has to do this all on
his own and it's such a unique position
for him to be in and after watching the
character growth and the trajectory of
his version of peter parker i'm
exceptionally excited to see what they
do with the future spider-man movies and
if they can keep it more in tone with
like the last half of this movie then i
don't know i feel like we're in for a
solid ass ride yeah
yeah well that was the thing i was most
surprised because yeah this has been an
insane experience and and i in the
lead-up i feel like you know we've
experienced or i've experienced kind of
every angle of like oh my god this
sounds crazy oh my god i'm so excited oh
my god i'm kind of sick of talking about
this and it's not even out yet oh my god
i'm getting excited again oh my god it's
almost here and uh and yeah
it got me excited for something that is
smaller theoretically than what the
movie itself is doing and i like that it
got me excited to see just tom holland's
peter parker go be on his own and be
spider-man
and you know
do that like it's funny like for as much
excitement as there was about like we're
getting all these characters together it
got me excited for just him out on his
own yeah and the journey that that could
be because yeah like you said there it's
we've seen you know this is like an
origin story like it's the truth it's a
three movie or yeah it's like a secret
origin story
yeah
and and it makes the previous films at
least in concept to me
you know work better even though there
are things about the uh
homecoming and far from home that i
don't love so much it at least makes
them feel very motivated but yeah
at this point like i would
you know my mind goes two directions i'm
like well part of you has to top it
right there's got to be some kind of
yeah you've got to team up with
daredevil or something like that but
also part of me is like but maybe we
could just do like a straight
spider-man movie where it's a peter
parker story and it only has to be about
this one peter parker and it doesn't
have to be about a million other things
converging like i feel like as much as
that doesn't sound as exciting on paper
i feel like you you often are doing
something in reaction to what you put
out in the past and i feel like that
would be an interesting thing to do here
because no way home was such a
multiversal event i feel like trying to
replicate that
feeling and flavor would maybe be a bit
of a treacherous prospect yeah but yeah
i think so too i mean i think far from
home and no way home have the best
endings of any spider-man movie because
they get you so excited for follow-ups
yeah um
though it would really quick
uh thank you green octadon that's a
really nice comment so thank you thank
you very much
um
all right what do you uh all right karma
hey you know we will take a second to
talk about something because i've been
seeing more people
mention some of the things about like
how does the spell work exactly we'll
talk about that in a second that's kind
of a spell word carmine we got two here
um thank you carmine
hey guys what do you think the future of
tom speeder parker is uh do you think mj
and neb will find a way back into his
life that is a fascinating question
without taking away from his sacrifice
or maybe they introduced gwen and harry
uh by the way saw no way home with kim
kardashian and pete davidson in my
feeders saturday in a staten island
that's incredible crazy we live in a
simulation how the [ __ ] does pete
davidson get all these like i'm the last
woman that you just gotta be like uh
she's a lanky child like
you know slacker guy
apparently he's like super hot or
something i feel like there is a type
and it's like that where it's like how
does this guy yeah
and i think whenever he gets like a hot
girl that just makes other people
that just makes him more desirable yeah
yeah it's just like he just keeps piling
up this attraction every generation has
a p davidson
giving like sarcastic slackers
everywhere hope
that they too could live in a judd
apatow movie um
but yeah i mean we talked about i think
the one thing i'll add on to that is i i
feel like this
i really want mj and ned to especially
mj but yeah i i i they they set you up
on their own where they could be like
off on their own mj and ned and this
could just be spider-man story but i do
think mj and ned have to come back into
the fold
doctor who has a companion that's what
like they are but they also set up ned
which admittedly every time i've watched
it i'm like
where the [ __ ] did this come from this
whole thing with him having magic like
it's so
just this movie
like if there was at least a hint at it
in the other one
there's one hint that would have
alleviated a lot of it but i'm not
really hyper fixated on it because i'm
when i'm watching the movie yeah it's
more it's there are things about this
movie that
don't bother me in the moment of
watching it but more like when i when i
think about it after i'm done watching
it and
the ned thing is like
we had to like trim some of this movie
down so let's let's give him some magic
abilities just to speed up some of these
plot points one we had to have a
surprise to distract you from how we're
gonna actually orchestrate the one thing
everybody wants the most yeah and that's
that is a funny thing about this movie
is because i do have like sitting here
now i'm like i love this movie i do feel
like a love toward it uh but it is
it's interesting to see a movie like
this that does so many things right and
has like yeah pretty easy to pick out
like flaws and plot holes and little
questions that make you wonder about the
logic but it's a testament i think to
the fact that they really focused in on
the most important things to get right
getting those as right as possible yeah
you could you could get really hung up
on the flaws or the things that you
might personally consider floss
um or you can kind of that's that's kind
of what i do when i watch the movie i
just bounce i just i look at like what's
out what out ways the experience for me
and so i'm like is it these little
things here
or is it um yeah
the the actual things we should make a
rule here that if a comment really
stands out we're allowed to interrupt
each other to point it out sure because
we've got so many comments coming in
oh someone did point out in the chat
about uh like how come toby's spidey
sense didn't go off when green goblin
stabbed him oh yeah that would be yeah
that's a great question a great question
spidey sense unreliable
david blonde david blonde thank you
david i was oh please go ahead i was
moved by andrew garfield's emotional uh
emotionality after saving mj and
character beats peter three
peter three uh any thoughts about him
coming back on a more regular basis they
should just do a toby and andrew
spin-off movie
spider-man
yeah i that would be lovely i mean i
would i would watch i'll buy that for a
dollar i'll watch that all day every day
out of all of them i mean obviously
tom's going to continue but it seemed
like
toby
could go home and that's kind of the
wrap-up that we have for him but but
andrew garfield seems like
i don't imagine that they would do a
tasm three and i say that lightly
because you know i didn't imagine they
would do a multiverse crossover like
this uh but i i can imagine him being
uh pulled back into the to the fray
sooner than later uh yeah and i'm glad
because it seemed like the one who had
the most
um toxic breakup with sony who was
andrew garfield so to see him back works
worked on multiple levels yeah because
it's like oh i guess they're good with
each other yeah right goodness yeah
jonas diaz uh but that i mean we got to
talk about that scene a little bit yeah
oh sorry no no we made a rule you were
interrupting what were you gonna say uh
jonas diaz just asked what's your
favorite shot from the movie and there
is one specific shot that comes directly
to mind which is when you when they do
the spidey sense on peter when norman's
having his change in the condo yeah and
it's just that really long
nauseating crush zoom like that that i
think is my cuz it's we've been waiting
for a long time for these particular
movies to do the spider sense with
justice and i think that was a beautiful
cinematic choice and they never once
called it spider-sense no just tingles
peter tingle yeah i got the tingle yeah
um
that moment the the second time i
watched the scene when andrew garfield
saved mj
uh i i think what's great about that is
a lot of us predicted that that would be
this the case and yet it worked so
exceptionally well and i i think
it it got me like oh my god you know you
get so many phone calls what is why why
would warren just call me right now how
how rude he just wants attention yeah
you shouldn't answer and get that clip
how badly do you want attention warren
i want to be on the live stream
he just wants to be on the line we'll
get you a third mic
i i don't know how to we don't know how
to do that thing where we plug people in
and then we're going to slow down this
whole live stream to plug people in yeah
here hold on
hold on a second hold on i'm just going
to facetime you super you're totally
interrupting
hey he's driving so you don't actually
want me in the live stream you dick yeah
how are you going to live stream from
the car
okay
i mean we look
well [ __ ] we we should do it we should
do a a we should team up and do a live
stream
[Laughter]
you guys are you guys should take this
bit on the road
all right
all right you got it buddy thanks for
calling
goodbye
yeah you did it man way to go
lucky caller number five
amigos
this live stream is not brought to you
by the cosmic wonder i know what he with
that i missed that guy yeah when that
happened like i actually didn't notice
it the first time because i was so
caught up in the excitement that he
saved him yeah because because when you
when you're with a crowd that is losing
their [ __ ] it could feel like
everything's moving so fast sometimes
and when he saved uh her i didn't notice
that he was crying the first time i
watched it oh yeah and so the second
time i watched it when he was crying i
started to cry yes because it was like
wow he probably thought about for years
what he could have done to save gwen
stacy yeah like really shows in that
performance and i really love that
andrew garfield he
he [ __ ] showed up
he showed the [ __ ] up he showed up to
perform and not out shine he showed up
to get tasman three three yeah he was
like i was like damn this dude is fully
committed he it doesn't feel both i
think for both toby and andrew it it
doesn't feel like we're here for a
paycheck no they feel like they were
back into character but they took it
seriously they got back into character
there was a sense of respect and that
they i mean at least
more on andrew's side just because of
what he got to do with his performance
but that he felt honored to do it
all right cool cool
yeah valentine productions good call in
the astral projection shot too with the
spider sense
uh db mind studios hey hey uh thank you
thank you so much when andrew caught mj
i got chills and everyone in my theater
clapped if you didn't watch our reaction
rockstars breakdown opening night crowd
best one for that scene because oh yeah
they it was like
it was the they reacted to every beat
yeah
everything every every beat you wanted
to share in a big crowd reaction for you
got that it's like the crowd didn't
watch the trailer yes and i think
because aunt may died it lent itself to
the possibility that mj could die yes so
i think that's why like oh [ __ ] deaths
are like or toby
could die yeah yeah when toby get
stabbed like their their moments are
like they could actually die because
they killed off aunt may we've never
seen that in a spider-man franchise so
it does increase the stakes that much
more
and so when mj fell
the first time we watched uh opening
night crowd
everyone just gasped it was so funny
it's so funny just like your third time
watching it and you just know what's
gonna happen in the movie and you're
just listening to the crowd uh
and and like everyone guessed that
andrew then tobe uh [ __ ] goddamn the
third one so tom leaped yeah
tom holland leaped and when and then
when tom holland leaped everyone started
cheering
and then when he got hit by the glider
everyone went oh
yeah and then andrew leaved it
it was like every single emotion on
every beat was just coming out of the
crowd at maximum force and uh i loved it
that to me when i think back on opening
night i think back to that moment every
single time it was that reaction right
there where the crowd just reacted to
every single beat oh yeah that's great
because because weird the open dance
crowd wasn't that audible through the
first half of that movie like there was
like certain moments like doc shows up
big applause
charlie cox charlie cox yeah but but for
a lot of it uh
not not as much as like the other times
we've seen it but then with that scene
everyone was like
like you could tell they were so gripped
by what was happening yeah
you know so i love that and marissa tome
knocked it out of the park best best
delivery and best scene nothing given
about great power comes great
responsibility in any of the live-action
films oh yeah and i and i just love that
that uh detail that eric vos pointed out
in the new rockstars breakdown of how
andrew
gr he actually grabs her and cradles her
in the fall and doesn't go for the
thwhip yeah to you know mitigate the the
whiplash effect they should do a
post-credits scene where it says
meanwhile another universe he does and
then mj snaps her back
we should just see every universe where
this happened and she died that's that's
his absolute point
and then he just starts killing everyone
and he snaps yes marvin martin
uh choosing to cure rather than kill the
mentally ill about time more of this
please hollywood also i recommend
scientifically accurate spider-man
the the the corridor crew video right i
gotta watch that i haven't seen that yet
uh yeah that was a that was a great
choice it does
i do think the pacing was a little bit
affected by that moment but i really
think this is where i'll get a chance to
say some some criticism
is that
uh
after seeing this three times i'm pretty
confident how i feel about this
particular subject
like doc ock shows up it's really
exciting it's great it's a grand
entrance right and i really love the
electro entrance and then it's even
exciting when sandman shows up it's
exciting when they're all showing up
but i i i was a little i don't find it
that gripping or the writing that
interesting of the villains hanging out
with each other
that there's something about their
dialogue exchange that just wasn't that
exciting to me or or or even it doesn't
have to be exciting but
interesting or compelling a lot of it
was like point and catch you up on
background or exposition yeah and it
reminded me of a comic book more so that
way yeah like a crossover where they're
pointing out like here's what happened
in the previous issues yeah yeah exactly
yeah but uh and i think like you like
you need to do that obviously especially
for those who didn't know about or
haven't seen those movies there's a lot
of movies from like 20 years ago you
know there's a lot so it's like i get
the necessity to do that
at the same time though um i i was i
didn't find the interaction all that
exciting and like with doc ock too it
was weird like i i think doc ock is um
i think alfred molina is great in the
role because he's a [ __ ] alpha molina
and he's a damn fine actor
but i i did it i started feeling like
his character started becoming like
two-dimensional in the in the sense of
he brought the depth but he was kind of
just like angry and complaining which i
get due to the circumstances he was in
but i was kind of missing some of the
nuance like it was interesting how they
managed to layer
green goblin more make him more nuanced
and flush him out and make him better
than what he did in the first spider-man
movie
but uh doc ock
kind of had like a
similar arc in a way when you think
about it yeah angry possessed by the you
know the tentacles and then the
tentacles get fixed and he comes back to
oh no i'm a good person yeah yeah yeah
well i mean and that's spider-man is
filled with scientists who go and get
themselves jacked up by their own
creations only to then have to be
somehow you know cured by spider-man i
also didn't okay i really i didn't care
i actually like jamie foxx what they i
like the intention of max a lot in
amazing spider-man 2 and i actually
really like the time square scene with
max an amazing spider-man 2. i think
that like there's i felt really bad for
him in that scene he's just this
misunderstood guy who doesn't know
what's happening to him and in here i
was like this jamie foxx didn't seem at
all like the max that
we knew at all yeah
and i'm bringing this up on this
question for a reason and like jamie
foxx didn't seem at all like the max
that
was from the amazing spider-man 2. i was
like i get it if he was kind of putting
up a little bit of a front or kind of
supposed to laugh at him because he
thinks he's all tough but he did seem
like
jamie foxx essentially and you know if
i'm not mistaken doesn't he have like
some level of like engineer or science
background in amazing spiderman too and
there was this line there when he says
like and i don't know how you guys take
this line but he says
those are legos like kind of in a
condescending way to tom holland when
he's working on the uh chess piece for
him
and the way he said in a condescending
way rubbed me the wrong way because i
was like that doesn't seem like what max
would say i feel like he'd actually be
interested in the science of this or
interested in understanding what this is
instead of just being cool guy jamie
foxx and so i felt like he was more
interest i thought he was actually more
interesting in the ma and i know a lot
of people prefer him but i actually
thought that he was
um
less interesting this time around he
kind of just seemed like a generic dude
to me
and sandman like
i didn't i don't know what it is a
behind the scenes choice for this of why
they had to do it because i noticed
thomasin church doesn't talk at all when
he's in human form yeah um so i don't
know why
he they chose to make him sand the whole
time and i've did it like his motivation
was just like i want to get out of here
i want to go back home you know it
wasn't that interesting lizard they were
like yeah there were some complaints
about his portrayal in amazing
spider-man one so we're gonna really
even make it worse and just make it make
it more one-dimensional
so with that i did find the choice on
this question of peter parker making the
choice to scientifically cure them
instead
really in tune with peter parker and i
love the idea of watching him do more
science and like so i love a lot about
that and i do find it necessary for the
film
i just thought like a lot of attention
in the first half was given to the
villains interacting especially leading
up to the sequence and i didn't find the
dynamics between the villains all that
appealing to watch and i thought like
that should have been as much of a
highlight or at least close to a
highlight of watching the spider-man
interact with each other you're watching
villains
you're watching villains crossover
interact with each other and i felt like
you should have watched it that should
have also been interesting even like doc
ock and
and angering and norman yeah that should
have i really thought that should have
been like really dynamic yeah i i would
agree it's it's funny because yeah i
liked what everybody brought for the
most part to their performances of the
ones who get to you know be performances
and not only cg effects uh but yeah it
felt like that stuff was kind of
underwritten or underdeveloped and then
i feel like with villains is where you
can have the most sort of
nitpicks and and questions about things
and yeah like with max it's like you
know even when amazing spider-man 2 came
out i didn't hate that character and i
liked seeing jamie foxx play such a
character and something a little more
kooky and a little more akin to a comic
book uh and yeah it it it's like i could
feel echoes of max but especially
because he doesn't even like fully
revert
when he was pauses for a second lizard
and sandman were cgi because of covetous
scheduling conflicts i think
they voiced their roles at least aided
insane okay that makes sense i mean it's
kind of that's what i was saying like it
might be a behind-the-scenes thing but
then which made them feel like a little
like unnecessary to be in the movie
especially
yeah especially when andrew because
there's no stakes with lizard either
when andrew garfield was like yeah i
could do it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
which i mean which i think is funny for
his character
yeah but yeah for lizard and the whole
thing with like him waiting in the van
and i'm like why is he king shark in
this
what reason is there it seems like kurt
connors would also even in lizard form
be interested perhaps in the science of
all this or something i actually weirdly
i might disagree with you on that one
one beat i made sense to me he was
staying behind because he didn't believe
at all
and he i thought he took it as this
would be
a step backwards to cure it because as
lizard form he views this as a superior
form so he's team goblin before goblin
yes essentially
when he's in lizard form
that is god form to him yeah so the idea
of changing this is not appealing to him
that makes sense um that makes sense so
i i understand that
yeah
that part i got yeah that's the only
part i got
well yeah and that
like it's it's the movie isn't lacking
hugely for it but that is kind of a
bummer is like you know uh yeah he shows
up and doesn't nothing really gets added
to the character and nothing really
interesting
happens although i i gotta say i i do to
get off that because we can talk about
like the specific villains all day long
but i really did admire that what the
movie came down to and what the big
ending fight came down to was not an
intended fight it is just yeah we got to
cure all these people we got to get
these macguffins security
yeah we got to cure some ass we gotta we
gotta get these mcguffins to their
counterparts and we gotta you know save
everybody this way and i was just like
yeah on principle that's a great call
like i love that because you know we're
gonna get some punching and kicking and
swinging and all that junk but yeah like
the point and having it be the choice
that we have to do that i thought was
was quite uh unique and powerful yeah
plot mechanism was great let's can we
check on the stream labs again really
quick just because uh i know there's
been people who've been donating there
too and i want to make sure we
we uh get to that you got this john i
believe in you buddy all righty
you got this all righty all righty
today's date is 12 20. yes
it might be some from 12 19. yeah let's
go to 12 19. so
yeah okay
uh dan v the plan to cure all the
villains we have uh streamlabs here open
too the planet cured all the villains
was a nice idea except for doc hawk he
will be back to the moment to take out
the reactor hey yeah that's true
that's true
back up
oh i'm going to die
he was pulled out when he has a tentacle
around peter's throat before he was
redeemed toby be like don't ask
questions throw that [ __ ] thing in
the river um
go up please
and toby said his relationship is
complicated after asking andrew if he
had somebody made things work with mj
give me amazing spiderman through
garfield the hearty venomverse if they
need to connect in the spider girl phone
with dunce and toby as mayday's parents
uh yeah i mean all all those ideas sound
good but yeah you're right about the doc
ock thing right am i something wrong
because like as i understand the whole
thing with um you know like i think uh
loki really establishes the rules really
well
cause i've heard that brought up like
what happens to them like does our
movies just get undone like no i mean it
creates like a different timeline yeah
like they're like those movies still
happen they've died already on the
original timeline but yeah there's a new
timeline yeah yeah exactly so like that
that makes sense to me um but with doc
ock he would still return to the moment
right wouldn't he still return he would
have to destroy it seems
why the fusion reactor the fusion
reactor would have to uh destroy the
fusion reactor at some point or he goes
back to his world and the fusion reactor
has destroyed manhattan yeah like does
it
that that yeah because then max is gonna
zap back to being
just inside electricity so he's gonna
get cooked and then you know norman
we don't really know where in time he
was plucked from but one could assume
i mean he doesn't he's got the mask on
so part of me feels like it's before the
fight in the big you know
broken down building
but either way it does seem like sending
them back will
kill at least a couple of them yeah yeah
yeah or necessitate some kind of
horrible sacrifice
we got to watch matrix resurrections
today so we should be sharp
so with the villains of raymie and
destin thank you so with the villains of
raymie and webb's universe cured what
exactly do you think that means for
those movies oh we just answered that
question so we can't go ahead uh are
there events retconned or alternate
universes created does nothing change or
does it suggest a possible spider-man 4
amazing spider-man 3
spiderman four hey we're hanging out
we're all buds now and then then and
then all the villains are gonna help
spiderman fight the new villain in town
no and it'll be super easy i really
loki establishes the timelines and so
this would create a separate timeline
the moods would still be intact yeah
branch timelines from literally each
spider-man movie now
you gotta factor in everything from
everything to understand everything and
then that well i guess it's still you
know i think that's just going to stay
on the floor
uh
it it makes you wonder all kinds of
things especially too because you only
get one spider-man from each of those
dimensions
and we don't really have a good read on
when they are plucked out of their
universes
so uh
yeah the whole question about who
returns and how is very fascinating to
me and i
i don't know if it makes any sense yes
hi this is my first donation well thank
you so much appreciate that
celebration
i kind of like toby versus the lizard
how did you guys feel about i got a
question for you guys in the live stream
be curious to know if
i on my third viewing this became more
clear
in the final fight of the statue of
liberty how did you feel about the let's
let's i think the highlights of the
fight are are these isolated moments of
them interacting the three spider-men
toby and like when they're when they're
running together when they're swinging
together
those like little shots
make for grand moments right yes
but the fight choreography itself i
didn't find all that intrigue like the
actual fighting
i didn't find all that interesting um
like it's exciting the first two times i
watched it because i'm like [ __ ]
there we're doing this
yeah but then the third time i watched i
was like oh you know i actually prefer
like the green goblin fights and the
fight with doc hawk on the bridge and
the doctor's franchise like i think
those are all better than the final
fight yeah they're more striking and
they're more
i don't really remember fight moments
from the final fight is what i'm saying
yeah you don't really remember like
actual fighting stuff you remember the
splash page moment yeah i'm landing on
the statue of liberty and yeah yeah and
i mean
i don't begrudge the movie that it's
funny yeah it's like i remember the set
piece and there's not really like an
action moment it's more just like this
the stakes and the circumstances that i
remember so yeah that's a good point i
didn't really understand the electro
power in the end what made it so
different with the arc reactor but
whatever uh flood doran stay flevy
so many feelings on one hand it was a
great movie full of everything you want
on the other hand i get a little
headache trying to figure out what all
this means for the continuities the mcu
in previous spidey films this is some
end game level mind boggle i mean if the
movie's just acknowledged loki this
would be less confusing
yeah
tva was just to poke their heads in and
be like hey guys your universe is [ __ ]
up i mean there's been two t's people
bringing up miles in the chat room
there's been two teases for miles so far
yep
it's coming
uh let's get going up and then they're
gonna cut to jamie foxx just with a tear
rolling down his cheek it was a lot of
football with the cures is guaranteed in
that final fight
i love that
yeah yeah yeah it really is
uh
that's a good way to put it the combat
of the fight yeah it's a great yeah
the actual fight choreo what's up guys
so happy we can finally talk about this
movie winter soldier in my favorite mcu
movie oh happy to hear that pj but no
way home jumped it uh swung over it i
thought this movie had a lot of heart
emotion and surprises is it does he have
more or is that it okay uh i also
thought it was the funniest mcu movie um
you know i've heard koi said that i
don't want to share that sentiment for
this i thought it was thor ragnarok uh
it was
hands down my favorite theater
experience for any movie is one of the
best theater experiences i've ever had
easily uh my favorite performance in the
movie were from tom holland willem dafoe
and andrew garfield no one's been citing
toby
he's understated and i think it's easy
for him to be overshadowed
yeah but i thought he did exactly what
toby would do
no 100 and i gotta say though that that
was i mean i was overjoyed from the
first time but the second and third
viewings was when the three of their
chemistry really clicked and made sense
to me whereas the first time i was like
man andrew garfield is really here
uh but yeah so you have more and then my
favorite lines were norman's on
sabbatical honey and
you're going you're going into battle
dressed as a youth pastor that was a
great life very i didn't it sounded
almost [ __ ] improvised yeah yeah like
i think there's some hilarious moments
in here but i i don't think this is the
funniest mcu movie but lb said she
laughed so [ __ ] hard in this movie
hello lb it's good to see you good to
see you um
i was so excited to see charlie cox and
i cannot wait to see multiverse of
madness and imax that movie already
looks visually stunning have yet to
catch this movie in imax that's the last
viewing that i'll have for this movie in
the theaters when we go do there your
brother said it was the best way to see
it really he saw it yes
uh pandemic but he didn't say it was
actually the best he said they didn't
really utilize the imax very much that's
my brother for you yeah
who walks away with the criticism
who were you guys favorite performances
and what were some of your favorite
lines
oh it's great question yeah as far as
they haven't talked about our favorite
lines yet no
sorry about all the messages i think you
might have got our favorite lines this
movie just got me so excited i felt
every emotion i laughed i cried it was
so good much love guys i'm done now i
think well thank you pj i really
appreciate that buddy uh favorite
performances are easily tom holland and
willem dafoe uh followed closely by
andrew garfield in this movie but and
toby mcguire i'm going to throw him in
there i think so
because i feel like andrew garfield and
tubby are like i don't think andre's
performance would have worked as well if
it didn't have the right balance of
chemistry with toby since a lot of they
put they pair them up a lot and a lot of
andrew's highlights
are from his
back and forth with toby yeah you know
um and from the sage wisdom yeah yeah
like that that interaction between them
about the web what the web block and
then like
toby saying like hey
you're amazing yeah like that was you
need to acknowledge that was a great
self-talk
that scene made me really happy and i
would definitely say like we did a video
talk about our favorite scenes and i do
wish i just kind of tack that on at the
end because
they have like such great back and forth
and you can't just you can't just make
that happen in editing yeah like you
could tell that they're especially with
the way they overlap with each other yes
it felt like they had three locked off
shots yeah they were three different
cameras and then they edited that yeah
because their chemistry really feels
like that like the the way they interact
with each other is so natural
and um
like to me i'm like toby shined a lot in
that scene
that was a scene where i thought toby
was great and and i love the the scene
with toby too
when he
like like the um like while andrew has
the more like bigger moments between him
and toby when he is talking with tom
holland on the roof of the of the school
uh i think toby like i like the aged up
wise version of him who's like you know
like like really connective and takes is
really serious
uh and a really great i think that's one
thing that toby does really well he's a
great listener uh uh in his performances
and so i like that scene a lot from him
it's just
this is the one you got to pay a little
more attention to to get the nuance
or has andrew just go a more motive
or like naturally expressive yeah where
toby's always been more internal you
know
so yeah
you named all our favorite lines uh for
the most part i'm gonna i'm gonna name
one moment there's not so much there is
a line but what tickles me is when ned
goes do you think there are other ned
leeds's he sits down at the computer to
look it up
which i think is hilarious which which
i'm the only person who laughed at all
three times i i liked that what he said
i pro this is like and i promise i'm not
going to turn into it i'll try to kill
you to kill you in a smaller crowd that
line actually works the best yeah
because you could you really just feel
the awkwardness of like tom holland just
look at him for a long time like where's
this coming from you you're the previous
yeah you didn't hear toby give his spiel
so he's like what the hell are you
talking about
i'm a really good lawyer
yeah we talked about a lecture earlier
um yeah i like his line about hating the
woods that got me
that made me laugh i want to point out
what lb said here about underrated tom
acting moment the final scene in the
coffee shop because oh yeah that moment
is such great like that that rests on
the actors yeah in so many ways like
they could have done a zoom in on the
band-aid on her head but you know like
john watts calls attention to it before
the memory wipe where he's like oh
you're hurt and she's like i'm okay and
then brings it back and then the way
you could feel peter parker because
when he is going to the bridge to talk
to mit lady she says you didn't prepare
that speech did you
and then when he's going to talk to mj
he's prepared a speech yeah yes and then
with a prepared speech you see in his
performance that he decides right then
and there after seeing the the wound on
her head and how she's been healing and
how her life is looking better that i'm
not going to
i'm not i like i'm not gonna tell her
like any you could feel the heartbreak
but also the bitter sweetness and the
choice of him really determining i'm
gonna let go now yeah and unless so you
could live your best life that is a
really well acted moment like seriously
i think tom holland is the best one in
this movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely you can you can see the
decisions behind his eyes being made
back and forth yeah
hitman hudson
why'd you put this down i tried to put
it up and that only made it worse
we had it right one time
you had it right one time give yourself
some credit you're amazing you're
amazing greg hitman hudson
no way home was amazing i wish they had
done more with risa funds though
we do too if it feels uh it feels like
he was just kind of there uh is this
because he's probably the least well
known of the villain actors y'all are
one uh y'all are
close personal friends with kevin you
tell me lol
uh
yeah i have no id truth be told i have
no idea why i was like that because i
feel like kurt conner's the lizard is
you know a notable spider-man villain
and i mean even if people aren't the
most familiar for risa fonz isn't the
most common household name i still feel
like
you should write that character to be a
character
yeah you know how like green goblin has
that line in there of like these are not
curses these are gifts
i think dr connors
based off of what we got an amazing
spider-man one
would have had a great monologue to
contribute in that moment yeah or some
form of that ideology
to contribute based off of his character
an amazing spider-man one where everyone
was viewing him as a monster but he
viewed what he was doing as the cure for
humanity
and so i was like there's a level of
pathos and depth here that they could
have brought with lizard in no way home
but
they didn't
yeah
but but i but i also know the lizard
response is not very uh well received uh
generally just for that for that one
movie it's not well received and i don't
dislike him in that movie even but i
feel like yeah it would have paid to
play off that because in this movie he
is pretty much just a monster who
occasionally has a funny line
yeah and and i feel like that kind of
betrays that character a little bit
because yeah he's he's not a monster and
you could have made something
interesting is that rhys stephan's voice
acting him
i don't think it was it it sounded like
a british cartoon
what was this yeah cause going back you
like is he doesn't sound like that he
looks
better in amazing spider-man by far yeah
he's like disheveled in this movie which
i mean makes sense i suppose but at the
same time yeah i'm gonna make this [ __ ]
work please hear what it takes here take
it away and i'll read starkiller three
four eight two nine regardless hold on a
second starkiller that is incredibly
generous of you thank you so much oh
[ __ ] that's a big one thank you dude i
think it would have been awesome if
spider-man talked about some of the
villains they fought after we last saw
them instead of the villains they fought
in their last movie i was that's a great
call starkiller i was hoping that we
would hear about like i fought a russian
guy i thought a guy with wings called
the vulture yeah then tom hall gonna be
like i've got one of those
yeah like that would have been does he
have a big metal suit i don't know he's
like an actual vulture
that that would have been really cool
like if they pulled from the spider-man
4 yeah or like uh
or uh yeah do something like that or
like because even andrew put it just
like siding killer uh exciting rhino
when i'm like what are you talking about
yeah freaking green goblin at the end
yeah i actually think there was a
there'd be a more interesting movie
if they had dayton to han instead of
sandman and lizard sure because then you
would have the son of green goblin and
like you see that
the uh willem dafoe's norman osborne
does care about harry
where as
chris cooper's norman osborne and
amazing spider-man 2 is just the coldest
dude it just seems like he really has no
affection whatsoever at all before dane
dahan and dana han like you see why he
craves and desires it so much as he just
doesn't have an ounce of it yeah and
he's like morphed into a freaking
monster so it would i think there could
have been like some weird interesting
dynamic where because norman's like i
don't have harry here my son that he has
a harry and that harry doesn't have a
father and son to see what happens to a
different alternate hair which happens
to his hairy but even still he could
have been a pop goblet yeah
yeah that would have been interesting
yeah for sure
poor danahon
that's the next spider-verse movie is
everyone who wasn't in this movie yeah
that's the team up then iron fist shows
up
oh hitman hudson
also can i get the peter parker spell on
me but instead of everyone forgetting my
entire uh uh forgetting me entirely
everyone forgets how cringe i was in the
middle in middle and high school
know any sorcerers who can help me hey
if i knew one i i would be on top of
this spell right now no regrets man no
regrets those that's part of what made
you who you are today i admire that
those when i watch movies that are about
like oh i've been transported to the
past i could do over
yeah i uh do so many things like that
where would you go if you could go
anywhere in time seventh grade seventh
grade
all my life regrets stem from seventh
grade king dingling king dingling this
movie had so much to live up and
exceeded all my expectations
it really did live up to a lot yeah this
really could have been the movie that
doesn't live
up yeah
tom holland range was unreal but
garfield stole the movie see i'm
wondering
here's here's honestly what i'm
wondering because a lot of people are
saying that it was fan service on so
many levels of fan service done right i
love this movie so much uh can you
scroll up and see if he has more usually
on stream labs we got to kind of double
check okay um
i'm wondering because it's like there's
such an enthusiasm and an excitement
when garfield shows up yeah
i'm wondering like when you guys watch
it at home
like on your third time
will you guys still think he's the best
part of the movie i'm not i'm not saying
this is downplay him he's [ __ ]
phenomenal in the movie all right
without saying that it's just it can be
really easy to be caught up in crowd
excitement and like he's [ __ ] bad
looking you know and and to think he to
go there
um that that can overshadow just taking
it in it's like really watching it with
a with a smaller crowd the second time
was was like a very different experience
or you're just able to take in the film
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and not
the crowd as much so
it is it is uh interesting so i'm
wondering like if that'll still be the
case yeah bottom line is please keep
celebrating the excitement of andrew
garfield absolutely i don't want to
downplay that at all well i feel like
wonder i feel like he he has the most
fun stuff tied to his character
especially of the spider-man and this i
did watch it at home and he's amazing
well done
i'm not saying he's not amazing i'm not
i'm just asking will he definitely still
be the considered the the one who was
the best performer
and stole the show that's just the
question not a not a like i'm here to
prove something to you guys
yeah
um
well all right caleb
and the thank you again king dingaling
caleb
one of my favorite and by far the most
surprising moments of the film was when
i interrupt
ultra fan premium did you guys notice
the uh miles morales reference by
elektro
oh yeah
now we went what
[ __ ] world would a black spider-man
not my spider
no
he's up there i thought we already had
this conversation in culture peter's
white and that's that three of them god
damn it yeah what more proof did you
need
the white spider-man
of course we noticed man i can't wait
for freaking miles to come in yeah and
that was a lovely scene we can't wait
for us to come in and inspire verses
still might be the best spider-man movie
man i can't wait all righty
one of my favorite and by far the most
surprising moment of the film
was when they didn't undercut the
responsibility lined with a joke
it was one of the only earnest moments
from these movies and i loved it that
was the turning point for the movie uh i
gotta ask there were people who um
said
that uh
i was gonna say
jeremy johns he said that there were
scenes that were undercut by jokes
i never felt that with this one i know
that's an mcu problem often
but i can't think of a scene where i'm
like
that would have had some real tension if
you didn't try to make it all funny also
i can't i couldn't recall a scene where
that happened yeah because i was always
feeling the tension and the and the
balancing act of everything that was
going on in this sort of fragility of
just the entire circumstance at hand and
so yeah there there never really felt
like a moment where the humor was
inappropriately placed like there are
jokes
that feel more like oh that's a marvel
joke and then there are other humorous
moments that feel like they came out of
the characters in this scene you know
what beat was weird as [ __ ] to me oh
which one
in the trailer was like call me strange
all right still call me stephen
and he's like okay stephen and there's a
beat and then he goes
okay that feels a little bit weird but
i'll allow it
but in the in the movie it just like cut
out that whole pause yeah it is like
it's immediately it's like it's like
calm don't call me call me stephen okay
stephen that feels weird
every time i watch it i'm like what
happened to that beat in the trailer it
works so much better with the beat
well it's weird because you look back
now and you're like the trailer it's
like his dialogue is all edited but it's
mostly in order so it's like they they
worked to create pauses where there were
none for the trailer a lot on dr strange
yeah so yeah i don't know that is a bit
of a funky uh beat there or lack thereof
in the actual movie
all right goo please tongue punch fart
box our man the most fun person to do
patreon today shout outs for tpfb this
movie far exceeded my expectations where
do you hope to see holland spidey go
from here who do you want to see as the
next villain do you want one reprisal is
the official gg or do you want an
entirely new actor love you guys
okay we've talked about some of this so
far i would say okay the question of the
most unique one would have to be willem
tour prices roll uh
gosh you know uh
i gotta i don't know i it's like
no i wouldn't want him to because he
they [ __ ]
he finished his arc and maybe can go
home and be a guy again there's no oz
corp
in the mcu though so i feel like they're
done with green goblin it seems like or
or or he was the he was the like the
movie starts off like doc ock is gonna
be the villain but no it's it's goblin
for sure
and i mean they could still certainly
bring osborne's and ozcorp into the mcu
but i feel like that'll be a longer play
and i feel like yeah bringing back the
green goblin having him be truly the
villain that riles the other villains
uh to the extent that he does it does
seem like yeah you put a stamp on it so
maybe not in the next movie or two
should we see another green goblin very
soon but yeah i mean they'll definitely
come back to it at some point all right
but yeah willem defoe i think especially
and he's also getting older so i i feel
like he has put his stamp on the
character now let's run it back to the
take that rewind to bet i did think that
scooby uh you want to okay yeah let's
pick up from the left thoughts
[ __ ] i didn't think the scooby doo this
[ __ ] line works better especially
because it's like the i knew they were
going to do that there was a there was a
the first in in the trailer when he says
let scooby do this crap it's a close-up
on him when he says it or that that side
profile yeah whereas when he says the
scooby-doo this crap it's a the camera
is flying away it's wide so it works
better on the punching on the second one
a little a little comedy editing that's
right to make it better yeah
um here we go uh
cosmiccom1
after end game if i told y'all that we
would get toby and andrew spiderman mcu
but tom would you believe it or think it
sounds
to be ridiculous there was a time where
i think it would be ridiculous but now i
really believe the x-men would be a
multiverse madness yeah no i i it seemed
ridiculous until like
the beginning of this year yes
you're just variants of ralph what's a
spider-man
[Laughter]
yeah totally i'm an actor i play
spider-man on tv it's just a show where
i'm from
oh goodness gracious david blonde again
love everything you do
i hope so prove it uh any thoughts on
the speculation that toby was supposed
to die but re-shot it so he could be
used in future projects
i i'm really curious about that because
i i could absolutely see
wow
part of me was like maybe he wanted to
be killed off but i
i can see a version in which that would
be very impactful him dying
but when they were about to do it i was
like no you're not don't you know yeah
so i i can see this being a 28 days
later kind of situation where yeah maybe
they did actually shoot him dying and
then maybe tested it or just you know
internally were like you know what this
is
a bit too much and aunt may's uh you
know death and sacrifice is already kind
of the centerpiece of that kind of loss
for this movie so maybe we won't break
the fans hearts too much
uh but yeah what i actually uh found a
little and i think this is because of
scheduling and shooting
um because because if i'm to unders
because you guys hear some of tom
holland's interviews talking like before
this movie came out of there were things
we didn't think we could do yeah we
like late in production we were doing
rewrites like okay i think we can do
this and then like there was a lot of
things about toby
saying like he's asking for a lot of
money so they haven't booked him just
yet pay me more if you kill me and so
when it came to green goblin i i i was
this was pointed out to me and and i do
agree with it like you're like it's kind
of odd that there's literally zero
scenes
with toby and green goblin interacting
with each other yes there's like none
and in fact it's it's like uh i don't
even believe it if
alfred molina and tom mcguire were in
the same scene together like when they
shot that um
and and for especially for green goblin
like because one thing is with when the
when he stops tom from killing him with
a glider i i like that moment a lot i
like to i like just the quiet moments
where like they're communicating just
through looking at each other i think
that's really strong
and uh and also serves as a cool little
arc for uh toby because he's clearly
felt the guilt over the death of norman
all this time it led to the loss of his
best friend ultimately
and so it even has that line in there
like how he's thought so much about how
he could you know how he could have
fixed him or saved him or something
right
so him it's like goblin gets impaled by
his glider in the first tubby mcguire
film and this time he gets to save him
from being killed by his own glider so
it's a cool little trajectory there
but there is also no scenes of them
interacting with each other and i was
like i wish there was like one seed he
even cut to his shot later on where like
uh after he's been stabbed and then like
tom toby and andrew are like holding
each other which i love i just love you
they had their arms around each other a
lot like that's just so great so you see
this green goblin like sulking in the
background and i'm like i wouldn't get
one scene you know just like one little
exchange of dialogue here peter don't
tell him i think it came down to um
i think it was shooting schedules and
[ __ ] i i don't think uh
i i feel like they would have if this if
the shooting was on par but clearly
there's a lot of i mean we've all seen
the leaked footage at the edge garfield
there's a lot of blue screening going on
here and a lot of putting them in there
so i just i think they just didn't uh
they didn't shoot them on the same day
yeah so they couldn't they couldn't have
a scene but
but i wish they did i really wish they
had a scene together aloha elias j
thanks for joining us ibrahim khan
seeing no way home with my dad after
seeing raymies when i was seven with him
and watching the culmination of three
generations of spider-man made us both
cry tears
of joy power of cinema fave spider-man
film ever i'm glad you that's beautiful
to be able to share that with your dad
that's beautiful man yeah like i i have
no idea what my dad would want to go
back to the movies but i kind of want to
at least make that a semi-family
experience because yeah like my dad took
me to see spider-man way back in the day
oh nice yeah
god
get nostalgic yeah darth pug
love all your content thank you for
introducing me via youtube to coy
send some love to koi he's he's out
today do you think that the memory spell
in the end extends to all spider-man
universes imagine toby getting back and
having mj not know him anymore i thought
about that
it's gotta be tied to tom hall doc's
range would have brought that up you're
like you're [ __ ] these guys over here
yeah it's gonna ruin their lives
all peter parker's lives after he made
it work
because there's a reason why they're all
coming to the to this one universe yeah
no i don't think that's the case we got
to talk about this spell briefly a
little side tangent
some people in the comments of our
breakdown seem to misunderstand what we
were i was like i thought we made it
pretty clear we know what the spell was
declaring that it did our question was
is like how much physical wiping does it
do that that was the question yeah what
does it do to the physical evidence
scattered around the world that isn't
contained just to people's minds like
all that daily bugle archive footage of
peter parker spider-man is that all
wiped from the hard drives from the
internet database everyone's from the
dodc from the fbi
everything that was there for the
ongoing investigation like are all
photographs of aunt may and peter now
just on may somehow like
are the photos yeah that mj took with
peter are are they just gone now yeah
like the these photos they took it's a
problem the yearbook
they're not on a yearbook does it have
school records does he even have to have
some type of like record to be able to
go to college yeah just because people
forgot doesn't mean he didn't exist so
we know he exists now but it's just like
what's what happens to the physical
history of yeah what's to keep anybody
from being like holy [ __ ] have you seen
this video of some guy being unmasked to
spiderman you know like yeah
does the flashpoint book get erased
that's yeah absolutely these are good
these that's the i think these are valid
questions
yeah
so
because other people were like jumping
on us like you guys don't get it it's
not they didn't erase peter parker's
from the just this race the memories
people i'm like i know that i'm just
saying what happened to the physical
evidence
of like photos they took with him
because it seems like then things would
just get out of hand all over again yeah
but hey maybe maybe there's a an
explanation that we just haven't heard
yet but gandalf the white
thank you for rejoining us after your
transformation andrew
we're pulled from the same universe but
different timelines
when andrew goes back is it still a
timeline where gwen is dead and elektro
goes back to a time where andrew and
gwen were chilling in the uk
that does suck if following the
multiverse could have brought gwen back
i know
i know right well maybe he'll get
plopped back into the right moment in
time so he never met mary jane
apparently i guess not he never got no
shalane woodley i mean
woodley just wiped from existence yes
yeah
even her potentiality is stricken from
the record really gone now no shayla in
case you guys don't know shailene
woodley did shoot scenes for amazing
spider-man 2 as mary jane and she was
supposed to be a prominent character in
um amazing spider-man 3. yeah and so uh
yeah but they just scrapped all that and
he's even like she was my queen says
that's my mj second j so you said that i
was like oh
he must not
or he's just comparing her to his own
current now girlfriend yeah yeah who is
mary jane
olivia d14 is that olivia delgade maybe
either way thank you for the moment of
silence
thank you olivia much love brendan
christie
christina this is just because i love
you guys you all have become one of the
main channels i've watched daily keep
with the good work and daredevil mca now
pog
pog
uh daredevil in the mcu now pop pop paw
it's got to be an anagram or an acronym
praise oh god praise oh god
pounds
yes absolutely toby i think is still
collecting residuals from this film for
sure of course yeah [ __ ] i bet toby
and aunt like ragu and the chat is
saying that toby and andrew's residuals
definitely went up leading up to this
film oh they're awesome how many people
are re-watching that [ __ ] just to get
prepared for the show
which surprises me to learn that sony
originally did not want to show doc hawk
in the trailers
that would have been great
i would have put at the same time i'm
like
wait a minute though there's so many
people especially of the newer
generation who probably don't remember
those films that well or didn't even
check them out and so much of the first
half of this movie is is so uh hinged on
i mean a lot of this movie his hinges on
knowing those prior films like they just
don't have as much of an effect if you
don't know those prior films so you
gotta really let on that these like i
think showing the villain should have
always been part of the plan
because
that informs people like oh [ __ ] i
haven't seen those movies or i should go
revisit them to under to better
appreciate what this film is going to be
you know what i mean yeah which a lot of
people did because they were in the
trailers
and i mean it gave you
a confirmation but also enough of a
non-confirmation of the spider-man
i mean like if we hadn't seen the
villains in the trailer we wouldn't be
talking about this i guess but at the
same time
uh i don't know a part of me wonders
like man how crazy would it have been to
have no idea that that tentacle was
about to show up
and uh part of me who someday would love
to uh be on a multiversal timeline that
could experience that
oh look at this
perfect solution
it would have been cool but i also would
feel bad for the people who are not us
who would have i don't know yeah and who
wouldn't have the time to catch up yeah
yeah that's that's fair and and it's
weird like for as much as from my own
cinematic brain i'm like man i wish i
could have experienced the full
breadth of the surprise with no
inkling that it was possible uh yeah it
does feel like
perhaps the right version made it to our
timeline here
david blonde right here thank you dude
make amazing spider-man i want to see
what the uh how many tweets the amazing
spider-man make the amazing spider-man
right now oh yeah release the the snyder
release the the garfield cut
release more garfield's
78 000 tweets right now make the amazing
spider-man 3.
it is becoming the new snyder cut
movement oh my goodness for the next
week yeah
yeah we'll see yeah but i mean
even if there's no tasm 3 i could
absolutely imagine there being more uh
andrew
face chump
i love how when they're swinging again
when they land they actually land in the
order of their movies of being
spider-man small detail but really cool
really
wouldn't tom be on the far right then
i thought tom landed first yeah he's
first is this reverse order is it tom
andrew toby but maybe the dimensions are
bam bam bam
i don't know
maybe you know it's funny when you watch
like the mighty raccoon videos you're
like yeah that [ __ ] was pretty accurate
yeah you know all right
that was like really accurate to how it
went down it's fun living in the
internet ages and eric voss remember
watching his trailer breakdown and and
saying like if you watch the way the
the um oh yeah the the way her ground
moves yeah when he lands on the statue
of liberty yeah
there's like some jittering on yeah yeah
they took out a character i'm like that
that's true and the [ __ ] lizard
getting kicked in the face like god damn
oh god they gotta face it man these
leaks were the
as much as the leaks
might oh what might have undercut the
experience people so many more people
watched it because of those leaks
that's true the leaks made a lot of
people this this is one of those cases
where the leaks got people more excited
the leaks
convinced people of what could be
possible piss people off who don't want
spoilers or don't want leaks absolutely
completely respected that at the same
time it definitely sold more tickets
yeah oh yeah
i mean like if they didn't know about
like the returning villains and the
possibility of toby and andrew it would
have made nowhere near as much money
that's true
no no spider-man movies made this much
money for a reason you know
yeah yeah that's fair that's absolutely
fair olivia d14
considering they disappeared because of
the spell do you think that toby and
andrew ended up forgetting tom that's
such a great question and that's
something that i was curious about
because i'm like what if the other peter
parkers remember him
i could see there being mumbo jumbo but
for right now what the movie presents to
me is that they they wouldn't know
i feel like they would have forgotten
him which makes they're so heartbreaking
when he hugs them i know because it's
the last time
they really seem like they're best
friends they do and brothers
and in such a short amount of time again
like it's testament
to the casting over 20 years that they
got the right people that could bring
that chemistry here and now you know
it's not like fred and ethel on the set
of i love lucy
where they really didn't get along
or how lucy and ethel also had problems
with each other yeah it wasn't that case
at all they seemed like they really do
get along yeah fred and ethel needed a
whatsapp group chat
we only had whatsapp back in those days
oh mo ammo is that strange supreme in
the credits love your vids
yeah it was strange to pre
here's the truth about our experience
with that trailer
first time he was in the theaters it was
a lot of well we got to see some of it
come on
it's the only time we'll be here in the
theater yeah yeah
just don't catch it and then the second
two times we watched the movie
yeah
the people who were just gonna test it
was just john and i looking down
trying not to see the trip like we we
heard the trailer
we heard the trailer three times kind of
saw it one time because they're like
there's gonna be a time they release
this on the internet i gotta forget this
so that we can cover it online never
forget most of the details
but the the image that i did i did catch
it we did catch the strange supreme
moment uh at the end which i was like
cool yeah did hear about that that might
be in there more strange more strange
please hell's yeah
olivia d14 again thank you for your
generosity do you think andrew or toby
will be in any future projects
i can see andrew i can see either being
possible but i feel like andrew is kind
of probable
ms brings up a great point toby and
andrew remember that they teamed up with
the third spider-man they just remember
that that peter parker good call they
would still remember each other that's a
great point yeah that's a good point
yeah faith that's exactly why we're
going to the trailer because it was like
man we should we really want to watch
this but damn
we have to for get most of what we saw
if only there was a spell that could
help with that that's why we didn't
react to any post-credit scene breakdown
stuff see that's good because i was like
they're gonna break down the trailer we
can't watch this yeah
and that's gonna be funny too though
because because yeah they'll get back
and they'll both be like oh man i met
this great peter parker
and some other spider-man whose identity
i never learned
but we were there to help him
specifically
oh goodness funny timey wymy don't think
too hard about it uh michael clark
did dr strange neglect to wipe his
memory and that is why the multiverse of
madness will occur i've heard this
speculation i don't know
i mean i really buy it when he
the goodbye he says to him so part of me
feels like he doesn't but i could
absolutely see him doing it or there
being some reason of like well you cast
the spells so
you know
deep down or something strange seem like
you really love peter
he did that line when he's like everyone
who loves and knows you
when he said loves to know you was like
this guy loves him
ah you served him or is he just choking
up with the idea of them like doing this
to this kid
because in that moment it registers to
me as he's saying
we love you peter no he says we and it
yeah it's absolutely that it's
absolutely including himself among the
people who love peter which which is dr
strange that i would have that emotional
association towards him yeah and and it
kind of only exists in this movie
thus far and and for the future
obviously it won't exist they work
really well together i i think their
chemistry should not be overlooked
because they got they got great
chemistry together yeah yeah yeah uh
benedict cumberbatch and tom holland
that's something i don't hear like
anybody talking about they have amazing
chemistry and there were concerns for me
in the in the trailers with that for
everybody in the trailers with that
about like with doctor strange sure
acting weird why would he do that and
like it it plays so much more
interesting
jordan do we have a rule here for the
thumb for the spoiler talk
jordan bailey this is actually a great
thing it looked like doc kept the arc
reactor perhaps he uses that to stop the
machine and therefore it doesn't die
as uh
sorry we're just having a hard time
reloading as they seem like similar
technology as machine uses fusion
reaction
i'm not actually remembering now because
he has the arc reactor he says his quote
and then toby shows up
but they don't
show him return the arc reactor right
not specifically no actually you might
have just solved it right there yeah you
really might have just solved it right
there
and then that's good that's a good call
man that's a really good call and then
norman can show back up on his timeline
and just be like wait wait wait wait i'm
just me
[Laughter]
it's me don't worry back up the glider
impales him yeah [ __ ]
god damn it peter
chris donahue i loved the movie my one
question is how did electro know peter
was spider-man
he didn't i didn't something didn't even
cross my mind until the breakdown of new
rock stars and this is something i've
seen a lot of people bring up now is how
this because of the spell
of how it's specifically
uh worded
it would justify the existence of the
other villains coming in yeah
but electro didn't and it's just like
[ __ ] it who cares you know it's this
goddamn multiverse travel yeah
to me it's as much as i can get critical
about like how does this spell exactly
work in the end and what are like the
physical wipes of things it's magic to
me i'm like well he doesn't know peter
spider-man
no
he doesn't know he right doesn't
recognize andrew garfield yeah he says
that he's a kid he said i thought you'd
be asian remember that yeah yeah you
know you help out poor people and you're
good at math i thought you'd be asian
because i got i'm sure out there is a
mexican spider-man yeah
i'm sure in a few more decades we'll
have a mexican spider-man who's also
irish he didn't seem to know him that's
another part of jamie foxx's performance
i just didn't i like there's a we talked
about it like an hour ago but in jamie
foxx's performance there's something i
like
i like uh andrew garfield a lot in that
scene and i love the teas of miles but
it's just so weird to me how jamie foxx
is all about like power more power yeah
i love this i choose to be this way yeah
and then at the come down he's just like
tapped out man you won don't worry it's
fine it's like i thought this guy max
would be like you robbed me of
everything you know yeah and he was just
more like man
what did i do i lost
yeah which is weird because i i really
like that scene and i really like jamie
foxx's performance across the movie and
as much as he is different from max in
tasm 2 i still felt the core of that
character being used as the character he
was getting into but
yeah yeah like
the more you poke it at especially that
stuff the sort of less sensical it
becomes
if you guys are still here can you hit
that like button that helps us out for a
future performance like
yes sir william graham what do y'all
think captain uh
what do you all think america chavez
role will be in the next film
i've got no clue uh she'll be there as
soon as i can tell you i gotta kick an
ass
i haven't researched it enough to be
totally fair
her no
keeps going every now movie premiere
yeah like she keeps attending like they
want to have her they want you to know
her name yeah uh so i i i we took a
photo with her
so chisel gomez sarosi ronan
get some real names people what is all
this [ __ ] uh what have your names like
anna kate yeah yeah yeah you know
benedict
tom there's like three chris
jesus why not come on get us sick yeah
yeah yeah we need more we need more
making my dumb brain harder to
comprehend this more white lady names in
the mcu
spider-man
but that's different it's irish white
[Music]
you know american white
give me a marry or a sarah a good
biblical white name
hey spider-man
sent us a spider-man he's a menace to
this live stream what's up greg and john
spider-man no way home is the best
spider-man the fact they brought charlie
cox was amazing plus the other
spider-man
absolutely
is it the best spider-man though do you
think they'll just reboot charlie cox
i feel like it it's not the same no no i
mean i mean do you think it was rebooted
uh let me rephrase that daredevil will
have his own show again
that's an excellent question
uh i could absolutely see the
possibility i could see them wanting to
use him slightly differently here
i think he'll probably just wind up both
places
i don't know like it seems like
daredevil the show has worked so well
and and bring back daredevil has been
such a huge thing that i don't
necessarily think it's a foregone
conclusion but i absolutely think it's a
strong possibility because not only does
everybody love charlie cox in that show
they also love vince d'onofrio in that
show among other things the the the
first season especially is regarded as
being such a well told
demand for karen page all the time karen
page yeah he's always like bring back
him where's foggy nelson foggy nelson
where's
we got the ben affleck foggy but where's
the netflix foggy
uh yeah i i
i i think it could have or probably be
more like a hulk thing
like she hulk
no like hulk in general or he's just not
that's oh oh oh but he's always he's the
best yeah yeah he's in every ensemble
movie he's just a lawyer for everyone
he has all just legal i hear he's
supposed to be in she-hulk
i can see yeah that would make a lot of
sense just a rumor haven't seen any
leaked photos wait for john campy to put
them out but i could yeah there's go i i
think that at some point in the future
maybe not too far off we'll see
something that's called daredevil or or
that's a daredevil story specifically we
got to do a ranking video at some point
this week ranking all the daredevil
movies what are you doing christmas day
we should meet up we should meet up and
rank the spiderman movies found my
christmas day
i haven't spent time with my family in
weeks now but it's let's let's take
christmas off and go shoot some videos
uh but yeah no we should absolutely do a
ranking that would be fun would you guys
uh
peer the gamer hashtag 2k19
which can you refresh the livestream
chat 100 i feel like we haven't been
there something that's not updating or
people aren't commenting hit that like
button people hit the like and thanks
for voting in the most recent poll
andrew garfield and uh tom holland are
neck and neck as people's favoritest
spider guy really yeah
if it ever expands i think they're tied
at 36 of the vote interesting way the
the world works right oh okay so is
there a way to re-pop out our live
stream are we still live we're still
live we're confident about that yes it's
just uh you know it's it's it's oh [ __ ]
no we're good okay okay it's just uh
it's thinking hard all right
the computer is you know we've been
doing it
sorry we just realized our chat did not
refresh for such a long time we've been
streaming we're going on two hours and
so the computer is having a
a tough time thinking
i always had a john panic moment it's
all it was like
we've been live streaming for like 20
minutes but nobody's yeah if this
monitor goes black then we're out yeah
thank god okay but yeah look at those
results damn toby maguire is a guy from
the 70s yeah man nicholas what what's
his name he's got some votes it's good
oh man okay that's all right
i was i was really concerned because
yeah i i just noticed like wait a minute
this chat hasn't refreshed in a while
yeah um
uh okay camira no way to appear in the
game sorry would you guys rather
spider-man before they mean spider-man
3. i mean we answered this question
earlier but yeah definitely the amazing
spider-man 3. we're just saying the
popular opinion on twitter right now we
did not have a long explanation earlier
as to why we opted for amazing
spider-man 3. it's trending right now
and we're just pushing that trending
button dude get the click am i right
those clicks i want to ever go against
popular
i think tasm 3 but with a toby andrew
team up that's the way yeah really it's
really distracting finally get the
thousand three yes it has to be all
about crossovers have to be all about
sophie mcguire
camira
goblin and andrew spider-man were the
highlights of the movie for me
those are two great highlights and i
would agree they are among two of the
highest lights for me i'm just waiting
for that one time someone comes in
someone comes in and goes it's all about
[ __ ] lizard man dude lizard best
portrayal most accurate to the comics i
loved when he put on his iconic lab coat
and said i'm something of a scientist
myself
it's the best moment in all of no way
home kenny baichak
baysack baycat
do you think we'll see other classic
friends of spider-man like gwen stacy or
harry osborne in future movies
i don't know you know what made me
curious is i feel like when people ask
emma stone about it
do you guys forget that they were once
in a really serious relationship
if we have no idea how they left that up
we have no idea if it's like really
[ __ ] awkward for them to interact
with each other
so i i always get a little bit
uncomfortable when they ask them a stone
about it
because i'm like i know they're pros
they know how to handle this [ __ ]
publicly but at the same time i'm like
they were in a really serious
relationship and they're definitely not
together now yeah so yeah
what if like
a big part of like i won't do it because
it's awkward but then the awkward
spider-man i mean because you know they
can make it work they're playing a
couple like [ __ ] um jennifer
carpenter and uh michael c hall on
dexter uh they were like married for a
year or two and then they still did like
several seasons of dexter post-divorce
and they're still like really good
friends professionals so yeah you know
like they still could be like really
good friends i think in like this
when you're that high up in the industry
it could be very different enjoying the
way how it works
so well relationships work but as soon
as emma stone drops her 10-minute song
about andrew garfield they'll be good to
move on i really like uh i think harry
osborne and peter
are better together in amazing
spider-man 2
than any of james franco
i think james strange is a terrible
actor
and those movies i like there's these
those are great performances
in those movies he's awful i don't like
him in those okay which is your favorite
harry osborn james franco performance
of the three i think spider-man won
really he's the most believable in that
okay that's fair
re-watching spider-man 2 i kind of i was
kind of not leaning that way but i think
you're probably right oh god i i beat it
just i like the whole thing about him
being like i'm trying to run oscorp man
and i'm like yeah of course it's cringy
because he can't run oscar
i
what incorrect incorrect oh [ __ ] no
what's the popular opinion yeah yeah
what is the james franco's better let me
just say that
don't go against popular opinion did
franco defranco did so good says massimo
semdol i guess
dude i don't think he's that good in
those movies i don't too
i think he's really cringey uh yes he he
is but but yeah i think it's despite it
you're probably right spiderman franco
fit the 90210 style thank you that is
good for like the soap opera acting yes
exactly when they're making eggs and all
that stuff and tossing the basket overly
cheery yeah yeah they're my best friends
i just smoked the blood before i came
out
yeah
i'm really cheery everything
guys
oh yeah no i'm not talking about [ __ ]
dean de haan's goblin all right that's
not what i'm talking about just talking
about harry harry osborne even though
his voice was distracting to me this
like patrick bateman thing he's doing in
it my really low deep voice i really
bought the chemistry between him and
andrew garfield a lot i really i bel
weirdly as much as like we were only
friends when we were children
i i felt a true history with them yeah
i like dang it the scene on the
staircase when when harry decides to
walk down the staircase and actually
interact with him yeah i thought that
was like that's a good scene when
they're hanging on the park
oh yeah and then he cry and andrew
climbs over the rail and yeah he loves
to point that moment out yeah he's like
there's a rock then the water is like
wow good shot there peter
my name's harry osborne
i'm 20 years old
i need the cure for wellness
we need him back just as we're done
but uh i don't think we'll see gwen
station she's clearly [ __ ] dead yes
but a spider gwen would be cool
just some
aiden
that little [ __ ] that little [ __ ] is
that how dangerous in real life it's
dreaming this whole time i've just been
making fun of this man
i thought that was like
i thought it was a voice it was an
affectation i mean part of it has to be
a little my bad
take it back then kudos for danahan
i think you come across weird then
yep
let's see
uh uh
saberwall
uh let's talk about that new suit at
that and
both james franco and nina han seem like
they both be like
cocky ass child actors yes that's the
vibe i get from both of them yeah you
were like you thought you were the [ __ ]
at your actor parties
and you hit it big
you were a heartthrob in high school
uh yeah we're just behind on super chats
that's how we work um
rashab
sabra let's talk about that new suit at
the end finalist someone brought us yes
yeah man i i think that suit looks
gorgeous it does gorgeous i you have no
idea how excited i was when i saw that
it was sewn together i was like holy
[ __ ] they did it yeah he [ __ ] did diy
his suit finally it looks
i love the i love the color pop on it so
much yeah you know because i uh a moment
in the movie i i did not like the first
time i watched it it's much way better
for me the second and third viewing
because i knew where the movie was going
with transitioning to him being on his
own
i really did not like how he
overtook doc ock that that actually
really bothered me the first time i
watched it like oh god he didn't even do
anything like he the [ __ ] he just
touched the suit did everything for him
like he didn't he literally didn't do
anything and then he's just like oh
interesting let me put it around no i
have control
that that actually bothered me quite a
bit um because i'm like of course little
iron man junior getting older
thanks buddy uh but knowing it's breezy
apparently
but in the moment it did by the end it
did it just because i i could see what
the intention of the movie was going
with the transitioning yeah there were
going so like on the second and third
viewing it doesn't bother me um but yeah
uh but i but i think uh i think the suit
on the
at the end the blue pops like carlos in
the chat is just saying the blue
really pops a lot and it made me excited
for like what's miles's suit gonna look
like yeah yeah
well and i'm curious too because yeah
like the blue is very reflective and it
almost looked like i don't think it was
sequins but it almost looked like he was
using something that is kind of sparkly
and reflective and so i'm curious to see
part of me was like i wonder if they
made this decision because it's a
nighttime scene and the blue needs to
pop so i'm curious to see what his suit
will look like in daylight next time
because i have a feeling they'll
probably go with the exact same
layout design but they might change the
hue of the blue well the thing is it's
still cgi'd yes absolutely and i i
really
like the less one thing i actually one
thing we didn't talk about at all yet is
i love the choice that they kept peter
in a spider-man costume for vast
majority of this film yeah most of the
movie he's in the spider-man costume i
think that's so cool like whether he's
just doing p most of it is just doing
peter parker [ __ ] and not spider-man you
see he's one of the same in this film
and uh i absolutely adore that choice
and uh because one of the things in the
other films that kind of bothered me is
like a lot of times when i when we see
them in the suits you could just feel
the cgi of them like a lot of the time
predominantly
and
especially like civil war that would
really distract me even though it's the
most short appearance of him uh so whoa
i can't wait to see is to see that suit
in action when it's not cgi yeah
um that's gonna be great or when it's
minimal cg
yeah yeah and i wish that i wish the
swing went on longer at the end i
thought it was like oh we're doing it
that thing that happens at the end of
those other movies
yeah i want it to go i wish that swing
lasted longer i was like come on man
let's make it even two hours and 30
minutes yes yes and speaking of things i
wish lasted longer
uh
your time in the band the bedroom
special
sex is disappointing
no i love love love the moment for
andrew when he saves mj but there that
shot is such a fast shot on such a fast
motion
that i wish they had made it like a
couple shots or slowed it down a little
bit so that it felt a little less like a
foregone conclusion
uh but that's just a nitpick of my of my
own design uh victor gamora
my daughter texting core to see how he's
feeling it's been a journey guys
but how do you feel now after watching
the movie to be honest i felt kind of
sad walking out of the movie theater lol
i mean
you felt sad
after the i mean
after watching the movie i i was just in
awe
yeah it wasn't like hooping and
hollering it was like
it was like a different you know like
there's like two kinds of applauses you
know where you're just like wow
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yes yes
and for me i was like
they did it
like we're snacks mad respect applause
and i guess that's why because i can see
why you would feel sad because there's a
certain thing about having to let go of
the anticipation and being on the other
side of something but yeah for me part
of the
the sustaining joy has been
they did it and i've woken up several
days since the first time i saw it and
this is reality and they did it still
and it still is yeah it is you know
after so much time and hype
it is the event we were all hoping for
and again i feel like it's special that
even though there are
let's be fair a good amount of
questions nitpicks and criticisms you
can pull up about how it works and why
uh it's still like the emotional impact
and the and the main impact of what's
important is still so resonant and so
fully formed that yeah it it's only left
me with joy thus far
tattoo a hawker kin saying there are
rumors that they're gonna be a solo
electro solo film oh weird choice hey
coy's gonna come by and say hi he's
feeling a little he's feeling under the
weather right now but uh he wanted to
say hi on facetime really quick oh koi
koi pong koi
how are you doing buddy are you doing
i've okay coherence adjacent
well you guys could hear it in your
voice you are wonderful adjacent coy
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry you couldn't we
miss you so much i missed you here you
could have answered our america chavez
question yeah what's america's chavez
going to do what's the mirror every time
we don't know of an answer we'll be like
get coy on facebook really fast
can you guys see him
some people can see
you're really really right on the phone
there you go there you go
yeah absolutely you are but we miss you
koi we wish you could be here
what do you think america chavez's role
here john can we dual mic this to get
some sound in here probably yeah we're
gonna duel mike coy's answer
here
here cause they're saying they can't
hear you
koi the only reason i watched this
channel was for koi and this person's
just been in this live stream they're
disappointed okay
so uh coy can you say uh what do you
think
america chavez's role in doctor strange
multiverse of madness is gonna be
okay so it's a movie about the
multiverse and it's a movie about
portals and there's a character named
america chavez who does a very good job
wielding portals into other dimensions i
think that the multiverse is out of
control due to magic and i think the way
it resumes control is due to america
chavez's ability to wield the multiverse
so i think she's going to be the
thing that that unites everything back
together
so because if for those of you who
couldn't hear that because of this
speaker is on the phone you guys still
can't hear him
coy even louder speaker for koi we need
an even lot the speaker's on i know
i mean here here here put it against
your mic again and i'm going to crank
the way up we're really going to crank
this
let's make sure
we don't talk into the mic
put the top where's the sound from right
here
is that where it comes from yeah yeah
all right go for it
so in multiverse madness a movie about
portals and about multiverses it would
only make sense to me that a character
who wields the multiverse and uses
portals to control the multiverse would
be the common denominator to solve the
problem so i think magic causes the
problem at the jump and then the
solution is america chavez so her power
set being so multiversal and so portal
heavy i think she's the thing that saves
the day
now lower the volume exceptional back to
where it was all right now you're back
now you're back
well koi
that's a theory that he has coit is coy
is the only one i know
that is
so religious
about not
about no spoilers no leaks
no so [ __ ] religious only pure
speculation before handling speculation
this guy he was the only guy i know that
he did not
he did not believe he's the only guy who
we lost a thousand viewers after we
cranked it
he's the only one who did not believe
that andrew garfield [ __ ] was real when
it was leaking going around the internet
yeah how do you feel now
all right buddy i hope you feel better
thank you for chiming in really fast try
to get some rest okay
all right take care buddy love you buddy
all right
love you man bye
poor guy poor coy he's not feeling good
victor gamora uh it's been a journey
guys but how do you feel now after
watching the movie to be honest i kind
of felt sad walking out of the movie
theater
weirdly i was excited about the future
of spider-man after this you know i i
didn't think they could do that i
thought this would i really thought this
was it this was this was the pinnacle
how much better can you get but i've
never been more excited it's it's just
savvy when you're like looking forward
to something so much and i gotta say bye
yeah but um i i think that this was a
hell of an experience and so to be here
with all you guys is talking about it
it's amazing and whoever's the dumbass
and the stream being like stop spoiling
the movie we waited till monday unlike
most people so and you could click off
this shut your mouth
shut your mouth shut your mouth you guys
dang cook references
shoes bleeding from the ears
[Laughter]
black chocolate you know that's the
other thing of why i'm not satisfied
it's called
oil is my blood
seed
trunks face i don't feel sad too because
uh it feels like it's still present and
happening and i feel like i'll still see
it again in the theater at some point
and and so like
i feel like maybe i'll be sadder once
it's like left theaters and i can tell
like everything's dying down and now
it's just about waiting for home video
the guy who's in the chat saying that
about the title don't worry about him
he's being he's just trolling you guys
it's thanks for stopping by pogba's a
lot here appreciate it appreciate it uh
black chocolate
andrew's saving mj is emotions after she
said i'm okay what i liked about that
too is mj zendaya has that reaction to
that moment going like
are you okay why are you
she has no idea why he's crying right
now in the middle of this battle
thanks for saving me but you need help
that was great
say in leagues he he understood that he
understood the dane cook reference yeah
yeah you understood the dance you know
the pronunciation boy hasn't heard the
length of a dancer call back in a decade
yes
oh we got them all we got them all
memorized oh yeah lord of the rings and
dang cook
bk lounge
go to the beekeeper we're sorry so we
you know us we fell behind we're gonna
we're gonna refresh this in a little bit
yes and we're gonna be like wow we're
gonna we're gonna be on crunch time to
watch the matrix um
risk runner 101 uh hey greg
uh people spoiled it in this in their
thumbnails uh hey greg i have a video of
your newbie intro
i haven't seen it yet i even went to go
watch being the ricardo's yesterday was
it good
there was a newbie ad but the movie is
the newbie adam will only play mainly
before spider-man no way home and and it
has to be pg or pg-13 i did not know the
i love luciada uh biopic film was
r-rated it was nc 17. it's nc 17.
there's a lot of literally
lucy movie
slow moving but man those sex scenes
uh yeah um
that would be cool to see it
maybe i'll go
just gotta buy a ticket
three times and i haven't seen my
commercial you'll see it don't i
actually think i'm like i'm ready to
cringe at myself could i please send it
to you hi john anyway i love the film
scene imax for the third time i did okay
so there's like two kinds of imax
cameras and marvel doesn't use the one
that does
full capacity yeah like it's
like if you go to universal amc imax or
like a real imac screen
you'll know when it's real when you walk
in and there's nothing playing and
you're like
when it's overwhelmingly intimidatingly
large when it looks like you've entered
the mirror dimension and the building's
about to fall on you yeah
like there's because because i've been
to a few imaxes and most don't have that
effect and there's only a few out in la
that have that effect and so i imagine
across the world and there's not many
like there's imax projection quality
and but the imac size i forget what the
size is supposed to be but it's 70
millimeter
that's like this the size yeah i think
so okay yeah you're probably right about
that right anyway um
that size is um
so
like
if a movie does not have imax conversion
imagine this is the screen right right
here this is the size of the screen let
me get you some more real estate so you
can really explain this cool
so if this is the screen
if a movie's not imax converted it only
takes up the center of the screen and it
looks like it has like giant letter
boxes yeah then if it's a movie like
dune or christopher nolan it takes up
the whole screen yeah
marvel uses a different camera that
meets you halfway
where you get like a little more screen
and there's more definition yeah more a
little bit but it's not even the crystal
clear definition that this screen offers
yeah it's not the full breadth of imax
not imax converted but can play on imax
yeah imax inverted with the best quality
ever and size and
it's just bigger
yeah
yeah but but still it's it warrants
enough where you get a little bit more
extra frame to go watch an imax
spiderman no way home i still wish i saw
it on imax oh yeah uh and i'm going to
um but yeah
well all right then at that point i'll
be like i've seen it enough
usually three times is enough for me in
theaters i'm like all right i've seen
this enough
uh okay here we go and hello to you risk
runner 101 thank you for the shout out
the shield milner
andrew was my favorite spider-man in
this movie he had the heart and the
trauma that was shown in his expressions
especially when he saved mj that really
seems to be the major highlight of this
whole stream it's almost as if people
are hashtagging make the amazing three
right now yeah you might go on twitter
and find that as a popular hashtag yeah
oh sorry antidote to hear that that you
did not have a proper crowd reaction oh
no that was too bad
go today on a monday
to a guy yesterday was like yeah i saw
one of the scenes on youtube like what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] even if you do
that to yourself don't do that don't
i'm like do you even like the spider
movies like yeah i've seen them all
give a [ __ ] to you are you talking to
brandon mr b
oh man thank you for the super chat oh
man four nl one quid so does everyone
forget all the different peter parkers
now because it affected the multiverse
the spell would cause new branches in
the timeline no i don't think that's the
case at all it was specifically directed
towards him and that's why i think all
the villains and everyone were coming
into that mcu into tom holland's
universe not the other one's universe
they're all coming towards him
specifically and the spell was about his
individually so i think that's why it
was uh specifically that yeah
almighty ninja who gets killed by bees
believe your best dane cook your best
classic dane cook for a chance to have
it read uh yes all right willie please
i'm sitting in the theater right now 15
minutes before it starts second viewing
you're probably well into that viewing
you should just keep our livestream
playing yes the whole time
yeah be one of those guys who carries
like the sports game on their radio but
just with the spoiler talk or the guys
in the sauna who decide to just blast
their sp yeah their music on like a
speaker because
because nobody cares for the silence
everyone wants to hear your loud rap
music or your freaking basketball game
or something
sauna experience is missing a soundtrack
mon arc uh nice name i've seen the movie
five times while i've come to realize
the first 30 minutes such a strange pace
ah no pun intended the movie is still
phenomenal i really think whatever
criticisms i have are completely
mitigated by the fact of how great that
whatever is great in here really shines
and catrin in this live stream says it
is a bit sad that stan lee never got to
see this movie it really is sad i also
really respect it didn't try to do some
weird cgi stan lee thing yes that was
although out of anyone to do it for it
would be probably okay with stan lee to
do that for yeah because you'd be like
drawing him into the movie
so it would actually be okay i feel like
like there's always a debate for
everyone else who's died like is this
all right foolish but with stan lee i'm
like i i feel like it would be okay
yeah i i mean this is his empire and
he's in all of them and yeah he clearly
loves this stuff and he's yeah been in
this amazing spider-man uh in the tom
hall and spider-man universe
so yeah i don't think it would have been
inappropriate or they could have done
something like they did with venom or
they have an image of him somewhere
which maybe they do and it's just really
hard to spot but yeah it would have been
nice to have a little stan
he should be one of the forms coming
through the multiversal tear yeah just
uh excelsior from beyond we are going
over today super chess what do you think
we're doing right now we are on screen
yeah
all right we're just we just uh we don't
we're not really super speed roundy
about it yeah when we ought to be
all right so john campbell makes
ten thousand dollars a day re-shop
yo greg and john what comes next for
peter parker in spider-man 4. that new
suit gave me classic vibes
i mean
we haven't really established a villain
i don't feel a scorpion be the right
villain to go down
no not yet i think a proper version of
shocker would be cool yeah
yeah that would be cool instead of
henchman
adjacent henchmen towards them
two different guys like i like the
portrayal of shocker that is a mercenary
for hire
and is like uh
uh yeah he's like an assassin with
respect or like it's the job done you
know
he cares about the game a lot like i
like that
or um
yeah like a proper shocker would be a
proper shocker that's a proper proper
shot spider-man in the proper shocker uh
yeah i think i think a shocker a proper
shock would be good mr negative actually
the kid j uh j458 is saying that i think
mr negative would be up excellent that
would be very cool
um yeah i know he'd be [ __ ] great i'm
hearing rumors there's all rumors like
literally i and when i say rumors
i mean heavy like it's just rumor
that
uh mr negative might be a villain in uh
across the spider verse oh no idea no
idea
but but um [ __ ] uh
it phil lord and chris miller when coy
interviewed them in our video uh he they
did tease that they would probably get a
better look at who the villains might
actually be in across the spider verse
okay i think craving the hunter he's
gonna have his own uh movie first before
we actually see it but damn if they
brought kingpin in as his next villain
that would be dope that would be dope
and that was too heavy
i need more spiderman
just to weave him at the belly
and then he throws up everywhere
aneurysm fun because vincent de nofrey
was big but he's not that he's our comic
book
no he's not kingpin's like [ __ ] he's
not cartoonishly large
yeah
aneurysm phil fun spiderman no way home
was incredible besides ned randomly
doing magic which i thought was stupid
and random god got them to their run
time
yeah it did my favorite scene is tied
between anders spider-man saved mj and
matt murdock catching the brick before
peter
what i thought we might see is um
is uh
is what you may call it um
ned in doctor strange multiverse of
madness yeah i thought that's what we
would see like a trailer and i thought
that'd be like their big reveal on the
trailer that ned would that would be
their biggest one
that ned would be in it yeah i thought
that or or there would be another mig
credits scene like shang chi where where
like wang shows up and he's like
all right i gotta
initiate you too come on yeah
yeah something like that batman yeah
william defoe is tiny as [ __ ] he's a
small guy meeting him in person when co
introduced us to him it was like
wow i am looking down at you to talk to
you you small
person i still feel like you can kick my
ass at 63 years old that's right that's
right man
all right um you gotta show just gaming
2006. oh [ __ ] why the fudge why the [ __ ]
did you spoiler spoil the movie i
haven't seen the movie yet because
you were smart enough to walk into a
spoiler
spiderman am i the only one who wants
the amazing spider-man 3 now you are not
i'll tell you exactly how many people
want the amazing man
um
uh here one second uh i'll tell you
exactly how many people
uh
where's that hashtag
no it's not showing oh no no it isn't
oh it was i think i saw i think it was
like 90 000 so far
90k might be a little bit more
that's that's enough how many hashtags
did the snyder cut get like you know 50k
yeah
every day
every day four years
and oh you refreshed it already yeah we
got to the to the top of it did we
really yeah oh so we only got like a
hundred more to get we only got like
500. we don't have to leave for the
matrix for like another two hours so we
could
keep going
we'll keep the supers on for now rushing
yeah yeah yeah no no for spider-man no
way home we should be able to sink in we
literally this whole day is dedicated to
this oh you know what that's a great
idea who's suggesting that poll
scarecrow 273 let's suggest all right
all right oh would you rather
would you rather just say that would you
rather
have
dot dot dot amazing spider-man 3
spider-man 4
with toby
yeah do that
steven i've always wanted a logan style
uh reimu version but then i saw andrew
here and i'm like you don't look old
enough i mean if they really like
scruffed him up and [ __ ] i was hoping
they'd do that for him trying to keep
him looking like relatively young
because then i'm like now you just like
look like awkward old guy trying to look
at
you
oh no
you got to keep him at the appropriate
age because andrew when you watch the
movies back to back i'm like andrew does
not look like a kid anymore uh he
definitely looks like an adult yes he
does yeah but let's see what that poll
says soon yeah
you shouldn't have refreshed this we
should have called it a day taking the
good people's money
has been like i don't know what you guys
are talking about
through all of them it's every super
chat they're done
we're done we did them we're so thorough
you didn't even hear it
we got this we got this since we got no
super chats
don't worry they'll catch up who's
saying they're having andrew back
the leakers whenever i check in on a on
a twitch stream here's what i always see
it's just
every time i see a twitch stream it's
just like i'm just on my phone
barely talking to the people
saw homie on the right at ralph's
yesterday were you ralphs uh was it uh
yeah i went to a few ralph's
why would you go to a few rounds uh what
what does ralph's have that is like
ralph's exclusiveness they didn't have
my water and so water do you get my
toppo chico
it is that special to you that's emoji
you're like yeah i will hunt down yeah
i don't like any other sparkling water
as much as i like to chico and i and i
have drank them and i don't i i will
finish a toppo chico no matter what and
i don't finish a lot of other sparkling
water this is why you don't sleep sean
there are a lot of reasons why i don't
sleep this is sparkling water is not one
of them sir we have to drive to several
ralphs well they were on my way home
i only stopped at three because there
were three in my immediate path
there's that's the convenience of living
in the future and in case anyone is
wondering uh uh because this live stream
event was created on the 19th that's why
you're seeing all the dates read as the
19th
i was initially quite confused as well
but uh it's just reading them because
that's when the live stream event was
created and uh
set up so
anyway damn warren you got hella views
on this spider-man 4 officially
announced andrew garfield returning for
amazing spider-man 3. really it's
question marks
okay
yeah yeah we don't know yeah read
everything with a grain of salt
all right we're back in action we are
back caught up to where this new
rockstar has uploaded a video about okay
let's let's stop the live stream guys we
gotta do new rockstars we're not gonna
answer everyone's questions here today
yeah we want to do this we're trying to
we're trying to relax a little bit right
now so far amazing spider-man 3 is in
the lead with 77
people wanting that over a spider-man 4
with toblerones expect nothing less and
uh this shirt i got from a comic book
store called
oh blast from the past yeah what's the
next one here
all righty we are on to josh becker
hi
josh thank you so much love you guys so
much i've seen the movie five times
hoping to go many more times
really
wow wow at once a day
the hype when andrew took off his mask
was insane that was a great that was a
great like moment in the theater
especially because
they could have caught out and just kept
the guy in the mask yeah especially when
you're watching like two villains who
they've kept messed up the whole time
yeah essentially matched up or they
could have thrown in some rando who's
not either of them yeah right it's like
another white guy like you recognize it
you're like maybe and then when the mass
is off it is like the like they did yeah
you're sad
he's tall he's lanky
they're not just nodding that's right
they're not just pointing at each other
i'm surprised they didn't do some bigger
thing with toby being in a suit
yeah he kind of is in the suit he's just
like yeah i got it yeah yeah like i
thought there'd be like a moment where
he like shows up in the suit it's like
this big thing it's glorious the crap
the back cracking scene is so [ __ ]
fun i love the back cracking scene it's
just like a real moment between them
and and and two for andrews
by peter to be like i don't know i feel
like anything to do with back
stuff would be traumatic
so you know to to to have that scene
like it's such a human scene but it's
also a really funny scene and that's a
great example of like humor but it feels
like kind of character oriented rather
than just like hey a joke he's really in
shape man [ __ ] toby mcguire man oh
toby yeah he he looked you could tell
underneath that that
shirt that he worked out he worked out
to get in a cgi suit you rock stars
going live right now oh no are they
going live
oh my god they're doing it they're live
i don't see eric vossen here
what's the point in going then ouch
shots fired punched by her shots
in there
phil molina could crush either of us
yeah
so be careful there
uh all right olivia d14 here yes
would you rather have toy man spy or
amazing fire right there maybe
spider-man 3 definitely yes back gear
play oh man we got gotta catch up on
somebody pull there you go all right oh
man damn it's definitely there bat gear
play hello i miss your live stream in
the philippines
well what does that mean
they miss they missed the the olden days
when we used to live stream direct from
directly to the philippines yeah we're
just like this is only for our filipino
viewers right now okay
it's pinoy hour at the real rejects
uh yeah i guess i guess maybe because of
the time difference they're not able to
attend yo if you guys want to go to the
the new rock stars when they just went
live man sure go check them out
no i'm just [ __ ] i'm being sarcastic
as [ __ ] no go check
oh speaking of new rock stars uh anyway
never mind uh hey uh todd
by the way thank you so much for being
here yeah and hey uh
hello to germany mario swenson
uh todd andrew hey greg and john love
your vids do you see a scenario where
andrews peter is in the venomverse and
tom's in the mcu in the future no way
home is fire
i mean i think they did save themselves
in the post-credits scene i think yeah
with having
like the because he says i want to i
should meet this spider-man guy they get
sent back so he's probably forgot
already who peter parker is
right yeah uh tom tom hardy
and like we've been saying it just seems
like it would make more sense for andrew
garfield's to meet tom hardy's venom so
maybe they're gonna do something or
maybe when they got sent back something
went wrong when they got sent back
like andrew garfield specifically could
be that'd be really fun actually that's
some multiversal madness and it'd be a
cool way to still have it be like we're
not sacrificing our weird venomverse
yeah and then he goes up against andrew
garfield's spider-man like that would be
pretty cool yeah i would love to see
andrew garfield and tom tom hardy square
off as actors that would actually be
really interesting but the build up has
definitely been
for
tom holland and tom hardy to cross paths
yeah and i think with this more edgy
version that we've that we've watched
tom holland give a portrayal of i am
more excited for
um
i am more excited for the idea of tom
holland crossing paths with tom hardy
who
is a very weird
weird still weirder to me
even the post credit scene was like this
doesn't feel like it fits
yes this doesn't feel like it meshes
well
yeah it feels like it's tacked on from
someplace else like the sony universe
yeah
which i mean good for those movies on
having some sort of tonal continuity but
uh sage mode we should we could all
stand to go sage mode could you guys
imagine if they had a post-credits scene
where we see toby is back in his
universe and just looking over the city
and then andrew comes in and says we
have a problem crowd would have gone
nuts
oh dude yeah any any multiversal
spider-man crowds are gonna [ __ ]
themselves
uh that would be cool
i do wonder when we'll see miles morales
i know right he is in college now it
would be okay to bring him in
he is he would be by this point in time
oh oh you mean tom holland's tom harker
is in college and so miles would be
younger
and that would have given him time to
grow up since homecoming i just think
tom holland always looks like
he always looks like a little boy
he does yes even though this was the
most manly in in the spider-man
franchise i thought he really like uh a
young i think it had a young manly
quality in the devil all the time yeah
that's really well life haven't seen
cherry yet but i've heard that about him
too there uh but it and here he really
had a young man like i thought it was
like a genuine badass you know so yeah i
would love to see that
um spider-man's back
reaction when goblin stabbed toby's
peter and may
i mean if you watched our video the
other day where we broke down that
25-minute chunk you'll know why we love
that scene so much of aunt may dying it
was perfectly executed love that they
killed her love that they killed her
[ __ ] waited for this to tell me she's
a terrible person in real life that's
right
no that scene is perfectly executed and
um heart-wrenching and her delivery in
that scene like when she says the line
about great power comes great
responsibility brings me to tears every
line it does because i know she's about
to die and she says it and it's like
using your dying words to inspire yeah
to inspire how to keep like stick true
to your morals and beliefs don't give in
to revenge yeah um
that's so great like i love the way
which is like what
what what norma was saying about the
morals still like oh my god her
performance moral mission yeah so damn
good oh yeah dude yeah i think it's so
good the the only
gripe i have about that sequence is the
actual glider strike is a bit cgi mumbo
jumbo because i'm like
where and how did that thing actually
hit her i mean she would have been like
dead she would have been impaled
in real life should have been dead right
away yeah but but yeah though that seems
george it would have it would have
sucked yeah if that's how she dies if it
was really just [ __ ] dead
i'll take the cg mumbo jumbo shot for
what we get after that which is a
testament which is a great i think
metaphor for the things that work and
and maybe are are could have been more
polished about this movie is like yeah
the shot where the actual glider strike
happens is a bit muddy but the scene
around it is gorgeous and i wouldn't
trade that shot back for
anything you know can you imagine if
that scene just [ __ ]
oh that makes that splattered
this is like a rick and morty moment
where yeah she's just exploded all over
the wall no actual love for her um yes
all right when toby got stabbed i was my
thought was like
if he dies this is a bunch of [ __ ]
that's my actual thought i was just no
they're not gonna it wasn't even like i
mean people in the crowd were like
yeah but for me i just looked at it like
no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you movie
movie
don't do this
terrible way to kill them
and i mean
then they do solve some of that with
humor but i did enjoy that whole thing
about like i've been stabbed before yeah
and you're you're in so much pain right
now yep and he has healing they have
healing abilities of spiders yeah
all right tayden tayden tayden
spider-sensing in the apartment was
insane
that is highlighted so much yeah it's
such a shift
it's it's it's a shift that scene well
and it's it's a tone yeah it is and it's
a tonal choice that and it keeps you in
the character perspective yeah and it
disorients you which i feel like a lot
of these kinds of movies are semi-averse
to doing where it's like
the scene starts there's that crush zoom
and then it transitions into this like
you pointed out before that locked off
shot as he's walking through the
apartment and it's great because like
you put together what's happening but as
the moment begins
you are kind of with him just going like
wait what what the hell is going on
right now and then you get puts together
in your mind and i love that they went
with that experience they didn't do like
a crazy zoom in and and like
dude like they they show his little
spider sense lines in his astral
projection moment but but yeah it's like
they really take the time to make it
to put you in his shoes being
disoriented by this stimuli yeah you
know it's a good way to put it which is
beautiful i like the way you talk john
thanks like the way you say things
i like the way you die boy
bo cl fox reference yeah why multiverse
multiverse spidey goes
uh correction it's not the third highest
it's the second highest at 260 million
beating
infinity war
no way it did
damn
go spider-man i mean it's gonna crack a
billion the question is is how many
short days from now will that happen
i can't stop it from cracking up really
i can't stop the box office i can't stop
the tickets that's what happened tonight
i can't stop the internet from crashing
they're starting to come through and i
can't stop them picking processing
because servers can though
the servers that they didn't update i
would i would love you know sidebar i
want to know if anybody ever in the
comments or just anybody in the world
knows how the servers that run those
things work to know if i sh am justified
and being like guys what's your excuse
you had time to prep for this versus or
is it just always going to be a [ __ ]
show when you have a billion people
crowding the server either way
uh
yeah thanks for pointing that out
emotionl zai it's been a while since
we've hit a billion it's true zydescope
would it be better to leave ned and mj
in the last trilogy or bring them back
in some way later
it's mj man you got to bring her back i
feel like the way i could see it going
right now is there will be like not much
of them in the next movie until like the
very end where there will be some kind
of clue that maybe they could uh you
know remember or maybe there's a way to
kind of open that relationship back up
but i don't want it to be
in the next movie and i i won't say that
like a hundred percent because i'm sure
they could come up with a good way to do
it part of me feels like it should last
for a little bit so that it feels like
something truly impactful rather than
just like okay how do we undo this plot
point so we can get our ensemble back
you know
and that's bringing up a good point
maybe kobe's been getting pretty bad
again lately omicron
delta
can learn all the greek letters pretty
soon what do you mean bros on mj her
name is literally mj watson
bro and they say you're mary jane and
like i don't go by marriage she just has
this whole exchange there the multiverse
it does away with a lot of definitives
but um uh uh all right dan we were
talking right before that mj
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh kobe it's
been getting really bad again and uh
like even in the states too
there are people i've been seeing like
people who i know who have really been
catching it's been sucky and uh
uh so i i've been saved like i met him i
went to a dinner with people and i was
like i'm gonna be that [ __ ] that
keeps his mask on the whole time
even though i'm the smart one i'm not
really the [ __ ]
i'm gonna keep it on
the [ __ ] who's looking out for the
people yeah you guys are gonna be like
i died
respiratory fluids
i'd rather just you know uh keep it on
just for safety
i'll still hang out with you guys and
talk i don't care if you guys keep your
mass off i'm sticking mine on okay
um
so yeah it's been getting really bad and
then other countries yeah other
countries have really been suffering
with it and that has been i can imagine
that definitely affecting the box office
but even still
no you can't stop spider-man nope not
even covered that's the one thing i feel
like it's the new doctor strange i feel
like i can't stop people from attending
the theaters
i'm trying to conjure up more variants
but it's not working why is that a meme
yet
what does that mean does doctor strange
a meme to the photo i can't stop i
didn't do that why are we not oh my
goodness someone make it happen somebody
i wish that's the one thing i wish this
dude i know someone who got hospitalized
so nope it's definitely it's it's real
it's not a hoax
it was bad i've
have some family friends who died from
copenhagen yep
de los soul legendary uh hip-hop and uh
music group de lost soul yeah did you
notice that tom holland's new suit has
toby's spider on the front and andrew
spider on the back
congrats on an amazing channel pointed
out is that are you sure about that
michelle jones watson i was wrong it's
not mary jane yeah oh yeah michelle
jones but but still
yeah thank you for correcting me yes um
it's still an mj it's just a variant
yeah
yeah
the initials are i don't notice are you
are you 100 right about that
i would need to go back and i mean i
think that's really cool kind of tribute
detail if it is true but i also
culmination of them
he is the perfect combination he's got
some of the darkness but also some of
the earnest you know
dopeyness
uh chris jackson
trying to cure the bad guys was cheesy
i could see
i i understand maybe how this take works
but i just i disagree flat out no and it
makes it even more powerful that after
green goblin kills at me
and that they all
like just go [ __ ] this guy
except for doc hawk
but they all go [ __ ] this guy that he
still sets out to cure them and that's
such a great beat because it it carries
for so long with tom holland like in the
lab when there is like okay electro and
and connors and he doesn't say goblin's
name even as he puts his device down
like you can tell and even when uh toby
maguire has the the talk with him about
like we got to cure them all you can see
how much apprehension and how much tom's
spider-man tom's peter is
not agreeing to that until the very end
so i think it's a powerful choice and a
good way to avoid
just having it be a punch out uh but you
know
i don't know i don't think the idea is
bad i could see why you might have a
problem with the execution or something
but
yeah at that moment when he's live
streaming to the daily bugle and he says
like just so you guys know i really did
try to help you yeah i couldn't kill you
damn just listen i believe him i really
did try to help you and and i'm still
trying to help you yeah
yeah
mateo diavino phillip carney thank you
for the the super chat super sticker
matia dvd 1030 phil candies i'm so sorry
yeah look at that cutie little guy here
uh mateo we can control f him do that
all right
you got this john all right
it's with an o
there you go
we only got one uh here it is yeah we
found it that's above but sure
oh these are in a weird order guys oh
you guys said somebody
here's what we have to do to be safe so
this isn't gonna keep getting [ __ ] up
for us um these are in the future whoa
this is presented we order oh we're
gonna have to go through these again all
right we're gonna end the super chats
right now
no we're gonna keep we're gonna go
through them but we're gonna stop then
we're gonna disable them from being out
because some we got to refresh this and
clearly they're being in a weird order
because youtube's like
we're not used to you getting so many
super chats so we're gonna we're gonna
stop it so that way we can uh properly
uh go through them uh yeah so john why
don't you uh find mateos read his then
we'll refresh this
ah did you hear it yeah i did fine
mateos refresh this but yeah if it's
let's read his then we'll refresh this
after the one that we just started at
yeah we missed this from yesterday
i am that's what i've been looking for
but we've got control effort
i did and that's the first one
yeah that was the one he sent in last
night is what he's saying today's the
20th
and he said he sent one on the 19th
yeah there it is
yeah see
yeah we haven't read any of these yet
well read it do it hey guys this is not
my favorite superhero movie of all time
obviously toby and andrew the highlight
but can we all agree and just told the
show and appreciate the amazing
redemption we did read that i remember
that a lot on clear we read that right
at the beginning of that we did all that
drama
this is one of the first ones we read
yes
you were here and we were one of the
first people we read yes all that stuff
was so it and stop it so that way we can
now because clearly these are also out
of order
yeah and we don't want to [ __ ] up
everything for you guys so can you
refresh the regular live stream chat
first while you're doing the stuff here
yes i can see it here yes all right
there you go
didn't care when that may die hot wow
matthews
in here i'm so sorry to hear that man
that's
that sucks
andy z thank you guys for staying talk
about this haven't been able to talk to
anyone about it well andy uh yeah that's
true you know i i i can't lose sight of
that because we have we live in
california and we have so many people
out here who are like everyone's in a
film out here like most people are if
you're not you can actually feel a
little left out sometimes
um so i can respect that jks we're
trying to put this back in order here so
we can uh make sure that we can get this
going and yeah you'll be able to see
this after the live is done but we don't
skip anyone's super chats
that's why we're refreshing this right
now because it looks like
it's been the computer uh the system uh
youtube has been putting in a weird
order and we're trying not to miss
anyone's super chat so be like we'll
have to ask towards the end uh in case
you know some [ __ ] happens where we're
uh
like all right who do we did we miss
anyone so thank you so much guys super
chats are now closed you can still send
super stickers if you want to if you
want but but no obligation no obligation
no pressure how many times you're gonna
watch i'm gonna watch it a fourth time
at least yeah i mean i'm excited to
watch the fourth time it's funny like
having seen it
all we did last week was watch
spider-man and talk about spider-man
uh but i'm still excited that's all
that's gonna happen now yeah
do all this stuff about andrew garfield
possibly coming back [ __ ] rpk being
like i knew it the whole time look how
smart i am
it's just bomb dude
yeah man
very gratifying experience
let me see here try to look at the
twitter thing okay sage mode
i was clapping so hard at the aunt macy
and how they nailed green goblin i
forgot she died
you must have been a weird-ass dude at
the theater at that time
yeah
oh sorry guys with great great great pow
great power it was great power all right
oh yeah we also got to check this room
though should we refresh the streamlabs
is there a way to stop the streamlabs
you're coming through
no yeah we'll just have to go through it
all right yeah yeah just replicating
refresh it yes it is refreshed
it is refreshing tag me on twitter for
what dayla soul
oh yeah
oh
yeah my mentions go to memento
i don't have anything from you dela
day long i must have blocked you dave
something really racist to me
why do you all keep bringing up campia
we have brought him up so many times
during this stream can you believe it
campy of yeah that's all we talk about
pretty sure we must bear up like at
least 10 times in this stream too many
times or maybe it was one time we
brought him up industry
yeah you know look at toby mcguire's
dick
uh
dolby was the third time we saw it uh
the first time was just a regular first
two times were just regular screens
but watching dolby i will not watch this
in 3d i i i don't like 3d
i like even even movies are shot with
the intention of 3d i don't like it
i'm not a i'm not a 3d fan it's very
specific 3d experience like i've had
some where i'm like that was worth it
but they're few and far between
um okay we're good there
calvin did you watch daredevil only to
prepare yourselves first for spider-man
because that's the thing it's like if
when you when i hear about the
cancellation they probably don't matter
the mcu it can make it feel like it's
not essential viewing so people might
not go check it out
that's that's why i think some of the
leaks actually came in handy
because it makes it feel like i should
go watch this because it sounds like a
central viewing to appreciate this movie
and one thing the mcu is really good at
doing is making prior
films that came before it or prior
properties feel like uh essential
viewing mm-hmm yeah especially in this
phase they're good at that yeah uh dave
losola's foxy grandpa on twitter if you
want to check that
uh and we got the uh stream labs back if
we want to jump into there
let's go to the uh what should we call
it
let's see let's uh
do we have an order here on the subaru
check you can you examine that for a
little bit
i mean it's in the same order that it
was before because i mean i've i've i've
found our way back to mateo's uh
question and the questions preceding it
are the same order so wow calvin you
just happen to luck out watching it at
the right time
all right cool
dip set thank you
cjt of course we're still alive we we
have people who submit who use our hard
earned dollars to submit to the super
chats tons of questions we really [ __ ]
up if we were like we're done
so yeah we've ended the super chat since
it allowed for more submissions but we
got to make sure
we got to make sure we go we go through
them all
josh ren
spider-man uh end suit has a combination
of toby and anders symbol on his chest
they used the home trilogy as the
spider-man origin loved the film you're
the second person to say that yeah i
mean so i guess
not even eric boss pointed that out and
their boss points out everything the the
symbols yeah i i really want to go and
and
get my magnified glasses i do put eric's
fault on it like it was a whole other
pedestal yeah
like don't even question him it's eric
voss and coy at the top of the mountain
yeah
of of nerdum of references
i yeah i really want to check that out
and uh and yeah i mean that made me
uh the homecoming far from home are not
my favorites of the whole spider-man
cinematic series but i
did come to appreciate
it's like even the things i don't love
about the experience of watching those
movies in real time make sense to what i
see now as their end game or or what
they concluded
based off those couple of movies so they
do appreciate in value in that sense i'm
like okay we did see a very protracted
origin story where at first he is just
trying to live up to his mentors and
he's got a lot of influence from them
and then the second movie he's kind of
trying to make more decisions on his own
but still really struggling and trying
very hard to
uh you know hit certain things and clear
certain marks and in this one he does
feel like he's off on his own and he
learns the true weight of
how to fight for himself and to make his
own decisions and what the weight of
those decisions will be
and so yeah it again it makes it feel
like it was all part of the plan
uh which i appreciate
but it wasn't yep i don't think it was
thought it through
alto
how was youtube allowing long lengthy
videos of spiderman but if i upload two
seconds of feliz navidad i get a strike
because youtube's music copyright system
is the most broken system in the [ __ ]
world and it's the one that people flock
to to claim [ __ ]
yeah it is the easiest to manipulate too
it's the easiest to manipulate you had
two seconds of this song that could be a
substitute for the real thing who knows
i could literally
manipulate it myself
i i know how to
that's how much it pisses me off because
i can easily start claiming
royalty-free tracks if i wanted to
why don't you we wouldn't ever have to
post videos you could literally whatever
royalty free tracks you most commonly
here all i have to do is start uploading
it to a different channel that we have
like a more private one and then when
someone uploads it youtube will have a
system that goes hey this person might
be using your content and then i hit
copyright claim saying they're using my
content it's that simple
example
when peop
sometimes when we upload a trailer
reaction
and then another channel uploads a
trailer or a trailer reaction sometimes
youtube's copyright system says
this person might be using your content
which is the trailer yeah let's go claim
sony i don't own the
no way home trick
now and see how they like it like it is
it is [ __ ] up the way it works so i'm
sorry about that also but we get the
struggle man all right bat gear play i
think of my own theory the villains are
the variants that pulled in the mcu that
have different
uh that are different that will have a
nexus event when they return their in
their world on their spot before they're
dying
yeah i mean it would be a real bummer if
they just return exactly to when they
said they left off yeah i imagine it
won't be just like a quick flash maybe
some time we'll have past like like what
i'm saying is imagine the um
the andre garfield universe with electro
yeah grid fight happens he gets pulled
out
him and gwen are standing around goblin
shows up they fight
then a lecturer comes back after that
yeah being like what happened man yeah
that that's kind of how i imagine it
going mm-hmm
well what a big super chat thank you
sorry for taking so long get around to
it holy [ __ ]
what do you think of may dying giving
peter the great responsibility line
instead of his uncle ben personally i
love it as ben has become a meme and has
no impact anymore you know i never
thought of it that way that like the ben
thing is a bit of a meme quality-ish
did they establish that there's never
even been an uncle ben
i mean he says that thing in homecoming
about like everything may has been
through but there i
wait a minute in in in what if that's
supposed to be a variation of tom
hollands and he does say he has an uncle
ben yeah
i mean just leaving this movie for my
own head canon it felt like there isn't
an uncle ben and i feel like i kind of
like this movie better thinking there's
no uncle ben but did you hear what i
just said yes but you know that's that's
the canon so
but i don't have to accept it because
the multiverse is real so
that's not and it was the worst word and
it was a what if episode so it's you
know it's like it's supposed to be a
variation of tom holland yeah so in some
other tom holland then he has a variant
of tom hall it's
fine a variant and a variation are the
same thing
yes
then all right then you win
yay
but no i mean uh i i think i think it
was great to give to her especially
because
it's mainly in the moment that they gave
it to her of when they chose to use that
line
it leaves more of an impact because
usually when that line is said it's been
like you're being kind of a dick man
and then for him to when they say with
great power comes great responsibility
they're not aware
they're not
uncle ben is not fully aware of what
he's saying at the time what i mean by
that is they don't realize that they're
saying with great power they don't know
that he's [ __ ] spider-man
yeah they don't realize that he's
powerful and that he has yeah they don't
know that
so for her to say it in the most literal
sense because she knows his actual power
holds a little bit more weight at that
time
you know to everybody in the comments
i'm aware that the initials are on the
suitcase in homecoming john you're
[ __ ] [ __ ]
how do you know i'm sorry far from how
do you not know that
i do know that maybe he is still alive
oh he's an [ __ ] he's just
walked out on this it could have been
his grandpa's suitcase who knows there
could be a different ben and it could
have been at a different place in his
family tree you know i don't know i i do
love giving it to anime though i feel
like that is for for everybody bitching
about and i and we've done that too
about you know there's no uncle ben oh
there's no great power of responsibility
it doesn't feel like that lesson was
ever imparted on this spider-man
and and given that it's a multiverse
story it feels like a very fitting
rhyme uh to borrow from the jj abrams
book or george whoever said that you
know like it it's yeah george george
lucas you know same thing
now it's like rap it rhymes as i think
is what he said yeah it's totally said
about the priest like rap it's like
it's like a run dmc song it's like tmz
yeah
but yeah it felt very appropriate and
very heartfelt to have her be the one to
to impart that on him in that especially
yeah in a moment that is of great
consequence and not just like i want to
try and get through to you before you
get out of the car kind of moment
uh so yeah i thought that was really
a wonderful choice and it felt like just
the right thing what if at the
end of spider-man no way home he
actually found his parents they were
still alive
and then everyone forgot about him
[Laughter]
you never have that connection can we
help you young man
are you lost
that's a very colorful barrier
he'll leave us
we don't have any change
matt powers spider-man homeless
matt powers favorite line of no way home
has to be i stopped pulling my punches
from andrew the amount of weight it
holds what was both of you guys favorite
lines yeah we've talked about our
favorite lines in here but i do want to
touch on this i think that is a great
line because
it starts painting a picture of what was
that movie we didn't get
you know so i think that's why a lot of
people champion especially for an
amazing spider-man 3
because
that
indication of that one line lets you win
on like a batman version or some [ __ ]
spiderman
new york city yeah
standing on top of the empire state
building brooding
uh tm animate turn the camera back on
pinoy pride yeah baby no yeah we do want
to do a spider-man ranking
now the new hype is going to be
andrew garfield when's he returning yeah
and now it's when i'm in the train now
of like i just can't wait for tom hall
and spider-man 4 no no no no that's
where my mind at heart is at but no
don't worry now there will be a rumor
mill of uh you know all the andrew
garfield like oh they're talking about
it rumor has it they're gonna do it it
is a weird trajectory if you guys think
about it because everyone was super
stoked mainly about toby
that was the main hype
like even if you were even if you
personally
were wanting andrew more than toby the
main hype the talk was toby that was the
one that was like the impossible one to
get the first one you know like that was
the big one yeah and now the hype is we
want to see more andrew who is really
championing for toby who you want to see
more andrew so it is interesting to see
how like it's like weaved in that
direction
um but yeah thank you matt powers tm
animate love the film but i'm confused
why everyone had to forget peter parker
exists peter's original request is for
the world to forget he is spider-man
um it's because all the multiversal
beings are being pulled there because
they all know that peter is spider-man
so if you forget peter
altogether
they're not going to have a reason to
come here yeah i mean you know i guess
it's in the wording it's in the
semantics of the spell but that's the
explanation generally
way to goat you did that really well i
appreciate that anytime i thought i
didn't know the answer no
i just stole it telepathically from you
renzi just coming to the livestream i
don't know if you talked about a
probability of remaining spider-man 3
now we definitely haven't talked about
it let's talk about it now yeah and then
all three of us
being together again in the future um
i think you should hold like if you do
it too soon
three of them together if you do it like
too soon
then it's just not exciting anymore well
you gotta have like another installment
without the three you gotta you gotta
have a couple more at least because then
it's going to be the constant gimmick
it's bad just like they did avengers 1
and then every movie after that was only
like avengers 2 of interesting like you
got to have you got to have the the
especially something like this yeah it's
not the same thing as because like the
avengers it's like different franchises
that come together everyone periodically
or them cross over and like you have
[ __ ] doctor strange spider-man no way
home this is like a a whole new caliber
here
of like films that we didn't think were
mcu or now you know that that's this is
something that you you don't want to uh
i don't want this moment of them coming
together to be ruined by getting used to
seeing them again
over saturation yeah yeah
i mean i i my big question now is is are
will there be a time and when is the
time that the spider-verse movies will
touch these movies because they're
tailor designed to do so in some way
shape or form i mean crossing animation
and live action is tricky
but uh that's what i wonder i know you
gotta do the roger river movie that's
what i want the mcu's roger rabbit
roboto studios huh
syringe's hands didn't shake sus
also they did the meme
and toby peter was such a dad
wish the last line of andrew toby wasn't
equipped rather commenting on tom
validating him as toby validated andrew
your back is
you have a spectacular back spider-man
you have a superior back spider-man
can we just get that that self-talk on
track
dallas mcfaul oh yeah
the beam part was great i love the even
semi do it when they're talking about
which peter are you
that's kind of the more of the meme in
some ways yeah i mean you're peter one
peter two p three yeah yeah spiritually
this is spring why are you being a [ __ ]
bfp's initials aren't far from home
guys
i said in my head canon
i have chosen to believe that there
isn't an uncle ben in this universe so
you live in there are other b names
denial
sure we'll call it that because it is
it just it doesn't feel like he left an
impact at all beyond that [ __ ]
suitcase
i would rather choose the lie that feels
more impactful than oh he was here and i
guess he didn't mean much to anybody
except he gave peter a suitcase to you
and i don't want to feel like oh aunt
may is just quoting uncle ben like i
don't know it feels more impactful if
that's just something that came out of
her because in this movie it feels very
much like that would be her mantra
what was in a brooklyn 99 reaction video
that's a long story oh god
it's it's it's ready it'll be up soon
time
soon
do you hope to see as the villain for
part four dallas mcfaul is asking us
i want to see
who would be a fun whacky villain
for spider-man 4.
let me think about this really fast i've
tried to narrow it down
no [ __ ] it i love him and better call
saul and he's a damn good actor and he's
barely in spider-man homecoming michael
mando as scorpion because if you've seen
him better call saul you know he's an
amazing actor
and how cool would it be you got tony
dalton from better call saul and hawkeye
you're michael
yeah you get him in there that'd be
amazing just get them in there matt do
it
yeah we're supposed to watch matrix 4
after this stream so we should probably
um
haul ass we should probably uh slow down
a little bit and just
let's open the super chats back up
really solidify us being here the entire
day cloverfield golden's thoughts on
toby spidey getting stabbed in the back
at the end but not dying shock value
changed ending i don't think it's a
change ending i don't think they would
kill him off in that matter
that would be a shitty way to die
[ __ ] spider sense don't work how much
crap they ever get for that
well that comes back for like 20 minutes
yeah just get killed people have been
upset man yeah you'd be very upset
they would be they would be and and uh
you know
the only question i had was i know they
have healing ability but it looked like
he got stabbed in the spine so i'm like
should he be paralyzed
whatever i'll also add
that michael mando's scorpion would be
great because he does not know the
identity of peter parker that's the last
time we saw him i mean yeah sure by the
time noah home comes out he would
because everyone knows the identity but
he'd be back to where he was at the end
of spider-man homecoming
whereas like that guy [ __ ] us over i
want to kill him yeah like scorpion i've
never found to be the most compelling
villain
um but i think he would make a very
interesting one to say the least uh
through the uh through the hands in my
of michael mando what he can bring to a
role
good morning to australia three minutes
in homecoming not enough
uh kiddo to brazil
am i missing something there's no
exception where jay jonah jameson was
there loved it but just trying to figure
it out he's just jay jonathan who exists
in this universe yeah just happens to
actually have the same face as
uh jay jonah jameson in the rainy films
he's just the only the only one of the
few who happens to carry the same
appearance yes but it's still slightly
everybody's bald yeah doesn't have the
hair to add in his uh and the bugle is
on a newspaper yeah the bugle is a is a
visual medium
so yeah i mean that felt like just oh
it's this universe is variant although i
think the casting is supposed to make
you go what did he bleed over from the
other universe like that initial shock
and far from home but
hey justin petry
hey guys from what i'm seeing it's
possible that a tasm three could be the
next trend i.e release designer could i
hope it happens but we shall see
i don't
the reason why snyder cut was so
demanded
was because there was a cut there was
footage there that existed to make it an
assembly
you know
where this
i i feel like people will move on
faster from it
that's why i think restore the snyder
verses even kind of die down
because it's like yeah they have ideas
but the only thing we still have footage
for is suicide
squad if anything and that's not even
that demanded
uh
so i i i demanded as much so i i think
that like right now it's just so it's a
such a hot button
and i you know as much as i think andrew
garfield [ __ ] kills it in the role i
i don't feel i feel like he just has a
really
hard public reception
with
being spider-man it seemed to really
take like he's been pretty vocal about
it over the years
how it was a hard toll it took on him
the experience of making one of these is
really hard on him and it just seemed
like he got so annoyed with like i'm
trying to promote two other movies and
all you keep asking me about is if i'm
in no way home you know
and i feel like the experience is like
the same way how like batman kind of
rubbed ben affleck the wrong way
i i start to get that impression where i
like i kind of worry about andrew
garfield's mental health association
with spider-man yeah because he's so
great in here but it seems like he just
gets so fed up after a certain point
yeah and with such a prolific and and
beloved character as a spider-man or
even a batman i have to imagine that no
matter who you are whatever actor
jumping into that role is is about to be
sort of swept off into a stream a
current that is much stronger and more
unwieldy than just the people around you
in the movie you're making you know all
right because yeah now you're
everybody's business and everyone feels
entitled to you and an opinion about you
and blah blah
r4t boy five
thank you for the moment of silence
yes siree bob
daryl bass
wish toby had a scene with norman
osborne after he was cured that's
something we brought up very early on in
the stream number one gripe could have
been a great scene and i see it as a
missed opportunity to be honest but
still doesn't take away from my
enjoyment for the movie no in the moment
it doesn't bother me i'm not like
where's that scene yeah
but i would have prioritized that over
i would have prioritized that over the
dark oxy
yeah i would give you that because it's
where it all began you know and it's
such a huge
part of peter's whole journey yeah like
it's meaningful for him to have you know
moments with doc but yeah i would like
he's the father of his best friend he
was a father figure to him at one point
he's the one who also works on the cure
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
yeah
like it does it it that was that one
haunted him more and carried through the
trilogy yeah whereas the doc aquan was
only spider-man 2. and doc ock is at
least redeemed to some extent
through peter by the end of that movie
so it's like there's less to do there
than there is with green goblin whereas
that's like a complete tragedy how that
ends
yeah but uh but yeah thank you daryl i a
teefa man i'm from scotland and the
movie was the first time ever i've ever
heard the cinema scream and cheer
freedom
freedom from the multiverse
not a popular thing in the uk
love you guys
everyone is very stoic in the uk and in
france where they have can everyone just
either stands and ovates for like four
or five minutes or they walk out halfway
through and boo
i know every venice film festival 10
minutes standing ovation or half the
critics walked out half the critics like
threw something and left in a huff
well that's good i'm glad it's bringing
people uh into their feels that's uh
it's got to be special starkiller base
big super chat thank you buddy i think
it would have been awesome if spider-man
if the spider-man talked about their
time since the last time we saw them
instead of all the villains they fought
in their respective movies that's what
we were hoping for man yeah i mean i
think it makes sense for them to compare
and contrast like wacky villains but
yeah i mean
you know you're sitting here being like
oh what have they been up to all this
time and you get hints but that's what
you really want more of toby sure just
recapped all of the spider-man four yes
and the script you just said the script
this should have just been them talking
about sequels we never saw
jake hedge and easter let's not forget
them forget to control search in case we
happen to forget them okay but thank you
starkiller uh brendan christinak how
would y'all compare the audience
reaction over him something like
infinity war and game more hype
i think no way home is more
spread
out
like um
like end game the cheers come in at the
[ __ ] at the finale
after cap on your left and then it just
doesn't stop for like 23 minutes you
know i was like
oh my god
they're all here they're gonna kick his
ass they're gonna avenge us all yeah
because we probably would have gotten
dusted
and it's different because that is such
a quantity and that is the culmination
the difference with that is
avengers endgame is the culmination of
the avengers franchise
um even though we know there will be
more
where as um
whereas uh we might have time to shoot
honestly guys we've been we've been so
tired uh we might not have time to shoot
another reaction whereas no way home is
the culmination of the spider-man
franchise
and they did
bring
i
in some ways prefer
the
enthusiasm of audience reaction to this
one because
at the end of the day we
expected the heroes to come back and end
game
here
like this is something that we just
didn't really think possible like end
game did what avengers already did but
on a much bigger scale
and this did something very unique
which was bring back
movies that got canned and now make them
canon you know like i i think that is uh
i actually kind of prefer what they did
here
in terms of audience reaction because
it feels like
um
like a thank you
yeah
of like when you see andrew garfield
like you didn't forget about them thank
you
and uh
you know sony they're very reactive so i
feel like they're like holy [ __ ] people
really like andrew garfield what were we
thinking
well and and that's the thing is i feel
like uh
yeah endgame is is
you know huge and overwhelming and and
cathartic by the end but i feel like
this is different because you have i
feel like if you haven't grown up with
or seen the previous uh iterations of
spider-man then end game would probably
edge it out but yeah for the personal
aspect of just like yeah a lot of us
grew up with these movies and have been
following you know the trajectory of
spider-man films and have varying
opinions yeah all of them there's
something way more personal and and that
cues
you into the passage of time and it
feels like a big shared life experience
that we all get to be a part of
so i feel like
through that you know no way home is the
more hype and it's like endgame you know
did something that at least for its
genre was new and different whereas i
feel like no way home is doing something
that's kind of new and different just
for blockbuster cinema in general yeah
you know uh because yeah this is this
this i mean we've seen
little crossovers like alien versus
predator and stuff like that but this is
a whole other thing yeah yeah
uh olivia d14
do you think andrew saying he wants to
fight an alien might be foreshadowing a
venom crossover no i think it's just a
funny line
yeah just some banter it's just a funny
life yeah
but mtu we we we read into everything
so if it does happen then it was no
one's ever truly yeah if he does it then
oh my god it was foreshadowed yeah
uh thank you olivia you've you've
contributed quite a few today thank you
luminaridins uh i think i said your name
right a little detail notice after the
third watch is may exclusively wears
red blue or a combination throughout the
movie as if to silently support pete oh
that's a great question
yeah great little detail
i think he did
but now i really see it not in that
articulation so
uh jonathan sicarios sicarios aquaros
hey real rejects big fan i want to hear
your thoughts on how no way at home
there's no ops in the mcu so how did
peter get bit by a spider
oh [ __ ] you just blew my mind
yeah that's a great question uh some
some other nefarious laboratories out
there i guess because yeah what science
that's a great question yeah it's always
oscorp isn't it yeah
where would he have been where would he
have got because yeah even in in tasm
he's at the corp uh building
are they oscorp and spider-man one
yeah uh
aren't they
or i don't know if it's oscar proper but
you know like norman shows up there
that's a great question i'm not 100
that's great to be honest
but yeah either way where's that spider
club diagnostics is where it was yes
just a regular
quest left it wasn't roxon
fifi excited to see more of tom in the
mcu especially since he has his classic
look now would 100 love to see
spider-man 4b spider-man civil war ii
i wanted to just be more grounded with
just him yeah
just him and daredevil
just do that yeah he's always got to
have a buddy in these movies now we will
check the stream as we're going through
the last of the super chats first and
then we will check the stream laps
we're also trying not to make it feel
like we're rushing through them
columbia university we are very aware of
the time that we are down to the wire
right now
in spider-man 1 they are at columbia
university apparently yes yes
so yeah cause it'd be [ __ ] weird that
norman drops them off at the front
yeah i'm here to make sure you don't
screw anything up on the way into my
company
but they will touch on in a freshman
year yeah fifi
uh we just did that yes uh spider-man is
then saying when toby says andrew is not
lame that was great him helping him
crack his back
correct backstage i just really love the
way that scene was done because it was
just so uh [ __ ] is so like
let the camera roll on them and just
took their time yeah it looked like he
was really getting his back
his face after he does it like yeah yeah
i'm good at that [ __ ] right that's great
that's what i if i ever get a chance to
interview him that's what i'll ask is
can can you crack my back
uh it's funny productions how you doing
funny fun me back in the chat what's up
dude spiderman endgame was great cried
three times it still doesn't feel real
toby and andrew came back i'm greedy
because i hope they return in the roll
amen to that i think i cried
no i cried like four times i think the
second viewing yeah i cried a few times
yeah i think i just didn't stop crying
i just cried the whole movie i am just
crying you know and it's okay
it's okay to cry the second viewing when
they were running before they posed in
the statue of liberty i just started
crying because i was like
they [ __ ] did it i i just can't
believe they did it that is so good this
is so great it's beautiful man
riboto studios theory uncle ben does not
exist in the mcu he didn't have a
headstone next to mays it might have
just been a briefcase it could have just
been a breeze that was a nod to
ben like like the initials were not to
bend maybe maybe benzodiazepine it
wasn't ben parker it was yeah maybe it
was her dad because it's like she also
like there's no when she starts dating
happy you think there would be some
acknowledgement of like
oh you're ready to move on and meet
other people and uh you know after the
death of uncle ben how [ __ ] up you
were
well and and she her name is mae parker
so either she would keep his name
posthumously or she's actually peter's
mom or dad's sister
you know like there are lots of ways for
there not to be in the end
i feel like three letters on a suitcase
can't just lock us in
it could be grandpa barry no it could be
grandpa barry hayden parker
could just be a very famous corporation
that makes these hp the finest brief
briefcase
uh holdings
p word
roberto we got you mr fryson jr thank
you for the bird you rock thank you for
the little sticker
mike watson i like how andrew and toby's
entrance was in a house that looks
similar to the houses their own movies
interesting
they own filipino households that's
right man
filipino rosemary harris
and filipino sally field
definitely i was like this looks like a
filipino household that's what i saw
yeah
every time i've been like when are we
gonna get the filipino spiderman that's
what we really need
andrew saba thank you for the moment of
silence my darling thank you c
lb
oh it's good to see your face again in
this tiny little bubble interruption
time peter parker got bit at the stark
expo that would actually line up really
well sure man not only did he get tech
he even gets his spider powers
all right cool let's roll with it why
the [ __ ] not that's the new meme uh
clb lb lb besides the 25 minute sequence
you mentioned what were some other
moments from the movie that you loved
also i love that andrew showed up as
spider-man and toby showed up as peter
parker likewise
yeah that's cool that's a good way to
put it uh i
a scene i loved i loved when
peter
you know what i love when peter and
mj are talking with each other on the
cell phone in happy's room because i'm
like man they really are a great couple
i love the opening shot not the opening
shot i mean i did love that but i love
when they go into may's apartment and
it's hand-held
post-breakup yeah that's that to me was
when i was like this is a different
movie yeah the hundred percent real and
gritty well choreographed that shot
there
instantly told me this is gonna be
different this is a film of a different
structure this is not going to be john
watson's typical funny
funny light yeah there's going to be
there's going to be some real weight to
it i i love like him like webbing the
window shut yes just like he's parrot
it's like a paranoid he's trying to like
focus on their breakup to distract you
know uh i i that scene right there was
uh
that was that like that opening scene
had me hooked right away
yeah absolutely um andrew saba
you guys have made this so much fun
no we haven't
we're tired we made this a chore for you
guys i mean this is sure to sit through
why the [ __ ] are you here uh
june 20 20.
thanks man thank you so happy the
pandemic occurred
andrew and william stole the show
that's right
uh
yeah they i think for they must have
because everyone keeps saying that yeah
like tom holland was the first part to
me in the movie yeah but he was the
first yeah
i guess gently
remake studios will you do a poll which
actor performed best in the movie toby
or andrew [ __ ] it let's throw it up
there i like that
let's do this everyone wants tasm three
all right i love that may broke up with
happy
dude we have marissa tomei and mickey
rourke in the marvel cinematic universe
i know
and next joe pesci
yeah i don't
care
that's it that's what i want yeah i'm a
[ __ ] rhino
laughing at me because of my soup
i think i got a big nose
i'm pale you oh god
joe pesci is rhino would be awesome
start that petition was no one
hashtagging that
had the better performance
why are we asking this question we know
the answer but [ __ ] do it
say andrew garfield or thomas andrew
garfield
toby maguire
oh my god you guys don't play with these
lives that are dinner a bath got my kids
ready for beds i don't really sleep in
my surprise your life is still going hey
man look if people if people have uh
contributed to the super chats like we
stopped them but if people had done it
i'm going to uh
we're going to make sure we're here
because
it's not right for us just to bounce uh
off of people doing that
yeah and based off of some people's
response to us saying that apparently
there are other people who do live
streams you do that
and i was like i can't see myself that's
why we don't do live streams a lot
because if
if we do get into it it's not always
like this for us a lot of times it's
it's uh you know we're like oh we've
caught up good but uh but no if if we
land in a situation like this we're
gonna have to be late for stuff uh oh
renzi
just wanna say
i love you guys work you guys cosmic
wonder have convinced me to make a
movies discussion and theory channel to
take my nerdiness higher
okay guys let's clear something up
costume wonders a hack yeah total frog
[ __ ] that guy and um
an [ __ ] in real life
so if he gives you advice about your
channel
run the other way run the other way
that's the only way we found success
doing what we're doing
what's he advising
let's do the exact opposite of what he's
suggesting and i'm telling you it banned
a lot better for us but no because
wonder suggesting that then sure he must
actually um
um he must believe in you yeah
and remember that with a great channel
comes great
responsibility yes to not get canceled
that's always the goal and not to get
pulled into some weird drama beef we're
almost caught up with the super chats i
think
no wait that little scrolling ball
that's the most misleading
bar is quite misleading martin do you
agree that john we find you're skipping
dude
swishes lightsabers man
i'm mixed with emotions there is just
one thing i really want you guys to talk
about ned can we see ned as hop goblin
in the future he wants it he told us
directly he wants it to happen he would
love for it to happen so i absolutely
think we can see it
uh although i don't think we'll go down
that particular trajectory
ned hobgoblin with a bunch of magical
powers at the same time too
that's just a little much if you ask me
raghu you've been here all the whole
time raghu
that is amazing also joe pesci uncle ben
i'm here for that
peter you [ __ ] look at me while i'm
talking to you with great power here
comes great responsibility martin uh do
you agree that andrew had the best first
movie toby had the best second movie and
tom has the best third movie you
couldn't have said it any better
uh that is my that is my personal
opinion yeah that that the the
spider-man one is better that amazing
spider-man's better than spider-man one
uh i think spider-man 2 is better than
amazing spider-man 2 and far from home
and uh i think no way home is better
than the amazing spider-man 3 because
that never happened
absolutely that's pretty solid um
that dude jake c loved the movie i wish
the hype didn't cause leaks to be
everywhere like campious photos
what those show was wildly rumored but
not confirmed
um
yeah it was interesting being in the
theaters having two experiences one is
hey it's that video of andrew garfield
by the pole
what was he saying there does he say wet
blood oh web block i literally said that
in the theaters i haven't literally went
oh webblock i just said it out loud
oh webblock because a lot of us were
like is he saying web blood and the
other one was campious photos especially
especially the spider-man pose i was
like there it is
i want to know what the story what the
true story is behind all that someday
they can't be increased his following
successfully
i know but something seems
right i've seen hanky brian platts
uh they took the if you help someone you
help everyone graveline from the
spider-man game uh aunt may also where
was uncle ben's grave did he not die
well we've talked extensively about this
maybe john's a [ __ ] for forgetting
about
ben parker's initials on that briefcase
or maybe it was just random letters
meant to be a reference to ben parker
but wasn't actually an indication that
that was ben parker's briefcase example
a peter loses that briefcase it's far
from home doesn't seem to give a [ __ ]
about it at all so you know maybe it was
just a briefcase that happened to have
letters that referenced him you know
yeah
bring home pie
jason gabriel
i wish they gave matt murdock more time
thanks he will as future installments
come right now this was a spider-man
time i'm gonna answer all these
questions so efficiently and very direct
okay and this matters in my dane de haan
voice
chick chicago royal
thank you guys for being one of the most
wholesome and genuine channels on
youtube andrew's reaction to saving mj
will forever live rent free in my head
that's really good thanks
i'm looking for mr pembroke
the cure for wellness
ah yes that's really that's a really
good
really good uh
you got there gonna add that to my list
of random ass depressions uh
like campy has always been insanely nice
to me you know
so yeah i make fun of everyone clearly
yeah he hit us up beforehand he was like
hey greg do you want to leak these
yeah and i said i'm okay
you can have that one buddy thank you
for the thought
chicago royale that's what you just said
yeah chicago royal
i mean you handled it perfectly luke rs
jesus christ
uh thank you man
49.99 i'm like yeah that's a lot oh my
that's why we can't be dicks
it's not the super chats we're going
um we literally carved out like four
hours for this yeah unfortunately the
day i got coveted two days before my
spider-man
you should have just gone
super spreader event
you know i mean it is gone the thing is
i wouldn't be like you made the right
choice but if somebody said i had coven
and i just had to see spider-man part of
me would be like
nah man i understand
that's
it's [ __ ] up for everyone around you
but i i get it
you only live once and i hope you took
precautions
no no it's a good thing you didn't go i
had to resort to watching it illegally
to get it avoid getting spoiled not
proud of it
still had me crying and cheering in my
bedroom the whole time you know it's a
good movie when a cam footage is
standing out for you and accessing cam
footage is surprisingly easier than it's
ever been it's half of it's on youtube
like wow i'm sorry that you had to have
that experience man yeah i hope you get
sorry soon uh dude that that is awful
i'm glad you stayed home made the
responsible choice
but you know like yeah you know they're
people like soups um matt ramos had to
put out a post recently talking about on
on instagram he put out a post
saying that there were people at the
event who tested positive for kovids so
you know like that made me go [ __ ] i'm
gonna make sure the social distance of
theaters yeah
um yeah and uh
because i believe it's real subjectively
not objectively apparently
um but luke uh hopefully you have an
opportunity to go watch it in the
theaters for reals
um
i would be like what's going that would
be so funny
that would be great all they has is to
show a vax card at our theaters now yeah
every theater asks that now yeah
but you could forge it
sergey
sergey you really can
it would seem as though you pretty
easily probably could yeah
it's like the digital one
i mean you could just make your own
because there are a bunch of different
ones but i feel like the digital one
would be harder to forage but yeah it's
just a piece of paper
sergey chi
you show that
nobody get goosebumps when ned said that
he doesn't want to be a super bowl that
kills his best friend cough cop hob
goblins set up that's what i forgot
before
i
i feel like they i bought that from this
movie that they that they literally were
acknowledging it and choosing to do
something different
with ned not becoming hobgoblin but
becoming a sorcerer of some sort
yeah
i mean not that i would ever rule it out
because it's well it's it's well within
that character but at the same time it
seemed like they wanted ned unless he's
going to become a magic you know
hobgoblin look if you say your super
chat was missed what i'm doing right now
my phone is i'm writing down three names
maguire yeah sean mclaughlin
oh nicole
we haven't gotten to a nissan and then
there was another guy who kept saying it
[ __ ] i'm forgetting which one it was
he was really understanding how behind
we are jake hedge that's who it is jake
hedge okay
all right
um all right let's keep going spider-man
i am the werewolf andrew's got to keep
denying it don't be a [ __ ] it wasn't me
make sure you you still deny it man toby
mo-capped me daniel hey
from the uk watched you lads cover this
movie you guys do such a great job thank
you all we still got one for fourth
people watching i was like we probably
got like a hundred people watching holy
[ __ ] oh yeah i've had the specs hidden
this is the most relaxed we've been yeah
like we're just we're just kind of
keeping it chill right now you know the
count 209 i mean no we got it we have
tons more don't be confused by this
scroll that makes it look like we're
halfway there's a lot what often happens
is a lot of people will have contributed
and then you know a half hour an hour or
more will go by and we're still getting
to the point that you contribute yeah
there's just so many that it feels like
you got missed but yeah just in case we
got the list going daniel hey from the
uk
watchy lads carry this movie you guys do
such a great job
all the emotion in the film and when it
finished i felt a lot you guys will win
me love you guys keep up the great work
oh daniel that means a lot tonight i
feel like that we were there with you
the whole time that makes you
you were with us we wanted to be there
with literally we watched it twice we
didn't need to watch it a third time but
we wanted to be there with the fans and
experience the crowd that was like a big
part like it's opening night there's
only one opening night stressful it's
going to be to like jam this
time and
we gotta we gotta go
um yeah so yeah that was like a big talk
i was like dude we only got one
experience for this let's go
absolutely um megan if you've been here
this whole time that's amazing thank you
thank you
light lit fuse gd the ending with the
homemade suit gave me spider-man ps4
vibes absolutely super excited for the
future love your content can't believe
this film is real thank you so much that
means the world thank you i can't
believe it's real too
mike pavan any thoughts on where the
story is going to go now that peter's
alone in the world but it's finally
going to be independent with his own
apartment and suit i think we're really
going to get some like spider-man 2
vibes of him really struggling it'd be
interesting if he became a photographer
for the daily bugle which seems like the
last place you'd like
before it was like yeah i'll take photos
but you know like now i'm like would you
really go to the daily bugle now to be a
photographer something just so salacious
and so
such a pivotal part of like slandering
spider-man before maybe i already like
try to change it for like
i've always thought if i were to make a
spider-man movie it'd be the one that
fans really would not like it would be
like my weird darren aronofsky plot of
the of like i just want to see one
that's about spider-man and jay jonah
jameson
him really like feeling like uh this is
who he works for
and he's trying and jay jonah is
successfully tainting and destroying
spider-man
and he um you know he he wants to do
whatever he can to change the image and
he thinks all the lies and he has to
realize whether he has to what's going
on there does not matter at the daily
bugle what he's saying that that's not
the truth
and so i don't know i just seemed like a
little weird now
it would seem like especially weird if
he just starts taking photos for the
daily bugle
at this point here yeah i think it would
be a little odd although i can see them
using that route of like well i get the
best pictures of spider-man you need
pictures of spider-man this is a good
cover
uh but yeah given
it seems like it would be very
emotionally painful for tom holland's
peter parker to do that anytime soon
because of just how much j jonah jameson
had to do with [ __ ] up his entire
life yeah
adam featherston
can we appreciate that albeit for only
about five seconds there is a fight
between doctor strange and the green
goblin where else has that mashup
happened can we also appreciate that
there was like five seconds of goblin
versing doc ock and apparently goblin
would have won in five seconds
[Laughter]
you know that's all it takes
what a short-lived fight
yeah
the whole spider-man 2 movie dedicated
to this
yeah gobbling around spider-man would
have been a short filmmaker's ass right
away that's right let's just slice those
tentacles in half spiderman [ __ ] oh yeah
greg
robertson
what are your thoughts on toby and
andrew in secret wars not gonna happen
no also surprised there is no mention of
mcu peter's uncle ben and no way home
thought may would be buried next to him
at the end of the same grave it is
fascinating how this live stream has
taken a turn from all about amaze of
andrew garfield
to now all about where's uncle ben
yeah
you know
it's on that suitcase that's all you
need to know that's all you need to know
no i don't think they're gonna be in
secret wars hell no definitely no
scrolls dave lopez no scrolls in there
dave lopez how [ __ ] it would it be if
you found out that they were they were
scrolling all the time no
dave lopez you think that we could see a
sinister six down the line with venom
more i think this is the plan morbius or
being vulture craving i don't know about
rhino also merry christmas although
rhino was easily the the one you can
make out the best yeah there's a rhino
there's something that looks like a
craving i saw i thought i saw one that
looked like a vulture that was more like
you know biologically vultured
i'm pretty sure i saw the whole x-men
wolverine claws uh-huh cyclops blasting
his laser and spider-man yeah yeah [ __ ]
this guy it's like a whole x-men fight
scene in one of those ways
yeah and then galactus was inside of one
of them and the fantastic four was in
another one
crazy t-man i got your name random miles
in case we uh we're gonna go through it
at the end crazy t-man would you compare
andrew garfield redemption in this film
to thor to redemption
in uh avengers end game
no no this is way better than that no
what
no
i no no i wouldn't say that
i don't i don't feel like this is a
redemption
for him i'm like
it's more of like hey we finally
appreciate him
yeah but it wasn't like you finally made
him good or some [ __ ] yeah yeah it's not
like you took something that was
objectively bad and polished it or
something you know
a fault of the future i love that this
was basically a prequel to trilogy to
tom's origin if they do have oscorp in
future films it would be so cool if
peter's knowledge
um
what
oh oh it would infuse that if peter went
uh retaining the knowledge like what we
were saying yeah yeah
uh yeah i didn't think it was cool like
it really dawned on me in that moment in
the last 10 minutes like this is this is
like a hidden origin tale like a unique
one and i thought that was like such a
brilliant way of doing it or here's the
other thing i was thinking was that the
writers and john watts heard all the
complaints about iron man junior and
were like we needed changes
that's also it and it worked in their
favor to make it seem like they had a
flawless trilogy
uh jack zero uh jacko3770
wow you were in the avengers what is
that
that was a great line
that is among my favorite like
oh the avengers oh they don't exist yeah
what is that
yeah and the and and yeah a good little
uh universal multiversal confirmation
there i actually really like the the
when he screams like how does this
matter
yeah how's any of this helping yeah with
this helmet yeah
vault of the future's back or uh of
willem dafoe's green goblin to prevent
the new norman from ever becoming green
goblin then they could have a cool
father-son dynamic from there oh is this
a continuation from here
uh it would be so cool if peter's
knowledge of willem dafoe's green goblin
could prevent the new norman osborne
from ever becoming green goblin then
they could have a cool father's son
dynamic from there that's very true that
would be interesting i feel like if you
have normal magazine that's all i want
that's that's awesome
that's all we need
almighty ninja thank you for the moment
of silence
riboto
studios
i became bitter
rachel i don't want you to end up like
me that's freaking foreboding i'd love
to see a tasm three with a not so
friendly neighborhood spiderman imagine
a spiderman hallway scene one take see i
think now people will be down for a dark
spider-man movie
at the time they just were now ready to
accept the take and that's i feel like
that's part of why the first two in the
homecoming trilogy are so light
generally like just the the permeating
tone underneath it although even though
there are hard moments get up spider-man
like the general tone feels light and it
feels like that was a response to the
previous tone yeah
never would miss anisa
all right in your opinion do you agree
with the ranking the peters gave
themselves no movie i do not also love
and miss you guys so proud of y'all i
always love you no i i think uh i i
would put
andrew
i don't know yet i i need to think about
it but i i still think andrew's my
favorite that's all i'll say i haven't
decided where i'd put toby or tom
[Laughter]
a really crazy journey for me to go from
toby number one easily no problem no
prob and then re-watching the mingo
toby's number three
i need to i need to think about it
anything about a little more not yet
right love and miss you too and he is
always in our minds and hearts thank you
i'm still jury out but i feel like i
like them still in order but that's just
me matt peter parker is matt's new legal
assistant i like the sound of that that
could be fun renee a junior thoughts on
the new suit and future tom holland
became my favorite spider-man after this
film going to see it a third time
uh new suit looks great i can't wait to
see it when it's warm practically
and i'm sure it won't even be exactly
what it looked like at the end here i'm
sure it'll be even more touched up yeah
but i'm excited to completely eliminate
the star tech around it yes absolutely
very
very just uh stitched together himself
very excited about them
dylan
schmeltzinger i went today and saw it
alone and what anti-theater and it was
perfect
garfield's facebook mj wish it would
have been a touch longer absolutely yeah
damn i can't imagine watching this movie
alone in the theater god we're on imax
yeah part of me is
i'd be very fascinated to have that
experience because part of me is like
how how would this even be without our
audience yeah
but yeah a-rods thank you for the moment
of silence momento silencio
angel batista no stan lee i wish they
could at least pay tribute to him in a
shape or form yeah yeah i feel that
digitalize him in there man yeah that's
right man just just resurrect his
resurrection just do it without without
talk they didn't pay him enough and now
put him in there michael g michael
giaccino in the chat love your channel
andrew got wrecked uh the recognition he
deserves yeah absolutely look on twitter
right now the text of the movie even
gives him some recognition that was
overdue my brother's calling me oh good
everyone's joining hello
i'm literally live streaming right now
this is the content
don't worry omar i don't need to fill it
up we're going to get there you could
invite another person that's cool we're
going to get there don't worry even yeah
who's better venomous green goblin
[Laughter]
green goblin's probably better than both
on-screen venoms right now
derek sword happy holidays guys i am in
this weird zen place
right now where i'm just like i'm never
leaving this chair and i've accepted
reality we live on these super chats now
happy holidays guys open the super chats
back up let's smile it on even more
can we just appreciate they actually
pulled off the sinister six with jks
thank you that was a thought of mine was
that the sixth villain is jk simmons
yeah
when he shows up at happy's place that's
when it really hit me he is a villain
here
and he's never felt like a villain to me
he's more of a nuisance ah here i was
like this dude's an actual villain this
time around like him showing up there
being like i got you like damn that was
uh that i i felt like he was the sixth
villain
absolutely gamer i like that
do you think there will be a doc ock
movie nope
not a chance no definitely not i'm not
gonna do that
uh wolf and tux after eddie left how did
a bit of the symbiote stay back great
question because
sony that's all i'm gonna that's how you
answer that question because sony
because sony
does things to set up things and you go
what whatever let's roll with it
whatever thwip whip that's the way you
do it people silas hey greg and john
thank you silas i've been watching your
videos since 2014. do i believe you and
this channel is arguably my favorite so
keep it up do i really believe you
because there's much better channels out
there mr beast
philip defranco
pewdiepie hot ones oh yeah
sis noir has released these the rumors
of it's amazing spider-man 3 happening
haven't heard about these rumors yet
would you all want that i really would i
don't think they should call it the
amazing spider-man 3 i think that might
confuse people the dark and brooding
spider-man
yeah
they should call it spider amazing
spiderman redemption uh sure
might as well go for that that would be
cool i heard the next villain is a big
wheel
that's [ __ ] funny
that is [ __ ] funny uh
i appreciate that
yeah no we will want it mr go big go
home you know what's sad i was waiting
for soundtrack 19. oh
man those music cues you missed some of
those music cues with a screaming crowd
shut the [ __ ] up i'm trying to hear
michael giaccino's hard work stop stop
and can we get the dialogue mix lower
too
i wish characters wouldn't talk over the
music that was me in there
they didn't you know they did not hold
for applause breaks in those that's what
i liked about it
oh yeah yeah they just start talking i'm
like what are they saying everyone's
sharing
the second time we saw it when the
smaller screening it was it was like oh
good now i can hear all the lines that
were drowned out by screaming hey man we
did a fight we did a nearly six hour
stream for the trailer
this is nothing we're going 10 hours
today we're going 10 hours and skipping
our matrix screening yeah
we haven't been looking forward to that
for years yeah and i'm not also worried
about how people are responding to that
movie
gotcha
morgan morrow
i haven't i have this feeling that tom
spider-man hasn't fully dealt with his
anger after everything no he did holy he
got over it fast he processes things
quicker than an average human that's
what makes him super heroic he can heal
emotional trauma fast too yeah it's part
of the spider abilities uh spiders are
known for that or you think his next
villain will get that anger i think his
next phone's gonna get that anger hence
the symbiote staying behind it's gonna
amplify all that negative dark energy
within him
and that's where the coming of jesus
moment's going to be you know what i
mean yeah that's why i think they left
it behind it they have a great setup for
it i feel like it'd be a [ __ ]
disappointment if they don't do it yeah
uh johnny hustle is there any truth to
the amazing spider-man 3 discussion
rumors i mean if daniel rpk is saying
and it's gotta be there's gotta be
something to that and i'll [ __ ] say
it man like i ended up watching his uh
his daredevil breakdown scene that came
out weeks before this movie came out i'm
like
that is almost exactly what happened in
this movie yeah he's almost actually
exactly what happened he's got actual
connects it's more fun going back when
you're like what did they say about this
like holy [ __ ] they got this right they
predicted it brendan you're wrong we
read it we did read it i remember your
complicated ass last name we did read it
go through the minefield and try to find
it but i know for a fact we read your
life read yeah we've definitely read
foreign
i read your last name i was trying to
get down properly
bashy what if ned ended up learning more
magic and became a sorcerer style hop
goblin
probably i mean it is a bit of a setup
for that i guess so yeah but i hope they
still keep him hilarious
he's the funniest villain we've ever had
a rods thanks for the moment of silence
did you go down
no i went up totally okay with me my
only issue with this film from matteo
diavino is that goblin and toby never
had a real rematch yes i mean i didn't
feel like they needed a rematch but at
least a scene kind of wish in fact you
know it might have been okay if toby is
the one who
you know gave him the little
snickerdoodle here
but then again i would have undercut the
moment of the redemption of the ark for
him you know and i i do find it kind of
funny how when he delivers the injection
he also like twists it as if he's
stabbing him for real i think maybe toby
should have been the one to hand it to
him yeah yeah
um kind of wish god made won five scene
against all three in his new suit once i
think it for the storytelling purposes
it works great this way you know you
can't make it
it's
the big they make the movie what it is
but it's still tom holland's journey and
i felt like because they killed off his
ant-may it works really well yeah
because they still have their old-ass
animes
that's right peter lost his hot young
anime man
benjamin
button toby told tom thank you for the
super chat that his best friend died in
his arms after trying to kill him ned
promised i'll never happen but he still
has a portal ring and doesn't know peter
ned villain turned soon
i mean i don't see the ned villain
what does that do to ned's magic that's
a good question because i don't see the
villain turn coming sooner just because
like he's just a normal guy now
without all of his spider-man
experiences maybe he finds doctor
strange i mean the the thing about the
magic runs in his family that's the
thing that the family said so this is
not something that he has only made
privy to recently he was aware about
this yeah but but john mcu is
impenetrable please stop okay fair
enough that's right that's fair i
shouldn't ramble for too long i can't
question him
or lord feige knows all this also
straw hat prime hey guys i enjoyed the
movie since daredevil and deadpool are
now in the mcu you think we're getting a
team
team red movie team up i would love that
that would be awesome to do it do it
they said the first appearance of
deadpool will be in
doctor strange too so daredevil and
deadpool do not line up at all tonally
it would be [ __ ] weird and i would
love it i think it would actually work
for a strange reason and throw andrew
spider-man in with them mm-hmm josh wren
spider-man's ensued as a combination oh
my gosh this is like the third time
you've mentioned this
thank you
keep mentioning it
everyone keep mentioning it the
combination of it yes that is amazing uh
i appreciate that joshua and i'll never
forget it now i'm gonna be really on the
lookout for that a broads thank you for
the super chat you guys think mj and ned
remember far from home and homecoming
but would know peter but with spidey
around like wow what a coincidence
spider-man is always around us yeah they
just have very selective memory of it
all mm-hmm i remember spider-man with
the mask on but now with the mask off
i remember helping out spider-man
i don't know who that guy is though yeah
i don't know why i helped him either
no it creates the muddy territory and
you know what's best they're not gonna
answer it properly they don't have that
that's the beautiful thing about the mcu
they don't have to talk about it
miles sloane wouldn't it be cool for
spider-man 4 to be a cravenless
hunter-inspired movie also love the
channel well now with the fact that he
is ground level like pure ground level
like just spider webs
power abilities but no stark [ __ ] it
would make for a perfect matchup for
craven the hunter versus in spider-man i
think it would be like a perfect time
for it absolutely so yeah i would love
that miles sloane miles sloane we got
your question don't say we did it don't
say we didn't we're on the list thank
you miles sloane love you too guillermo
navarro connie t connor
she saw spider-man with us what and she
is just a beautiful woman
i watched the movie two more times and
i'm still a wreck man she cried like a
mofo though much more quiet with my
emotions have a great holiday buddies
i'm lucky to know you both lucky to know
you we are the lucky ones we are the
luckiest you are the unlucky one yeah
really appreciate deal with us
hottest mom soon to be in the future
rom-com matteo diavino we've all seen
origin movies but they made an origin
trilogy and now knowing now that's what
it is made me appreciate the trilogy way
more
definitely because spider-man homecoming
and far from home we're closer
especially far from home we're closer
damn you knew rock stars are going live
at the same time you know you're way
bigger than us and you're going to steal
everyone could you damn you knew rock
stars i only just got my epic hero
shirts
i love those shirts they are great i
have worn that no way home shirts in so
many videos i'm gonna buy more shirts
just just of my own accord god
uh yeah we're rocking hawkeye for the
hawkeye finale tomorrow too so thank you
um thank you if we didn't have to rush
to a matrix screening we would spend the
next 10 minutes riffing to you guys oh
my god
thank you rockstars
um
but yeah no i i was far from home is
closer to the bottom of my list and i
would also say homecoming is probably in
the
not like bottom but they're not not
definitely top uh and it retroactively
made those a lot better so yeah thank
you
uh tj3 i tried to watch homecoming
yesterday and that short documentary
peter made broke me because i'm just
like man this kid has no idea what being
a hero will cost him in the future yeah
yeah ain't that the truth
ain't that the truth ain't that the
truth that's the truth that's the
[ __ ] truth dude dude that's the truth
we found the truth
i wonder what it would be like to go
back and watch that stuff you know
dude epic hero shop best shirts in the
world seriously they i always get
compliments on them did you get that
shirt dude and then i
pulled it up on a website i'm like i
have to go and the internet's not
working i'm sorry
i got i was wearing the rogers one just
yesterday and that is the most i have
had people point out my shirt in the
same day like four or five people were
like what is that shirt that's an
awesome shirt yeah the no way home one
people are like is that official merch
i'm like no the channel heavy spoilers
produces them yes
mclaren
i tried to watch homecoming oh yes
aneurysm fun back at it what do you guys
think of ned's comment about not
betraying peter and then free guys look
i'm looking at the time and i'm really
concerned we're going to miss our matrix
screening so we're going to have to go
through this a little bit quicker and
quicker than we normally have been uh
earlier and i'm sorry to do that to you
guys because you guys contribute here
and i [ __ ] hate being like we're
rushing and but we are probably going to
have to answer these a little bit
quicker because we don't want to skip
over anyone
uh what do you guys think of ned's
comment about not betraying peter and
then forgetting about him being a setup
for a hop goblin movie i'm certain that
those plans are there
jacob battle on has alluded to him
himself and i completely do think that
they will make him like they've set it
up and like especially with that with
the um magical side of uh sorry for a
few hours especially with the magical
side of it uh yeah i think it's totally
gonna happen it's what jacob battle on
desires and uh i i think it would be
perfect and what he desires he gets and
it would be more heartbreaking where
it's like you have magic abilities cool
and then to have it turn into something
sinister would be awesome
uh t06y let's say disney sun beef wasn't
a thing sony beef wasn't a thing i would
love to see a disney plus series of
andrew stopping pulling the punches uh
life and it's rated 15. uh
okay i get what you're saying 15's like
are in the uk right yeah i guess you're
saying yeah uh yeah we're like a more
r-rated show of andrew garfield and
spider-man i mean it would be cool to
see a really dark version of spider-man
no symbiote required
and if there's any want to do it it
would be the andrew garfield franchise
would be the one that has to pull it off
man that's right
uh and spider-man blue with andrew
sounds great man thanks toby uh michael
mack these live streams live streams
always give me podcast vibes which i
think it would be you guys would be
great at uh ever consider it i'd listen
maybe we've thought about doing
podcasting but uh at the same time we we
haven't really thought about doing
podcasts
still on a high from seeing no way home
love will of andy and tom's performance
those are the top performances of the
day for sure
um thank you michael mack ej menchaca i
can get trials i get trials and take
months but didn't go to trial how big of
a time jump was the start of the movie
to the end why did peter wait that long
to see mj ned started of a movie with
summer and n was xmas
that's a fair question you know but i
imagine that they assigned him something
you would think too that would having
happy in your corner you could probably
hire a better lawyer than matt murdock
yeah why is happy at the table being
like wait wait wait i need to layer up
what's going on unless nelson and
murdock really did uh grow a lot in
popularity uh and in terms of a clout
over the years you know
um
but i don't know the time jump seemed
like six months at least ellie in in the
and the next spidey team up let's have
miles toby andrew and tom say hey i'm
tom holland i play spiderman sure
amazing movie finally full uh sold on
pete and mj's deep relationship making
the end heart wrenching but if this
takes place immediately after far from
home post credit scene hadn't they only
been dating for days well there's now
they love each other there's been a time
jump probably from pope's credit scene
to
i mean probably from their trip back
from europe
to
that scene there
you know what the [ __ ] i'm trying to
tell you yeah you know what i'm trying
to say right they had some time after
the trip yeah that's what i'm trying to
say for getting back out here that's
what i'm trying to say you guys get it
we're still here jonas yeah we're still
here trust me you're not the one dealing
with the pressure don't worry
i'm [ __ ] screening it
go john hey real quick
i'm a big fan you guys are killing it on
youtube do you think daredevil will have
an appearance in the next episode of
hawkeye
cox here's my feelings on that i kind of
hope not only because i think that would
take away the spotlight from
jeremy renner and haley seinfeld same
time if it's there i'm going to be
really excited
um the other thing it might be cool if
they give an illusion alluding to like
us one that we haven't heard about like
a jessica jones
ah yeah or lure luke cage anyone but
teddy randy
thank you travis novak for the moment of
silencio
prime sports cards love all your videos
why did wanda in doctor strange trailer
have no sukovian accent have a merry
christmas and a happy new year because
it's really up and down with her
performance and the more in touch she is
with her like the roots of her character
depending on the emotionality of a scene
is when her sakovian accent really comes
through i think it is more of a specific
character choice than usual
um kevin do you know the person in the
mocap suit is that john campbell
mentioned i'm not talked to john campy
about it i would
reckon it's probably rhino because that
there seemed to be a lot of uh things
about rumors and speculation about him
showing up here you do see through the
multiverse like the one that was the
clearest to make out was rhino like
that's the one i think everyone could
can notice so i'd imagine that it was
probably a rhino of who he's referring
to
you know
abstract media i will say after watching
the amazing spider-man 2 elektra's
personality was a lot more confident
after that fight in times square he
didn't seem as timid
after that uh it's still too big of a
drastic change in terms of choice of
language dialogue to me it just
he just seemed way too cool for school
for me to to have such a leap and and it
was very obvious when you watch like
interviews that jamie foxx seemed to not
like what happened
to
uh curtis mason we're just trying to
honor here thank you buddy uh well it
just seemed to be like too big of a leap
where it just didn't feel like max at
all
you know and uh especially when it when
you look at the trajectory of the
amazing spider-man 2 it doesn't span a
lot of time with max yeah i think
so
uh yeah like i i would i feel like it
should have been um
yeah i think it's too big of a leap of
like he's just way too different and
that seemed to have lost all
he's a really smart nerdy guy you know
he seems like he came back as the
fantasy version of himself yeah mark
mccowan how many times how many of these
events do you think we connected or
happened simultaneously peter strange
botching the spell wanda becoming the
scarlet witch he who remains crossing
the threshold
uh that's a very fascinating question
because i feel like it's kind of bizarre
as [ __ ] to me that nothing about loki
has been brought up at all so i'm like
where does loki take place you know what
i mean like like where does loki take
place in this timeline
uh so because i i really think by this
point
loki should have been acknowledged so is
it multiverse of madness is it ant-man
quantomania when it finally gets
acknowledged if so you chose a weird
time to release loki yeah they do that
only to explain this whole thing with
variance and time time so that way when
this question comes up about like what
happens to the villains of spider-man so
i'm just like well okay what's happening
here you know what's happening here yeah
daisy rodriguez never vacation that's
what i say you are a sweetheart thank
you my dear back to the super chat will
say compared to mary jane and gwen mj is
the best love interest because she uses
science to help from afar you're not
rolling your eyes because she tries to
directly interact with enemies
that's a very good point um i did like
the inclusion though of gwen
using a lot of her science knowledge to
help out peter like with the cure
towards lizard how to take down electro
like i really enjoyed those aspects of
gwen and justifying the necessity of
kind of keeping her in the around the
fight
uh but mj i i really like i did not
really care for zendaya in homecoming
she wasn't really the focus it was liz
far from home i was more like i liked
her chemistry but where the [ __ ] did
this come from and but in this one i
really bought it a lot and you make a
really solid point john you take the
next one all right alpaca nation 87 i
hope the stars align and garfield gets
the third movie he
deserves a lot of people are on your
train get that patish going
tag it skyler hillman thank you so much
i would like to see them wait for mj and
ned to remember peter maybe in the fifth
or sixth film to make uh the moment when
mj and ned remember it's more special i
agree i think leaving some time and
letting that uh choice and that
sacrifice really build and be real and
give us enough time to feel it i think
that's
absolutely the right way to go and uh i
hope that yeah they reconnect somehow
down the line uh omar ovo we finally got
to ya
dude after no way home they have to give
toby a proper send-off movie and have
andrew and tom still be spider-man
similar to what dc are doing with
pattinson and ben affleck
i mean i don't i can't see them
necessarily doing a whole movie
uh and i can see it being more likely
that andrew garfield will reprise the
role sooner or again as opposed to toby
maguire but yeah i mean i would love to
uh have them kind of i feel like no way
home in some ways does give sort of a
closure to toby's but i would be happy
to see either of them again
uh olivia d14 is back timothy chalamet
for harry osborne please this is the
number one harry osborn related thing i
have been seeing this week keep your
friends close keep your enemies closer
he watched dune that tom holland and he
said
ah man i kind of worry that's guys
coming from my career
man oh no coming from my career are you
forgetting that they're dating in real
life i know i know
they're all dating it's attracting me
for your week or punchline oh sorry
weaker
in the multiverse it was a great
punchline no we're just not on no
universe
how many of the outcomes do i have a
good joke
eric wilhelm
can't believe it in barry may with uncle
ben people seem really pissed off about
this
i mean if you had only seen the
spider-man homecoming and then again if
you got to know my home and and all
you've seen is homecoming and and far
from home you probably wouldn't
appreciate no way home because you would
have
that's kind of the weird part right
because you're like well what the [ __ ]
uncle ben you're like but he's not even
brought up in the homecoming trilogy but
then again the no way home movie only
works if you've really seen the other
one the suitcase yeah
i understand the feeling on that
wellington t
hear me out
since venom was left behind at the
post-credits scene he still has all the
info he heard about tom's universe
before eddie was sent back
venom is the only one that knows peter
parker
uh
he must have forgotten they sent him
back yeah multiversal hive mind but but
yeah i mean it seems like it would apply
he said spider-man he didn't say peter
parker yeah true that
uh all right i think they were just
showing what was happening with him in
that moment you know mm-hmm
so i mean he was the sixth member right
he just wasn't in the fight
venom yeah i guess
i mean he was he got
semi kind of villain who gets yeah
sucked in
a thorn
guyara
keep it up you guy real reject nations
with your power come the best responses
or responsibility what a fun comment
thank you everybody thank you i hope
you're doing well out there thank you
for the love navinda ali couldn't tom
have asked strange to make everyone
forget mysterio at the beginning of the
film
yeah
that would have solved a lot of problems
so who did spiderman he i guess there's
there was just nobody so he's fine
yeah
that would work
every you know there's a multiverse of
different versions of the spell so
that's actually a good call ghost chaos
to be honest i thought the green goblin
was going to revert doc hawk back to his
evil form uh i thought it was going to
be spider-man and venom versus the
sinister citrus that would have been
great for toby in this new form of venom
uh maybe i i don't i think i i think
keeping it you have to keep this peter
parker focused that's gonna be
spider-man focuses on the movie it comes
about spider-man and venom and i'm like
nah leave that for a different movie
that i really think that would have
distracted and not have had the
emotional impact they needed to have
that's what's so great about the three
of them coming together is that it keeps
it about peter parker themes and
struggles you know what i mean
absolutely brian mchenry thank you for
the little sticker
it's a cute little
thingy it's a little christmas tree or a
train okay quite though
uh frank dx or frank dix
all i gotta say is tom has my blessing
now he became spider-man at the end also
defoe was 100 my guy was given peter
suplex during their first fight
that's right that's a good point man
he's giving it hard
and long
and painfully david
uh
y'all think sony had something to do
with thomas hayden church being sand the
whole movie and the re-shot or so uh and
they reshot or something else so i have
to send a message to people meeting up
with i don't know if it would be that
like they did something silly or shady
or whatever to keep him in that form but
yeah it seems like there would have had
to have been some kind of conflict and
now i'm sitting here thinking like did
they just reuse his footage from
spider-man 3 for his human moments
because i saw somebody say something
about reusing it look like it because it
doesn't [ __ ] talk at all yeah so uh
and it looked weird yeah
yeah it sounded like his voice for sure
but i don't know
uh pierre jones
when strange separates peter's body
during their battle do you believe in
the possibility that wanda may have
interfered in some way and uh as tries
to get as peter tries to get back into
his body no no i don't believe that at
all i don't think she's aware of that
one is like totally out of the loop on
this whole situation she's picking
fruits right now and pruning trees
abstract media i hope they treat the
memories like they do in the comments
where it's like whenever peter's dressed
as spider-man and unmasked himself in
front of and from someone who knew the
memories of him come back
oh interesting but that would be a very
easy solution for yeah but then he would
have to it would ride on the mask
completely because seeing him should
have done that for mj and ned no yeah
yeah you know he would have unless it is
only gonna work if he has the mask on
and then takes it off yeah yeah the
count 209 toby stole the movie
garfield's uncle ben never said with
prairie power grove's great
responsibility that's true so i hate how
he was trying to fit in with toby but he
got the thesis he got the idea he was
able to boil it down in his mind from
the paraphrasing that his uncle did of
his dad
jake glows up uh did y'all notice when
strange says he doesn't have the time
stone he's not wearing the necklace then
in the next scenes he is wearing it
continuity error that eye of agamotto
i'm able to able to make it appear kind
of thing yeah maybe i totally think mr
negative should be in the next one
or across the spider verse whichever one
dimitri key
curiously if you guys recognize that
peter at the end of the movie is
becoming like peter in the ps4 game with
him being broke and alone yeah and in
college it's very much like the ps4 game
john wouldn't know i would i've played
all of it
david gandy gando
hey david
big dick david big dick day merry
christmas do you think ned's new power
reveal we followed up or forgotten late
to the chat sorry i've asked disgust
uh i think it will be followed up on in
the next one he's going to be the new
james franco [ __ ] fill them up over time
you knew this was coming pete you knew
this coffee doesn't want him to say that
that's the fan service i am hoping for
it's navig dev
why isn't dr otto octavia such a big
deal in the new movie he's in the
posters and everything
he had the greatest entrance of them all
yes the most grand entrance and one of
the best fights
but yeah he does like
progressively become not as interesting
yeah as it is he undergoes a subversion
which i appreciate but then
yeah he is kind of like angry yeah yeah
yeah totally ozzy beats unpopular
opinion the russo brothers ruined tom
holland spidey john watts tried to fix
the iron man junior problem through his
trilogy [ __ ] the russo [ __ ] them what
have they ever done for us how they've
ruined him
by having him show up and give him and
having to have an iron man give him a
suit
and then yeah having him hug iron man
later on
uh oj did every random dude that happens
to be named peter parker gets zapped in
and out of his universe no no no no no
no just our tom holland
make that pretty clear just tommy
it would have been a real dick move of
tom holland to be like hey guys sending
you back uh should i tell them that
people are going to forget them no i'll
just hug them
you know it's better if they don't know
then they'll never have known the nerd
good dude omni i was just reading your
text message uh when the theme plays in
the toby and doc moment beautiful part
man gorgeous
don't yawn i have gone almost five hours
without yawning
did you edit the new rock stars
for the team plays in the toby and doc
moments
satyas
keep up the great work fellas love your
sense of humor and personalities
i love john's sense of humor and
personalities but
i don't like
his his looks it takes away the
attention from me
kind of want to do like a lucy and ethel
thing uh-huh
that's how i'm going to review
everything is going to through being the
ricardo's oh we're going to make you
look uglier to make me look better okay
yeah
sure yeah based in fact
uh i like your looks just not your
personality chase gardner
what if the next hey chase what's the
sony mcu marvel spider-man movie for
venom symbiote we'll go to miles ross
and that's when we see miles moroso the
first time with actual venom powers but
him being a villain i don't think he's
going to be a villain i
don't want to do that i think that would
rile people up a little bit maybe a
little [ __ ] up to make a black little
spider-man live action he's a bad guy
spider-man is black of course yeah you
guys be like oh people are too sensitive
well yeah people are sensitive and be
they will be justifiably sensitive in
the moment so no don't do that yeah
aaron mcintosh i love the dynamic with
all three spider-man 10 out of 10. i
agree mofo give me the guy who picks up
pictures of spider-man
benji yogg
don't know if you spoke about this but
why does spider-man a sandman just turn
all evil all of a sudden with no
explanation only issue with the film
loving the content i think there is a
weird muddied ha ha
ah yes mud is made of sand muddy
motivation when it comes to sandman yeah
i mean i get it that he's sandman and
lizard feel like out of an animated car
like a cartoon yeah they do like not
just their look but like the writing of
them feels like a cartoon
yeah
so like i'm back to being bad
yeah i mean it's like he doesn't really
trust anybody and i kind of buy that
like i think he's got to shred more
character explanation motivation than
like the lizard but yeah it's pretty
thin he's like salmon just wants to go
back so he's so you can just touch the
box and that's simple yeah sheldon
stilton hickman so much i want to say
about this my favorite thing was the
ending thoughts on the future of tom
spider-man i hope he gets star tech next
next time
i hope he just gets an instant start
tech and gets pim technology so he can
shriek and grow large too he falls into
a vat of nano machines that gets the
iron spider right back
matt
peter parker loves that mary jane
oh that was a good this was worth it for
a good weed joke right here he does love
that mary jane i got it i'm really late
to understanding that joke no i have to
literally point out we joked to be like
why is john laughing you know who loves
it more than peter though is uh franco
osborne london peter and mj are cute and
tragic as sweethearts but the only uh
but the next trilogy starts with peter
in love with a girl that doesn't know he
exists like the other movies i know
right there's a reason why they brought
back the other ones to be like we're
going to kind of do more of what those
other movies did
i mean i kind of am here for this yeah
i'm like give me the spider-man 2 style
spider-man 4 it'll be conflicting for
him because it's like she seems better
without him but she he loves her so he
wants to be selfish
then she doesn't see him dating someone
else yeah
it's going to be [ __ ] flash thompson
[ __ ] flash thompson
tom holland spider-man is going to date
flash thompson yeah
zero do you think the next spider-man
film will be more grounded and smaller
scaled compared to the past mcu films
it'll start that way then get
obnoxiously big in the last half uh luis
fleet hi guys love your work watching in
new zealand in order name best actor to
worst actor performance out of all the
main and side characters of this movie
whoa jesus [ __ ] christ damn dude all
right tom holland um and then willem
dafoe andrew garfield
uh
zendaya
toby mcguire
dr strange uh cumberbatch uh alfred
molina
[Music]
mcrae2000 uh i would love to know your
thoughts on if they work advise us
later i'm okay with you unsubscribing i
hate that you are live streaming for so
long do another uh
i would love to know your thoughts on if
they were to do another live-action
spider-verse movie what direction would
you want them to take with it
spider-verse but live-action i would
just like to see alternate
versions just more spider-man no like
they they brought in other ones but it'd
be more fun to kind of do like what into
the spider-verse did where you see just
different versions of these portrayals
like those the first portrayals of a lot
of these people and it would be fun to
see alternate versions of like another
doc awk or something like like i thought
like bringing lady lockhawk or king but
like into the spider verse did an
amazing job at like doing that so it'd
be fun to see like all live action
alternate versions um yeah you guys
stream for so long it's the only thing
my notification about
nothing else is showing up on my youtube
i love that
ben reilly thank you for the generous
contribution this mo movie was a literal
love letter to the fan a love letter of
all the movies that get slapped with
that i feel like this is a love letter
uh it made me proud i literally got
exactly what uh
i i got
exactly why i can and how i had canon
not a moment wasted i must have seen the
spider-man one as a kid a thousand times
andrew and toby got their deserved love
absolutely man i'm glad i made you as
happy as a magic dude
yeah glad you i'm glad you got your head
cannon realized
levi did anyone notice that wong's don't
cast that spell trailer line was missing
from the movie we were just talking
about this i thought it was an alternate
take but then they played it again and
the doctor strange in the doctor strange
trailer
interesting there you go
that's a little multiversal future grab
right there
uh and yeah that scene plays a little
bit better from the actual movie version
uh senera riven
does norman osborne exist in the mcu uh
it doesn't seem that way when raymie
osborne arrived in the mcu he tried to
look himself up and didn't find his mcu
version or was he lying i think he was
telling the truth i'm pretty sure he was
telling the truth yeah
i believed him when he was saying that
that's what made him really compelling i
believe norman osborne yeah justice for
osborne
17 the goat you think the murder poster
of the murderer poster of spider-man in
the morbius trailer could be a reference
to andrew who said he stopped pulling
his punches i think he could be the sony
verse i did now
but see that makes that [ __ ] so
confusing because it's [ __ ] toby
mcguire's teams mcgee from the video
game
yeah this is weird this is all weird it
would that would make so much more sense
right if it was andrew what if we watch
the movie and it ends up being like oh
it is andrew garfield's sure like they
can digitally change that then that
would make you make so much more sense
right yeah and it's a small detail they
could easily have altered that or you
know did it as an easter egg for this
movie you fully knowing they'll change
all right that would be so much that
would make more sense yeah and as you've
seen marvel and sony you could just
digitalize [ __ ] out to hide stuff oh
yeah
california governor ryan newsom i don't
know if you caught the easter egg when
the doctor strange and spider-man fought
at the booth
earlier yeah about the liz and the
people magazine cover yeah yeah we uh
new rockstars pointed that out to us
that's really cool to learn right to see
that she actually ended up having a
pretty successful career she's on the
[ __ ] front cover of people magazine
yeah talking [ __ ] about panda man was
there man yeah just talking [ __ ] about
peter on magazines bj grace7 do you
think toby andrews spider-man asked why
are they adding a shield on the statue
of liberty it's funny that they don't
question it like what does that shield
mean yeah they don't have an avengers
but they got they do that
yeah
not a p
so clearly fury's three-year absence
from earth has to do with secret wars
where do you think he is he's in space
he's in space he made that abundantly
clear he's in space with the scrolls
working he's on that ship pairing
himself for secret wars yeah he's just
gay he's just reading his lines for the
show the neuro revenge hey we made it to
you
hey hey hey i think they should make
andrew garfield's peter into the scarlet
spider and ben reilly in the mcu what do
you think of that i think drawing on
inspiration from that will be absolutely
perfect if you are suggesting that they
can they change him to that yeah i don't
know about that but drawing inspiration
uh not a bad call at all uh i think what
a lot of people want to see is that
darker version that was alluded to in
the in no way home so yeah i absolutely
think that would be really cool why the
[ __ ] not hell's yeah daniel i agree
andrew crack and toby's back was
hilarious it was amazeballs if you ask
me i want to back crack right now de la
soul did you notice how tom holland's
new suit has toby maguire spider on the
front andrew's on the back also you're
the first amazing shout out thank you so
much dale assault first person tonight
absolutely sladro what universe do you
think venom and morbius are from i say
andrews i say its own thing entirely not
secret war secret invasion so sorry
five-hour livestream yeah um yeah i
think it's um uh i i would say that it
is a brand new universe because it's not
making any [ __ ] sense it's a weird
amalgam it's not making any sense at the
moment yep brendan
christine yuck uh you were we're back uh
what would be cool is if y'all did a
live stream and the chat along with you
guys made it a t i made a tier list uh
that would be fun and interactive that
would be cool that would be cool if we
could find a way to to
yeah have that graphic and be able to do
it in real time for sure that would be
awesome
if we spoil everything it's ridiculous
according to pablo the pigeon yeah and
these [ __ ] spoilers
for the reviews why the [ __ ]
later than most people are going to a
lot about they must be going to a lot of
people
they must be being forced to watch this
right now
jamie connolly you guys are the best all
the love from ireland brendan would love
for you to be in a live stream one day
jamie connelly
you guys are the best
oh the love from ireland is high oh
yearling i'm spider-man
i'm the [ __ ] spider-man
jamie dornan is spider-man next jamie
dornan spider-man or or eddie brock i'm
calling it j-lose that's a [ __ ] rhino
over there that's a [ __ ] i fought an
alien from [ __ ] space
made a black [ __ ] goo
uh do you guys think they are setting up
for a s for secret wars i mean
eventually but secret invasion comes
first i mean yeah
it's all about that secret invasion
uh hey it's so secret if you ask me but
um
ah they announced it forever ago and
we're anticipating it ha ha
alvin bro i thought about something the
other day what if stanley was still
alive he could have arrived through a
portal with andrew and toby i would have
loved to see that happen
and that he would have helped fight dog
hawk and would you have done that great
goblin and the lizard
lee shows up and just gets chopped in
half by one of them
with great power that's great
responsibility peter there's a message
we've been trying to get to you for
three movies now
jake
hedge tom holland came out and said he's
done playing spider-man and wants to
take a break for a female spider woman
to come in thoughts i don't believe that
i don't believe one second jake hedge
who i know isn't waiting for us to read
your super chat i'm really curious to
know what he means about that whole like
if i'm still playing spider-man by the
time i'm 30 i'll be doing something very
wrong but uh he clarified a little bit
and he's being signed up but i think uh
isn't olivia munn
is that her she's the new peter parker
no she's working on some like spider
woman movie i'm forgetting oh something
like that
i think it's a spider woman movie that
would be cool yeah be cool it'd be cool
to get a first live-action spider-woman
yeah and get somebody else to come over
from x-men to be a marvel character
sladro since spider-man freshman
olympian wilde let me be a wild oh okay
different person okay she directed that
one comedy movie with the two women so
she's the perfect fit yeah yeah yeah
definitely uh since spider so yeah no i
mean i'd be fine for that we're gonna
get so many different spider-man movies
just like every other gazillion batman's
yeah uh slader since spider-man freshman
year will be
based off pete going to college do you
think within the time span the miles
will be a freshman in high school
sure
maybe
who knows
i guess
i mean maybe yeah
we never why not we never find out how
old aaron davis nephew is so
sean mcglock a child yeah three years
old he's a baby
just born and i don't want him to get
into crime there's no way that aaron
davis could become the prowler jesus
christ you see him he's so chill
i don't know a [ __ ] problem i'm
trying to sell these weapons right here
sean mclaughlin coy hope you feel better
you're looking a bit white there but so
is sean thank you greg for bringing in
the philippine diversity that's right
you got it and don't forget that oily
italian skin yeah there you go thank you
thank you hey we brought a store she
wrote in earlier in the chat isn't that
funny yeah hey
agent josh triple 07. we never saw peter
clapping mj cheeks wow yeah that's a
very very true statement right
jesse what's up jesse
i don't know this guy yeah uh let's let
you know there's a stream lab thank you
flick and reel that means fellow quirky
merc
jesse jesse the jackal not remembering
yeah
that's a good person
and he cries earlier
it's just uh jesse i'm like
oh jesse we we got love for you here
don't we love you jess dumb hey guys are
the box office stats good so far no
they're terrible they're moving failing
and underperforming like taking they're
gonna cancel the mc [ __ ] awful man
[ __ ] awful griffith wow if tom
holland hadn't been signed on for three
more movies and freshman year wasn't
announced would you be happy with the
spider-man mcu ending like this
sure yeah i mean no i would be really
disappointed that i feel like they need
to do another spider versus crossover
with this new spider-man franchise so we
can see what happened with tom holland
everyone just forgot who he is and he's
off on his own i'm like no that's not a
conclusion this is a new chapter
beginning this is a definitive new
chapter beginning it does both it ends
something and starts something and i
would hate to not see how it goes from
here like what's his life gonna be now
that is the correct answer yeah so no i
would not have been satisfied but i
appreciate the question cinematic
goodness the movie did everything a
great spider-man story needed to be
especially love how peter really went to
a dark place in a singular hatred and
bloodlust for the goblin absolutely now
maybe you can't go that full dark in the
next spider movie but you can with
hashtag the amazing spider-man 3.
thank you cinematic goodness peter
parker's dark place
the fancy filmmaker so does this mean
the villains still die in their universe
are they now cured and just go back to
living normal lives we don't know people
have theories people really believe
these theories but we just don't know
for sure i think the fantasy the wonder
is that they would go back and live a
normal life now that they are cured but
who knows flynn marco would probably
have to go back to jail
jake hedge i did my best
i did my best
every time i think we're almost at the
top
maybe toby's universe had avengers but
they all got wiped memories like the mcu
union did because jay jonah did say
doctor strange was taken that could have
been before
wait
as in they're going back to their
timelines so that toby can start having
spider-man's movies events happen in the
future yeah
he got he got it he got youthified on
his way back
webcamschat.com is in here hell yeah
that's awesome to hear oh good i support
sex workers dude hot boys and girls it's
equal opportunity let's do this
what'd you put in the chat timeout
oh webcams yeah why because uh i don't
you
because people are gonna don't support
them i
think that all sex workers work and
uh and that's not a joke we gotta move
forward
is important and undervalued and
misunderstood african caesar they
already gave us a clue who the next
villain will be remember venom left a
piece of his symbiote before he was
taken back to his own universe yeah
you'd think so it also seemed like that
venom was in the mcu but apparently not
yeah who knows so we'll see
i think you could do a full movie with
him black suit symbol before he actually
finally had them cross over i think
spider-man would be in a venom three and
then venom in a spider-man three
spider-man four uh roberto studios i'd
like to see the amazing spider-man three
if only to see a take on a i became
bitter rachel i stopped pulling my
punches imagine a spider-man hallway
scene of terrifying
we did one with the similar sentiment
the antidote the amazing spider-man 3
but we need sam raimi's camera work if
you do a blend of both that would be
pretty sweet
pretty sweet yeah
i like that idea the antidote andy z did
you hear about the rumor marvel wanting
to bring back toby and andrew for secret
wars yes we did we acknowledge it don't
think it's gonna happen i don't think so
uh d webbs if we get the amazing
spider-man 3 i want to see craven the
hunter i think craven the hunter would
be good for even for spider-man 4
especially the fact that spot he is now
ground level
and he's getting his own movie uh
vincent moore are we gonna screening the
catch uh did you finally did you see the
final scene where tom was swinging off
the ice rink in the same place that was
in the trailer for hawkeye the
rockefeller center i think is what
you're referring to and yes we did i
still don't think they're going to cross
paths here but it's funny how this
movie's kind of bookended with two
things that remind you of what we've
seen in hawkeye so far rogers the
musical logo and the rockefeller center
ice rink where hawkeye is taking place
in the finale or at least having a
sequence too chess verden so happy we
got to see andrew save mj everyone
clapped and shared it was great it was
phenomenal it was a man friggingtastic
african caesar he has two we're gonna
read them i agree that the end credits
scene with tom hardy felt a bit tacked
on but i bet you a cameo in one of your
future videos that that was her way of
introducing venom to tom holland's
universe i meant to make that cameo bet
predicated on venom being set up to be
the villain in the next spider-man with
tom holland bet up lol
maybe i still think that we won't that
we'll see spider-man and venom three and
not venom in spider-man four i think
we're gonna get a venom three before we
get a spider-man four j rules says jim
starling was the old dude in the diner
really i recognized that i was like
that's gotta be a camera yeah at the
very end yeah just with the wig on i
thought so yeah um let's keep going all
right we're up there jojo points pinoy
pride lola
i don't want to say
how dare you jj star prod thank you for
the moment of silence and hello to you
in europe uh hey we're at the top uh i'm
lost
closing us out for at least the chats
does
does edith still know about peter it's a
computer not a person it was confiscated
so he no longer possesses it and
probably doesn't matter and they
probably had to go through some stark
legal ramifications to make sure it was
deactivated on his end in some way with
happy probably helping somehow yeah this
suit has a different voice thank you for
that super chat though different voice
on that film in the chat is that
refreshed
uh no
let's go back to the title
it was gonna have to tear down this
camera so we could bring it to the
theater yes we are
uh i mean if we are not tired honestly
i've been getting to bed like
obnoxiously late every night for the
past week and i don't want to do this to
my body anymore and plus uh my fiance i
i skipping out and going to colorado
with her this week beca to be with her
family because there's there's so much
to do uh
to wrap up that we're behind on so i'm
not gonna be able to go so i'd like to
spend some time with her tonight too uh
which it's not looking likely
but
um i'm trying so yeah i mean i'll try to
get the matrix stuff up tomorrow i'll
have to edit it uh tonight
how much do we have here
i have a slight solution in mind
in case we can't do this okay um
i knew we got one tongue punch but there
was a different tongue punch okay
no no no keep going i got this
all right so
uh there was there right there yeah so
we're talks talks okay
we'll see where we are in 10 minutes
all right talks
not about spider-man but i saw greg in
an ad before the movie hey first first
thing to bring up in the chat
um miles we did read your chat i even
said
we read your chat miles i just declared
it out loud i said it right out loud we
got your chat milestone you just weren't
listening at the time
uh but we for sure read it absolutely
100 so go back and skim yeah
not about spider-man but i saw greg in
an ad before the movie and i'm so proud
been watching off for five years now and
i'm happy to see all going places that
means a lot talks you know and it was
really all thanks to john 100
anytime i do anything people go john
i've sent a gift to someone and john got
cece in the email i love how that
happens brandon
yeah brandon yeah
guy guys i love seeing my childhood
spider-man toby again and diving into
andrews but tom's left in a place i've
wanted to see him for years i wanted to
ask him what villains for tom's next
movies would you like to see and who are
your dream casting i mean uh really what
i'm championing for is michael mando
michael amanda to return a scorpion i
feel like he's got this weird shortening
the stick and it's a [ __ ] shitty ass
position uh it really bums me out to be
honest that no one seems to be uh
fighting for it or we see articles about
it when it should happen if we do get
harry osborn i do think timothy chalamet
would actually be a fantastic choice for
harry osborne though you know
uh let's see here chai tea
that's what i drink because i don't like
coffee hi guys absolutely love your
channel and no way home as well i
appreciate how the run time for the
scooby doo in this crap was rather short
it was weird it would be that taking
about taking up majority of the time see
if there's more no
uh but no it didn't actually i thought
it took up the appropriate amount of
time and i actually really liked all
those scenes a lot of people say like
the first half like i don't know about
this it's actually kind of rushed and
not feeling bad and i really don't feel
that way when i watch it i've seen it
three times and i've never felt that it
was rushed i felt there were some things
that were underwritten with in terms of
the villains but i never felt the movie
in itself was rush i thought it was
actually paced appropriately well
all right
uh talks hello again i'm not sure if
this was already mentioned but i
wondered why venom was there because he
didn't know peter parker was spider-man
at least to my knowledge can you correct
me on that if i'm wrong he did you are
wrong at the end credit scene of the
the venom let there be carnage they
clearly show peter parker on screen with
a shot that we've never seen before and
it's crystal cut clear that it's uh it's
them
we're not going to the premiere of the
matrix we have an early screening for it
and it's about an hour away but
we'll be full see where we are in seven
minutes exactly yes i want to make sure
we answer this it's not right it's not
great i don't like i i would just feel
insanely guilty if we don't get around
to this i care more about this right now
i'm surprised no one want to call the
theater and be like hold the hold the
screen for us would you always stream
this is not the real rejects there i saw
drojas rojas in the comments and uh it
made me realize nobody's called out the
danny rojas uh cameo in that
post-credits scene
anyway moving on flev doran okay you
have a good theory as uh
answer to my and for others similar
question lol yeah loki did put that rule
uh but in loki there was also a timeline
fusing event where's that we thought
before that's the trigger for no way
home's plot would go up a little bit
more
did he continue yeah you go on we'll go
back also where are the tva agents when
all this multiverse jumping happens and
also mind wiping everybody to forget
peter isn't messing with this timeline
was that something supposed to happen my
only issue is while i loved the loki
show in isolation keep going up
i'm trying i'm
uh i don't know how much stock i can put
in because i brought me more q than a
questions than answers is what he's
trying to say nevertheless this time
travel string theories are always
difficult to deal with in movies so i
choose to focus more on the action and
not too much on the causes it can ruin
my mood i respect that a lot and uh yeah
i don't know why they haven't brought up
the loki stuff yet i guess the question
is when did the loki events occur is it
gonna be happening simultaneously the
multiverse of madness or is it gonna be
happening simultaneously to ant-man
quantomania it looks like it's probably
gonna be ant-man quantomania just the
fact that we know king's gonna
officially be in there but it just seems
like a weird time frame to have loki
that a bunch of movies in between before
those events actually are like lined up
so i don't know but time works
differently than the tva it doesn't not
all right let's go back down here sorry
but i'm glad you were able to still get
the emotional experience despite the
questions that you were having similar
for us too selma electro making that
comment about spider-man being black as
a side about making it a movie for miles
and rallis
that's why we all cheered and clapped
when it happened and it was an exciting
time toast malone
popcorn hi hope you all are well i sort
of watch an attack on titan with greg
you look like a baby
okay uh do you plan on watching another
anime after this one wraps up i love no
way home and i love the way that norman
has dentures as goblin has normal teeth
yeah good catch man that's a really good
catch
i don't have any specific plans at the
moment for another anime uh just trying
to get through the rest of the month
first and then we're done with that then
we'll go revisit our plans but uh kind
of stacked month for us they they're
releasing a lot this month you know all
the spider-man stuff of course uh which
is something we're very passionate about
and then we got matrix we're trying to
keep witcher there's there's just a lot
going on right now you know but i
haven't thought of another animated
cover yet six paths navi couldn't tom
have asked strange to make everyone
forge mystery forget mysterio at the
beginning of the film thoughts just
nimbicking we answer this i believe in
the super chats thank you and i believe
that was youtube thank you david
quinones you think sandman was sand for
lost lost of the movie because of sony
or something else
i don't know the choice i feel like they
probably digital him in but they
probably couldn't get thomas hayden
church to agree i imagine there was like
scheduling conflicts or some [ __ ] like
that so it seems like they animated him
in there and then eventually they were
able to get thomas hidden church to do
the voice then they could bring him in
that that's just kind of the
business impression that i get of what
they did with salmon in that film jesse
swift hey buddy whip thrip [ __ ] what
a ride from announcement to reactions to
the premiere cheers to one of the most
steadfast and consistent channels out
there all the love in the world jesse
one day you will surpass us and you
absolutely deserve to because you're
better at us in every single way
appreciate the compliment though go
subscribe to flick and reel captain
finland
hi love your videos why after the final
spell peter can't just go and tell
strange what happened wouldn't he
understand and believe everything even
though he doesn't remember pete and do
other avengers still remember working
with spider-man i believe they do not i
think that's actually the point of what
happens here everything is sort of
forgotten about it or something like but
i think there's going to be some
you know memory coming back for certain
characters in the next spider-man movie
that it has to be one of those spells uh
one thing boss pointed out really well
was the black dahlia necklace how that
that uh mj still had it intact meaning
that she probably in her subconscious
still has a memory of peter parker and
it's just about how do they activate
that not for everyone but for a certain
view tongue punch fart box back at it
again i can't remember the exact wording
of the spell but shouldn't peter forget
he's spider-man 2. i mean technically
that would be a [ __ ] bizarre moment
that should be their spider-man 4. he
has no identity at all
yes exactly flev doran's back uh sorry
if i derailed the mood with my ramblings
i really liked the film despite how it
uh
how it sounds lol i was the only one in
my
hall that jumped and uh
that jumped at andrew and toby's scene
cried for m for may i actually liked the
villains apart scenes uh we'll see it a
second time tomorrow i'm glad i'm glad
i'm glad there are certainly fair things
to point out also flip goes on in the
matt murdock scene i was in awe even
though i knew about the scene i
saw the leaked photo it was very short
and in the grand scheme insignificant
yet still very cool can't wait to start
the journey to doctor strange too this
was fun take care you take care of that
take care flevy thank you for all your
love and support across here patreon
everything man uh amber hello john your
dimples oh my god
uh can we ask non-spiderman questions
would you two ever switch hairstyles
greg grows his hair super greg grows out
his hair super long and john cuts his
and curls it up okay that's all have a
good day
uh
i would like to see it happen but it's
more likely to be a photoshop than the
real thing i don't i don't know if i'll
go that short ever again john doesn't
cut his hair says one most valuable
asset
flippy
hey guys i just first just want to say i
love your videos you guys are absolutely
awesome and so fun to watch and your
reactions are literally the best i don't
know have you seen blind wave and second
of all just finished had uh just
finished no way home second watch for my
birthday happy birthday and it ran
uh and it ranks at fifth in my mcu films
oh not bad fifth mcu overall i wonder
where ranks in your spider-man films
tedio wouldn't have been great of
instead of the doctor strange two
trailer for the post-credits scene it
was a clip of jamie foxx getting to a
different world where it was the world
mines more alice and jay fox would say
oh damn there is a black spider-man it
would be pretty cool if it was like an
off-screen shadow of that spider-man and
jamie foxx did say that that actually
would be pretty cool yeah that would
have been sweet if they just went into
like the live-action version of the into
the spider-verse that would be pretty
sweet i like that one a lot actually
that that was pretty dope
i'll keep that in my memory his head
again
thanks for that one that made me smile
thank you flippy floppy that doctor
strange credit scene was flipping
awesome and i swear i'm so excited for
it dr strange my third favorite mcu
movie heavily to do with the fantastic
visuals that i had oh my god multiverse
of craziness looks so cool am i right
you are right i'm also a member of the
lgbt and i don't know if any of you are
but what's your opinions on lgbt
spider-man because tom holland interview
said he would love to have a gay
spider-man or something it would be the
funniest relationship to see uh and keep
going up and one last thing i love you
guys and like i've said before i like
your reactions make the content you're
watching more enjoyable like all the
time and both are awesome i hope you
guys are doing well and yes spider-man
matrix and kingsman to go we saw
kingsman we haven't done a video about
it but here we are uh yeah i'm 100 for
seeing uh you mean the [ __ ] just make
tom holland bisexual i don't give a [ __ ]
and like do whatever you want like yeah
i wouldn't mind seeing a version of the
spider-man that is from the lgbtq
community it would be amazing to me i
fully support that 100
absolutely and uh yeah there's a lot of
movies to keep going through for sure i
myself do identify uh on the b side so
yeah i'm of course 100 for it a thousand
percent i appreciate your candor and i
appreciate your support so much flippy
luke bolton 200 hey guys big fan of your
videos how did you guys feel about the
venom credit scene do you think tom hall
and spider-man will ever be in a movie
with him now that he's back in his own
universe i think venom 3 will have
spider-man in it i don't think venom
will be in spider-man 4 if i'm being
completely frank with you guys um
so uh but that's my feelings on it i
don't think that veno i think uh the
venom post-grad scene was actually weird
and didn't totally mesh well but hey
what are you gonna do uh like
something that felt like sony made sure
that that was gonna be included in there
broccoli at the end of the movie
everyone forgets who peter parker is in
the world
what about those of off world like thor
and nick fury will they know peter
parker next time they see him i don't
think they will do that no i don't i
don't think they have the force agenda
guys i'm not saying they should force
agenda i'm saying if they ended up doing
it for sure what it's not even a big
deal if it's natural who cares
some people just think that when you say
it that means it's forced
at the end of the movie i don't have
time to get into it all right
you're gonna have a problem with it
either way that's all i'm gonna say and
at the end of the movie everyone forgets
who peter parker is in the world what
about those off world no i don't think i
think
it would undercut it if it's just like
it's only earth exclusive you know i
think it is the rest of the marvel
cinematic universe brandon do you think
the final swinging shot is set right
before the events of hawkeye no i don't
because i feel like i might undercut the
whole thing i mean actually it would be
cool if they'd alluded to that they saw
a spider guy swinging around here but i
wonder if there'll be some type of shift
where clint might talk about a spider
guy but say he doesn't know who he is
acknowledging the events of spiderman no
way home that might be pretty
interesting i think it would be funny if
when clint and kate are having the final
battle rockefeller center and peter's
just swinging about above them much love
from australia
yeah i think they would undercut hawkeye
and it'd be all about spider-man at that
moment so no i would rather you know
they don't do that
i have said like let hawkeye be hawkeye
and let those actors shine in there and
let the kingpin reveal actually amount
to something exactly
left doran i was joking on the trailer
live stream when i said i can wait for
the sixth live after the actual movie
piggybacking on a previous chat i saw
carnage imax and no time to die 3d
back-to-back empty rooms it was great
glad you had a wonderful last
experiences watching those you got to
redeem yourself i'm so happy for you
buddy
um and i hope you get to see norway home
a few more times as well mike's rambles
not sure if this has been mentioned but
did we touch on emma watson playing
spider-gwen emma watson a spider-gwen
interesting choice i feel like haley
steinfeld would be perfect but she's
already kate bishop she's already she's
already i mean she was great spider-gwen
in the in the into the spider-burst
thing but uh no i mean emma watson i
don't know about that
to be honest and i don't can't think of
anyone better at the time so sure
why not let it be emma watson i can't
see it but i'm always happy to be
surprised curtis mason random thought
what if venom and morbius take place in
andrew's world not so random we've had a
lot of people contribute that today
that's what it would be
batgare
if the japanese spider-man just showed
up at catch mj in spider-man no way home
and just used transformation first
before catching mj when falling in the
in the uh fall tower
there's a youtube like
cool don't have time to watch this
youtube league unfortunately sorry i
really do appreciate it though
another live stream maybe honor taylor
joy would actually be a great one i
appreciate this on the picture that's a
fantastic one we do have some stickers
here really appreciate those additional
stickers thank you guys uh yeah oh my
god we did it we have ten we've
maybe a few minutes to spare
ted ted talks guys
thank you so much for this this has been
a hell of a journey um
it's not done yet there's all this other
[ __ ] breaking while we were doing this
stream about amazing spider-man stuff i
appreciate everyone for the support here
for the amount of time we've been doing
this and the and for especially follow
us on the spider-man journey it seems
like there's just more [ __ ] coming out
now literally like i was on twitter i
was like oh damn like [ __ ] leaked
news about future stuff so hell yeah you
guys rock john look at the camera for
once in your life look at the camera i'm
pulling up the final stickers so we can
shout out omni media and lick knees
thank you guys so much
man he holds it all down
alrighty guys we got to get going
appreciate you very much much appreciate
much love to all you
john in the street we did it we did it
have a good week thank you guys all the
love to you in the world and we are audi
whip sweat 5000 a4 all the above and we
are ending up